the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
the world's best chess players are
putting on a show at the sink field cup
in saint louis with such an illustrious
cast you never know who will steal the
spotlight ian napomniachi made up for
his miscue in round one with a
spectacular win over st louis rapid and
blitz champ alareza for ruja hans neiman
is acting the part and proving more than
an understudy defeating chakriar mama
diara to join magnus carlson as the
co-lead the stage is set for more
jaw-dropping performances round three of
dazzling chess coming up next
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody to day three of
the sinful cup it's a beautiful day here
in st louis and the players are ready to
regale us with their play let's go to
the studio and start the action with
yasser peter and alejandro
from the home of chess in america
welcome to the singfield cup the
flagship event of the saint louis chess
club and the final stop on the 2022
grand chess tour
welcome back i'm peter svidler and with
me with me is it dwayne i'm probably not
pronouncing that right of chess
commentary
shouldn't be using foreign words all of
these words are foreign
i'm done for today peter as always a
great pleasure to have you with us in
studio your commentary is simply
outstanding hello everyone and welcome
to our show indeed two rounds of
exciting chess has brought us a surprise
in the leadership peter our current
standings absolutely
uh
it's the story of the two wild cards one
of those is not perhaps such a big big
shock at the at the top of the standings
there magnus carson on the point of the
high powder too very solidly beating a
nipple machine round one and then making
a draw yesterday but
uh hans even there up top just
absolutely bring it back and you
misunderstand exactly the standings are
gone yeah
and they're they're back and now now
they're back yeah uh and then uh a lot
of people on fifty percent right most of
them obviously with two draws but yan
nippon issue they're providing the
lion's share of their decisive games in
this tournament with two out of two so
far
and alireza and shahri are
bringing up the rear so far our format
and there we go
four one is a templar uh or round robin
with uh
the feed a time control in place of
somewhat
dynamic time control 90 minutes for the
first 40 moves 30 minutes for the rest
of the game with a 36 second increment
from move one a very established time
control by this point drawers are
never
yeah never allowed in saint louis chess
club tournaments which is a good thing
i'm pretty sure
and uh the normal scoring system uh is
being used here and our schedule peter
uh the schedule is fairly
straightforward uh we play until round
five today uh the day after uh tomorrow
day after two days i'm on forum today
i'm really really enjoying this and
tuesday round five then there's a rest
day on wednesday and four rounds in a
row uh until uh the final round uh on
september 11th and
the sinkhole cup playoffs will be played
the same evening but if there is also
playoffs required for the gct points for
the final gc standings those will be
played separately on monday september
the 12th uh so this is the uh the
schedule for this event wonderful thank
you peter and and we are so
pleased to have in studio with us
alejandro good to see you
my friend yeah sir peter a pleasure to
be calling all of these games with you
but you guys mentioned that we have
headliners in this tournament and
they're going head to head right now
right here it's the wild cards magnus
carlsen of course not a stranger to be
leading the sink field cup but our
newcomer hands demon young at 19 years
of age already making a mark in this
tournament and beating shaka yamamoto
yesterday they've never faced each other
in a classical game but they have played
throughout the champions chess tour the
magnus chester including a couple of
weeks ago in miami they played online
chess but they were in the same room and
in that particular match best of four
hans demon started blazing hot beating
magnus carlsen with the black pieces but
that only angered the world champion
because magnus came back beat him three
in a row to take that match for himself
has actually take took a lot of
victories from players in that
tournament but didn't win any of the
matches i know that he considers himself
a top player and a good top player needs
to be able to hold with the black pieces
against the world champion let's see if
he's able to do so in classical chess
because let's face it that is a tall
tall order
and well to follow all of the action we
also have women's grandmaster anastasia
karlovic who has been grazing us with a
lot of content in our social media
hello alejandro hello everyone it's a
pleasure to be here i highly recommend
to everybody to follow our social media
accounts saint louis chess club accounts
and granchester accounts are waiting for
you for backstage content uh yesterday
was a great day we had many spectators
as well as we are going to have today
and you can see the photos with fabiano
caruana rex sinkhole himself and also
levon arenan
their fans were waiting for them next to
the club and it was a pleasure to see
players in a good mood they were
chatting with their fans and
you can see it also on the video and i
had pleasure working together with peter
swiddler and also he had really warm
welcome from his fans too i knew guys
that you're very popular but it was
really fun to see peter with his uh
devoted fans um yesterday near the chess
club what do you think about it peter
did you enjoy talking to your friends i
think they were just you know it's so
it's very nice outside they were just
you know standing there and then you
know i'm i'm yeah waiting for hours you
meant to say that
peter do the honors uh what can we
expect in the pairings uh for this round
three uh we already spoiled the pairings
a little bit uh with the one match-up
with the one match up but the everything
else is also extremely tasty there on
your screen uh shakira madera white
against mdl appearing that you know
long history there uh linear naming is
playing white against the uniform
machine an interesting pairing in that i
did not it's not a huge advantage but i
did not expect lanier to be ahead in
there uh heads-up match and the year
actually leads uh 3-2 with a bunch of
draws there uh and there is against the
one iranian and here we have uh
our first shots of the day of people uh
arriving for getting wine for the game
and getting and getting checked here for
uh watches and wallets and things of
that nature no
pardon me no electronics at all and
they're going to be fighting and they
are fighting uh for the next 10 days or
so what are they fighting for uh peter
uh the prize fund of the grandchild
store is uh gunchester is far and away
the the richest tour in
in the chess calendar and as you can see
there uh
a sum total of 350 000 uh price one for
this event uh with a very cool hundred
thousand dollars uh even for for the
winner 65 per second 48 for third and
going all the way and all the way down
to 10.5 k
for the last place finish and there's
also a separate gct purse for the tour
finish
and that awards 13 points for an
outright winner for an outright winner
of the tournament 12. if you die and uh
that is an additional 175 000 dollars
awarded at the end of the tour with 100
up top except if the wild cards take all
the gz points but we are lucky because
at this sinkfield cup has a brilliancy
prize peter absolutely and we are very
grateful to to brian prister for
providing this five thousand dollar uh
prize for for the best game of the
tournament uh last year there was a very
clear-cut winner in a very brilliant
night or a victory in a game between
linear dominguez and
mbl uh and we hope to uh
award a worthy of worthy winner this
year as well as you can see this will be
our job so yeah
please petition us exactly exactly as we
see the players arriving and there's the
match-up that you mentioned a little
surprising that lanier does have an edge
over the next week i just wanted to
briefly mention because i think our
viewers have seen this happen pretty
much every day but i don't think we've
ever mentioned what this
uh
this piece of paper uh
on a pad next to the scoresheet is right
and uh as i've played in this tournament
a couple of times a couple of times as a
you know late replacement for people who
couldn't make it
i've signed those things before so i
know what this is this is uh a record of
who played on which board because those
boards potentially will be auctioned off
for for for charity
after the tournament so this is actually
a very notable
it's it's a provenance it's a
certification certification and it's not
just the boards it's the sets as well
yeah so they have these thing field sets
and you can just as peter was saying own
a piece of history
by bidding at these fundraisers and they
do have a quite a number of fundraisers
here in st louis uh gales that uh raise
money for everything that they do uh in
the uh st louis at chess scene i wanted
to mention this matchup ali reza now
because of his loss yesterday
he's kind of
feisty uh he wants to get back yeah and
he's playing a very uh worthy opponent
absolutely yeah they haven't played uh
i keep on being surprised by how few
games has played against players
but then i remember yeah he's he's only
just burst onto the scene and he hasn't
really had much time to uh to get volume
in so to speak uh but uh so far i think
it's just three draws and uh
uh
the vast majority of the games between
ereza and the one have been played
online and or in in rapid and blitz
events so it will be interesting to
watch and there we have our battle of uh
our leaders yeah with magnus starting
with 1g4 no surprise there magnus has
been a
1d4 player for
the longest time now and alejandro you
mentioned in their recent match
play in miami that there was four games
and crazily enough
the one game he won was with the black
pieces and what did hans do in that game
to win with the black pieces what was
the that game actually was a rosso limo
so that was a game in which magnus
carlsen started with the move e4
and in a sicilian with a very quick
bishop take c6 type of rosso limos it
was actually hans neiman that understood
the structures better the world champion
was very quickly under strategical
pressure and when hans expanded on the
kings i just no chance for white
wow
and then i think mangas actually
switched to
no no but he played some really weird
openings in this match altogether i
think in uh in game three as well there
were uh some quirky stuff i think maybe
he started with one a3 in game three yep
right i recall that as well and again i
have the game of magnus uh
versus hans with the move knight c3 no
catalans and an invitation let's dance
in a nimzo somewhat
i mean obviously it's not rare nimzo is
one of the most most important openings
in top players repertoires these days i
think pretty much everybody uh who is
not a lifelong grundfeld sufferer yes
has
king's indian suffering has this kind of
a group of openings available to them
playing perhaps the qgd
coupled with the nimzo to avoid some
move orders
but of course you can still go g5 cd5
knight takes d5 uh and play the the
semitarash there's a number of options
here available to hans that have become
very topical at the highest levels of
chess including as you're about to
mention this one yeah but bishop before
is the choice uh a notable thing we
don't have to go there yet but i will
just say that uh nipomnishi has been
a hardcore petrov player since the match
in dubai exactly but today he actually
challenges lanier's wow lanier's najdorf
and lanier on the white side of the
night or is generally one of the
scariest propositions i think he is
extremely well prepared he's been you
know putting a lot of questions to the
people he's he did win this really
brilliant game against mvl last year
their fight
yeah their fight uh this year already in
the rapid and blitz event so
linear is generally incredibly well
prepared in nine doors so this is an
interesting choice by uh by yan but it's
a choice that i personally very much
welcome because i'd much rather i must
honestly i'd much rather look at this
than than petra another petrol yeah nice
an invitation to dance in the english
line of the
um what are you expecting alejandro
knight g4 which at one time
used to be all the rage knight g4
bishop g5 h6 but recently e5 has become
the go-to uh
move in this exact position i think e5
is what every top level gm player is
doing at the moment knight g4 it led to
a lot of fun games and a lot of fun
adventures but it's really falling out
of fashion there's a couple of lines
that have been giving black a lot of
problems i'm not a huge knight or expert
especially not of this line so i don't
know and as we see jan does play the
movie yeah but jan in general i think
has been an e5 player throughout his
career in all of these types of
structures he just he plays on the the
neither of the players neither if not
right uh not to you know [ __ ] about with
those things yeah i'm not entirely sure
of what what put uh knight g4 sword
about it's not out of business but it is
out of fashion right
i haven't really
i can't say i'm entirely up to speed i
used to be i used to play these
positions with both colors very very
seriously and
maybe 20 years ago i could have given
you some kind of an overview but these
days um yeah i can i can just say that
yeah it seems like e6 has
really almost disappeared even though
it's definitely a very very serious move
as well gary caspar kasparov used to
play this
on par with e5 he would switch between
the five and the six at will more or
less
uh but both e6 and knight g4 i think
have been very much superseded by the
movie by the movie five interesting
yeah interesting that linear is thinking
here because i think he just always goes
knight b3 knight of three does exist
right and uh but
uh i
generally it's not how he likes to play
these types of positions because he is a
very direct player he aims to to get
those extremely sharp
night orbs with the opposite side
castlings and and i do have it in mind
that mvl actually won
a sinkhole cup
with a knight f3 against
nepo in the very last round
of the sinkhole but knight b3 is his
go-to uh weapon uh alejandro what's
caught your eye in uh some of the other
games
a little surprised about the start here
between firouja and aronian we had a
very standard italian bishop c4 bishop
c5 here d3 was the choice of course c3
and castle's also possible knight f6 and
a little bit of a quirky move here i
haven't seen this move h3 in this
particular moment very often i was
looking at the database and the top two
games that appeared are both between wei
yi the chinese superstar and peter
swiddler
so
i don't remember any of that
2015 i assume it was like a world
cup i don't know what else it could be i
did
i played him at the world cup but i
don't remember any of these yeah
well maybe the database is lying to us
but that's exactly what it says this
this may have been some sort of russia
versus china match but maybe it was the
other
world cup we played other openings i
think
in any case in this particular position
after castle's knight c3 i don't expect
people to know this in depth because the
move h3 seems a little bit rare but
people seem to have been looking at
everything if you see this database it
only finds eight games which considering
the logical moves that we've played so
far except for h3 you would think that's
strange but immediately not even without
any thought levon uncorked this move
knight a5 as if he knew exactly where he
stands and it's not ridiculous to take
this pawn on e5 it does require some
calculation and just the fact that it
requires calculation even if it's brief
means that the move knight a5 can't be
played without thought unless you have
some preparation in mind now the engine
does say that 965 is not better for a
wide side specifically d6 does give
compensation but queen e7 which is even
more natural barreling down on the e
file seems to give black more than
enough play after d4 you could take on
c4 it doesn't fully equalize according
to the engine but bishop b4 actually
starts threatening too many things on
the board of course d6 and destabilizing
the knight getting this bishop knight
takes e4 because of the pin is going to
be possible but the engines also say it
is possible to play queen e7 and then
just jump on f7 take take take and we
have this weird position in which white
is technically not in the preferable
situation with a rook against two pieces
but this is slightly discoordinated you
do get a lot of center the move bishop
e3 can be playable very soon to open the
f file so because of the concreteness of
how black's position is set up right now
they just are saying it's a playable
position it doesn't give white an
advantage but it doesn't think that
black is better either
so knight a5 currently on the board it
does capture this bishop immediately
right there's no way to save it at the
moment and if levon just gets the bishop
player from the get-go without any
consequences he can certainly think of a
good job in the opening
wow very intriguing indeed
tough that i can't go to my residence
expert
on this line and pick his brains when he
can't remember anything peter
what can i say
well i'm forbidden i'm forbidden for
from from using the word old so i don't
even know where to go from from here
right those were those were actually the
the world cup games and i they somehow
only remember
it was a really strange match because i
kept on getting very good positions and
not winning them
and then finally in game four of the
rapid i got a position which looked
resignable and won that one well done it
was it was a really really bizarre uh
bizarre match i i did i did remember the
story line but apparently not the
openings at all
nicely done nicely done we'll keep an
eye on that one uh shaq i just wanted to
go say that in this kind of a queen's
gambit accepted ending they the both
players have gone into this
um
position very very quickly
um
could be somewhat boring and back to the
magnus game for just a moment because
i'm looking at this uh
opening if you will between magnus and
hans and it's like a hybrid of like
three systems that
you don't really uh yeah i i've
i got sidetracked by by the the fact
that i can't remember my own stuff and i
and now you're looking at something yeah
because i saw knight c3 bishop before g3
and i thought okay magnus is kind of uh
playing with uh with hans there because
this is not a very popular move order uh
euro monition variation
gary used it in his world championship
matches yeah but i think you play knight
of three you wait for c5 and then you
play g3 right this is what this is what
people i mean this is extremely popular
this is
one of the absolute central lines yeah
g3 here is by far the main move actually
exactly above everything else but
playing g3 and move four with a pawn
steel and c7 gives black so so much
freedom to choose
uh you know whichever whichever
structure you want castles looks well
castles is fine
of course yeah you can switch as you say
to different structures
even including d5 and dtx4
bishop g2 g5 and now magnus goes a3
i am somewhat mystified by this but i
think what it does is
it uh you know very firmly says to uh to
magnus's opponent
i'm probably not better but he will have
to start playing chess by move six
you're on your own yeah again somebody
who is i i think one thing we could have
very easily have already noticed from
the first two games of uh
uh hanses in in this tournament he is
extremely well prepared right uh i think
he very much relies on uh on a you know
very solid foundation of opening
knowledge not that magnus doesn't know
any openings magnus these days is you
know arguably maybe the best prepared
player in the world
yeah uh which is a you know a far cry
from his young younger years when he
wasn't really putting very much emphasis
on the openings at all but he clearly
just says
you know let's let's play chess let's
compare skill here instead of comparing
the notes can i uh can i uh ask the
questions therefore so captures on c3 uh
yeah that would be my that would be my
what is this a3 the same issue
move four a two a three so it's kind of
a samish where you've put the bishop on
g2 already never connected never never
connected any kind
and it and
white's setup has basically uh cost him
his queen side we can most especially
oops excuse me that wasn't a slip most
especially the c4 square we could
imagine a quick night uh
excellent day five i'm also ending there
a little bit curious if we go to take c4
here
my guess says magnus will actually play
a gambit of some sort i don't think he's
playing queen a4 does win the the back
but i think bishop d7 bishop c6 should
be fine for black
i think this is probably challenging the
light squares yeah because we get we get
so much control over the light squares
it's not what you're doing when yeah i
think you're absolutely right and uh
take us down the proverbial pathway
therefore
uh a case of the gambit
i'm not entirely sure once again uh
ideally i would like i would like to
play bishop c86 here or b5 bishop b7 but
obviously uh if we play b5 some kind of
knight e5 will happen okay or a4 first
and and okay i'm with you
yeah and uh in these positions they are
very very difficult to assess because uh
if white doesn't achieve something by
move 20 white probably is just
completely busted exactly
yeah the queen side is gone right
queenside is gone every single end game
will be
extremely problematic for white and so
on but for the time being there's a lot
of activity you can try pushing for some
kind of a quick e4 there's a very nice
a3 square for the for the c1 bishop so
this is not a position you know i'm i'm
trying to i mean we're still hanging the
opponent's e3 right we can't really be
doing this i'm going to ask
a couple of them
yeah um
you know let's just put a couple of
moves just just for fun yeah three or e4
yeah let's just go
with it
or i'm going to leave the king no i'm
not
yeah
it has to be 97 actually because yeah i
think we need to have the option to play
f7 f6 and drive this right away sure
display three okay
f6 knight g4 i mean this particular one
i very much like for white i think this
is sort of the dream scenario the knight
returns to e3 we go castles we go even
rook fb1 if we need to we can play for a
four or five big the big compensation
this is like yeah this is the absolute
this is the absolute dream but i'm not
sure we're getting that right but also
g64 of course is nowhere near forest as
you were saying 96 a5 is very playable
even simply b6b6
let's join uh
let's get alejandra to join into the
conversation and uh
an unusual approach let's say by magnus
in the opening but
what's the recommended theory of this
line if there's such a thing aleandro
it's a rare line but it does exist there
are strong players that have reached
this position is as you said kind of a
mixture hybrid of different systems
looking at this g3 setups the a3 same
ish but it has been seen at the top
level we have the gates between
mamadyarov and karjakin karjakin
defended also against wei yi coming up
again today topalov played it against
golfing so there's a lot of examples
from this position half the people take
on c3 and the other half put the bishop
on e7 and then one lone wolf with the
bishop on d6 in the database now bishop
c3 does seem like the most natural move
and then to immediately chop on c4 not
everybody chooses this way a lot of
people choose the more solid move c6
some people break in the center with a
move c5 as well this has all been seen
before but let's go down the variations
that you were mentioning dtx4 knight f3
and now the engine is pretty is
preferring the moves knight c6 or c5
over holding on to the pawn now c6 has
been tried once uh sorry has been tried
a couple of times and it transposes into
this game between galia moba and
kashlinskaya from the russian
championship of 2016. white ended up
winning that game and the engine is not
a big fan of it because after a4 it does
think that the dark squares are too weak
for black situations so instead the
engine prefers after knight f3 to either
develop with knight c6 and then try to
hold on to the pawn you can hold on to
the pumbia knight a5 or more importantly
rook v8 and then b5 and in that case
you're not giving up as many dark
squares and you're also developing a
piece that's a greedy way of playing the
less greedy way of playing and the more
popular one is to play the move c5
immediately breaking open the center the
idea being that if you castle you take
on d4 and if you take with the pawn now
i can play a move like bishop d7 knight
c6 also perfectly fine but i move like
bishop d7 and start hinting that i will
hold on to this pawn that i will
challenge your bishop and that you're
not gonna have any compensation for it
you have a couple of moves as peter said
to prove some kind of advantage uh for
the pawn before you're just going to be
down a protected passport where the pawn
reaches b5 so certainly white will be on
the timer now as you guys mentioned
though this is forcing hans to make a
decision and he's gone for it he takes
on c3 takes on c3 takes on c4 and we'll
see what the world champion has prepared
for this position there just as usual
saying that this is fine for black that
it's about zeros with both knight f3 or
the move queen a4 which has also been
seen at top level chess nakamura beat uh
federico perez ponza with this mama
dyarov drew chaparino in this so it has
been seen at the top level as well we'll
wait for the world champions suggestion
there in other games we probably i have
the feeling we won't be spending too
much time of our commentary on this one
it's wesley so against fabiano caruana
you guys were saying oh i don't wanna
see a petrov well too bad a petrov you
get
uh bishop e3 is the current position we
don't really have to go through the
opening symmetrical structure
reminiscent of a rookie one berlin but
it's not and wesley trying something i
don't really know
why white would be too much better here
the engine's saying that the best plan
here is 9697 to trade off the bishop on
a5 it's a very common and very natural
idea in this position honestly i don't
think that even after the move c6 black
can be too much worse it's a very
typical approach by wesley it's sedate
if black gets into trouble of course he
will try to pressure his opponent but if
black plays
somewhat
decently i would say not necessarily
perfectly then black should be able to
solve his problems without too much in
this petrov thank you alejandro i wanted
to turn our attention to the game of
linear because as you were mentioning
lanier almost always plays this move
knight b3 against e5 a little uh
trickery going on here peter with knight
f3
perhaps there's this interplay because
linear for instance is seemingly always
ready to debate
bhp 3 593 specifically against mvl right
because he expects it from mvl right so
he spends some time at home sort of
refreshing the lines perhaps looking for
the new little way to ask a question and
some in some line he has a realistic
chance of seeing on the board and as we
as we mentioned at the top of the top of
the hour uh
jan used to be a hardcore night of
player it's not like he has no pedigree
in the opening exactly but he has become
almost an exclusive petrov player in the
last year or thereabouts since since the
dubai match
50 rating points since doing it i think
i don't know and uh and i think
lanier was
i think to a degree surprised by the
choice of najdorf and he chooses a much
more solid setup today which is you know
from my eyes a bit i mean this mission
is still very interesting night off in
general is a very
large rich
[Music]
uh interesting uh
opening but
you know compared to the mayhem we could
have gotten here uh if even if the
knight went to b3 this is much more of a
positional approach
absolutely and in these positions
uh peter just kind of refresh for our
audience what the
what the struggles are for both sides
what is white trying to achieve what is
blind hoping for i think generally
everything revolves around the the
control over the g5 square and or the
the way for black to sort of play around
the fact that white currently seemingly
has full control over the d5 square uh
you
one thing to start
by saying i think is
currently it's completely relevant but
white should always strive if you put a
piece on d5 and it gets taken you pretty
much never want to recapture with the
pawn yes so you always have to
uh preserve preserve the option of
playing 95 and then taking with the
queen or the bishop because if you take
it takes d5 your entire structural
advantage disappears and in fact a lot
of those positions become suddenly very
very attractive for black with plans in
the center like a 5 f4 e4 and so on
black's play in the center and on the
king's side becomes a lot freer
instantly and these bishops crying
but uh if we if we i mean nobody's going
to play knight g5 here but just to uh to
point out the way the way the way black
generally tries to deal with it is if
you play 95 straight away here i will
take and then the second knight will
take its place
on f6
uh driving the
the white piece away and then perhaps we
can play b5 bishop b7 or bishop b6 in
some cases but depending on how
things are
it's also because the knight on f6 is so
instrumental for black in these types of
positions
generally it's often very useful to play
h7 h6
unless in these particular positions
with knight on f3 sometimes h6 can be
really well met by knight h4 ah so let's
say let's say we play two a4 here which
is a move i actually expect to a linear
to play okay i think stopping b5 is
pretty much always going to be useful
for white okay let's say we play h6 here
and we run into knight h4 it becomes
awkward because both knight five and
knight g6 as yesterday is indicating
there are potentially serious problems
for black the move h6 is really weak you
can play knight c5 here the game hasn't
ended as such but
you at least you have to be very very
careful with uh with these types of
positions because if you don't have a
good reply to knight h4 you could be
in trouble yeah in in very very serious
trouble but this move a2 a4 uh
also more or less as you were saying
does kind of invite knights yeah but but
this is the point if you play knight c5
yes i have the option at least of
playing 95 ah 95 bishop d5 and saying
the knight on c5 is not where it should
be it really should be on f6 you know to
such an extent that i'm actually going
to suggest 97
you know i get it
not even very ironically i will actually
suggest 97 here and that that's what the
fights are about and that's why you're
also recommending a2 a4 because more or
less from black's point of view an ideal
system bishop b7 will be fantastic
alejandra
is one you seem to be uh skeptical about
the the things we're we're saying here
everything that you've said is correct
and i love it what i'm skeptical is
about nepal's play you've explained very
well that this is the game the d5 square
and this position that we have right
here has been reached over a hundred
times in grand master play including a
very painful game for myself judith
pogar against linear dominguez of the
world cup 2011 which linear one with the
black pieces
now why it's painful that's a long story
but basically judith was supposed to
come to st louis play a tournament
she beats linear
and
actually advances in the world cup isn't
able to make it and i end up not playing
the tournament she couldn't a was she
going to make the event but everybody
here plays bishop e6 everybody lanier
played it every strong player that's
ever reached this position plays it
including anand many times like wang
liam voitashek morozovich kayaking you
name them nepomiachi played bishop e6 in
this position
but nepo here played knight bd7 and my
engine jumped
knight bd7 clear white advantage because
of the move a4
wow knight c5 the engine thinks is the
best move and everything that you guys
explain is actually accurate and it's
thinking why are you wasting the tempo
this bishop needs to come to e6 right
away because now that i have a4 b5 isn't
really feasible you could play b6 maybe
nepo has some ideas in this position but
the engine isn't very thrilled about
putting this pawn on b6 if you see it in
my engine it keeps jumping up and up and
up because of the weaknesses on a6 and
b6 especially with this bishop on e3
already targeting it so i'm a little bit
confused
about what nepo is doing in this
position he's playing very quickly and
we've noticed that he does that very
often he didn't play it instantly he
didn't play knight bd7 instantly like he
was part of his prep he took a couple of
minutes decided to put the knight on d7
and i'm wondering why he's not following
what everybody else does including
himself
yeah i was honestly i was a bit
surprised by 97 but
uh you know the decision to play the
night of today it's obviously his uh i
want a fighting
and uh linear
generally plays knight b3 but has played
knight f3 in the past so
yeah it's it's a bit confusing because i
i don't think this is how you develop
pieces in this line very often and uh
it's a it's a way to you know quote
unquote preserve the life and the
position you know you you're not
offering any trades you're preserving
the the complexities but i think you're
preserving the complexities complexities
here very much at your own at your own
peril yeah
and uh against lanier specifically who
is an incredibly sound positional player
i would be uh worried
about
you know introducing additional
strategic risk exactly into into the
game uh two quick uh ganders i want to
take a look at first of all was the game
between ali eraser and lavonne
yes excellent if it was a bluff it's an
excellent bluff that's exactly my
thought processes as well knight a5
a2 a3
you've got to take the bishop
uh you have by the way with the move a2
a3 prevented bishop b4 and after d7 d6
unless alejandro was saying he's won the
two bishops i'm a bit
sort of curious about the decision to
play d6 yeah specifically because bishop
g5 exists
but i guess he is not that worried
because i guess i can play bishop b6 for
now and stop knight g5 that way okay and
then if you play 95 i think tactically
uh it will be i think once this knight
is gone i can actually afford to play h6
and g5 because i don't think i'm going
to get mated
without
by the way a2 a3 i'm told by var
uh in our production team a2a3 novelty
in this little played uh variation
uh by the way uh so
that was first and second uh
developments came yeah this is so
quickly in between this is being this is
being played very very quickly c5 as
alejandro indicated this is the main
move and it looks like uh hans is
reasonably well prepared even here she
takes d4 magnus interestingly doesn't
take with the pawn takes with the queen
here which is
maybe with the knight either yeah maybe
maybe the way to go maybe it is the the
way to you know preserve something in
the position without you know committing
to too much risk but 96 is a very good
reply uh just giving up the opponent c4
to play 65 hugely important resource
here for black opening up the bishop
yeah freeing up the bishop bishop g5 h6
from gravity one on the board
uh hans is thinking which makes me
wonder if he wants to play bishop e6 or
because otherwise arguing e7 otherwise i
don't understand what he's thinking
about yet right queen e7 to preserve a
recapture of the queen against f6 but
maybe it is bishop e6 then
well
um yeah i mean queen c5 queen b5 i'm
guessing we meet with queen b6 i'm
guessing we play queen b6 here and we
claim that
if the trade on b6 happens
we are not that worried about anything
else because we will have enough
counterplay on the queen side against
the white weaknesses on a3 and c3 and it
might be true for all we know
and uh also but why not queen e7 i don't
know
also informs that uh
queen takes d4 is actually a novice
but it has a great deal of sense to it
as well uh once more let's just take a
look at this
position rook d1 bishop e6
i i'm trying to make queen h4 work and
then we should take h6 yeah exactly
i'm very
skeptical i don't think we have enough
attackers for this right somehow trading
queens on b6 may actually crazy only
enough help
i mean it's a mixed bag but i don't
think black suffers i mean you create a
like a very very serious weakness on b6
but a3 and c3 will uh
remain weak for the rest of the game and
this very often uh results in a in a
full liquidation of the queen side if
you look at the position again after
queen b5 can be six yeah
this ending peter black's comfy i think
black is fine
i just like i can't imagine how this is
worse
exactly unless very specifically like uh
but even e2 is hanging right you don't
have any tempo
right right right e2 is hanging um i'm
always loath
to accept this kind of structure i
understand i mean but uh
probably nothing no nothing to
okay well
then bishop e6 isn't it especially on
the board yeah this is very valid
yeah and you were about to say that m5
blitzed out b6 i think pawn is weak well
it is what was bit slow
sorry aleandro nothing was blitzer right
he hasn't played
i know sorry i i looked at i looked at
the wrong screen apologies yeah
i looked at your screen
but i'll take it from here because i was
analyzing this with uh sassy the
strongest engine out there following
magnus's games shout out to them but
queen b5 the engine hates absolutely
this move queen b6 is okay but queen a5
one step longer is very dangerous for
the white side if you take like this
then well thank you for giving me the c4
square this is a weakness we don't have
to explain this too long this pawn super
weak bishop is targeted and it doesn't
have a very good square if you take on
f6 i take happily on f6 and cover e5
black advantage so
you're wondering why can't i take on b7
yes indeed rook fc8 defends this knight
and remember that this bishop's hanging
if you take on f6 this traps the queen
advantage black so after bishop e6 i was
looking at it with the engine and they
want to go into this end game they by
the way already prefer black but
how practical it is i'm not so sure
takes takes takes knight d2 sorry not an
id2 immediately take one f6 first
they're gonna have six knight d2 hits
the bishop no real choice you could go
to e6 but
why not take on e2 right knight e4 hits
that pawn uh for some reason here f5 is
better than king g7 although i think
every human here plays king g7
uh f5 knight d6 attacks both pawns f4
for some reason you don't take that pawn
because of well not for some reason
because f3 locks your bishop so you put
the bishop on e4
and
the engines are saying white has
compensation and it's just some kind of
weird end game
this engine is for now evaluating it at
minus 0.3 and that's more or less what
cessy has it at and they think this is
the best continuation for both sides and
explain to our audience who and what is
ceci ceci is a super engine and you can
uh just google sassy spelled s-e-s-s-e
it's an engine that follows magnus
carlson's games and it is pretty strong
so no matter what laptop you're using
it's not going to be holding up against
what ceci is evaluating it is currently
one of the best freely available engines
that um well freely available is a bit
of a strange because you you can't
actually feel the positions but when
magnus is playing it will be showing
magnus's game and actually as a kind of
a public service if there's a strong
tournament in which magnus is
participating once magnus's game is over
if there is something else interesting
running in the round they will switch to
other games in that round so they are
not only doing magnus's games but
uh mainly it's just a kind of a public
service for the for the people of norway
who are interested in their in their
heroes games
it is as i understand it uh a pretty
standard uh stockfish 15 or perhaps 16
by this point by but ran on on hardware
that is not very easily commercially
available and if you will uh alejandra
because i know you're a very
computer specialist with these concerns
so i've got the stockfish running on my
laptop it's really really really good
it's 3 200 300.
cessy's hardware makes it what
i mean it would be a solid four or five
hundred points higher than whatever your
laptop can produce yeah somewhere like
four or five hundred thirty seven thirty
eight hundred i would yeah that would be
mine somewhere somewhere in that in that
region yeah yeah it's pretty not even
close it's like it's like
magnus playing at
like a 2300 yeah that's the difference
wow
wow very very impressive and that
dovetails nicely by the way with a shout
out to our audience please do feel
welcome to challenge our panel through
the chat window send your questions
to our social media
um i want to say guru but that's not the
word i was looking for anastasia
who is keeping track keeping eye on your
queries and we'll be delighted to answer
them by the way do we have moves in the
magnus game no he is deep in thought
after bishop six i get the feeling he
may have underestimated this
intermediate move and he is now coming
to the somewhat painful realization that
there is no good reply because there's
just no good squares if you go uh
to the left so to speak both b5 and a4
running into cb5 queen a5 and i'm
guessing yeah he realized that this
exists and is now acutely unhappy about
it and green h4 queen e7
uh you either have to take on f6 twice
and
if you have to pick a side i think i'm
picking black there honestly despite the
ruined king side and i just don't think
bishop takes h6 works at all
but i think uh
well
these types of things work wonderfully
when you have a knight on c3 and you can
play c4 or something
brilliantly to the e4 and d5 square in
this case not not not so well bishop e6
so i think i think magnus is
the good thing about him is that he is
you know fairly objective he obviously i
think uh as you know most of us are
you know this feeling that i have to put
the upstart in his place right will have
been
quite prominent before today but now
that he's here
he will realize things have gone
somewhat pear-shaped and he will find a
way to equalize and go for it
he is he's not going to accept
a war's position just to continue
playing now i know alejandro you're not
going to speak for sassy
but i'll speak for humankind when i say
i don't like losing the e2 pawn and if i
do take the time out to play king
f1 to defend it and then pursue
ideas i guess rook d8 for now right to
uh move the move the rook away from the
pin so that later i can play uh knight
a5 and v6 quite comfortably let's say
with that g5 here without uh fear yeah
like a 592 pc 92 currently is unplayable
but you can start with rugby one right
to avoid the the forks let's just go b6
here okay 92 [ __ ] b6
edgar 6 yes yeah i mean black is i think
clearly uh clearly very very comfortable
here the pawn on a3 is just
so much more relevant than the pawn on
f6 here like if the if the knight lands
on c4 at some point and it's not getting
traded straight away you're just in
trouble ruxin
exactly just look at this position i was
trying to get in knight e4 yeah f4
if you give enough time for the white
white probably will equalize but move by
move like like here after roxie you
might have to play knight b1 and how
happy will you be about no no no no no
i do not know no those split pawns peter
they're they're they're definitely a
weakness very aggravating well
for
the wild card
we found hans neiman
i would say uh he's probably played
about a hundred moves over the course of
the first two rounds maybe even more he
hasn't been playing very badly at all
and on the contrary he's uh
is asking some very uh awkward questions
to the world champion so far extremely
solid performance by uh by hans and uh
he is not you know shy of
stating his claim but so far it's very
well backed up by
by over-the-board play uh exactly and uh
yeah
we'll keep an eye on this and we'll turn
it over to whoa
oops what uh the game between wesley and
fabiano which we were claiming
watching very much just suddenly as an
unboring itself
somewhat
somewhat unboring that such g g7
g5 lifting his kimono what do you say
about that
uh alejandro the computer doesn't hate
it but it doesn't love it because it
thought that normal moves here with
black gave
favi a good position what are normal
moves in this position you see that this
knight came to h4 i remember i mentioned
about this knight c6 e7 uh line with the
idea of trading this bishop right right
so now you understand the move knight h4
you are preventing this because knight
takes f5 so
one way to do this is to play bishop e6
follow this up with queen d7 then play
knight f5 and trade all the pieces
seems logical enough family said uh give
me that square immediately g5 forcing
the knight back there's not really a lot
of choices here and i expect the point
is to play is there i thought i thought
queen f3 was at least like something to
mention but i guess just king g7 is okay
actually yeah it is something to mention
i sorry to miss that uh but it does
force knight f5 unfortunately there's no
other and then everything comes off we
go queen e6 and we claim that our bishop
on d6 is just so much better than the
bishop on e3 right yeah queen e6 or
queen d7 the engines are liking it so
yeah this apparently doesn't really work
out for white so yeah i just think that
f3 is almost forced but you can't play
bishop f5 now which was the whole point
and as you're mentioning you're trying
to get the good bishop right this bishop
is better than this bishop because it's
blocked by its own pawn but the the
downside you've given me a hook exactly
on the king side right i can play the
move h4 immediately start asking
questions about whether you really want
to come forward even more with the move
g4 and you the answer might have to be
yes knight e5
you got to defend this guy you can take
on c2 first and then we play h5 but you
can see there's a lot of dark squares
and this bishop doesn't feel so bad
anymore as he's controlling a lot of
important squares on the king side so
favi is being his usual feisty self
where he's giving a chance to make
things unclear over the board he takes
it sometimes this works out sometimes it
doesn't and let's see if g5 will be
rewarded in this game well it's a novel
approach to this particular position and
yeah i just want to make one one slide i
don't know clarification would not be
right but if we go back to the position
of tonight h4 there on you know
whichever demonstration board we choose
i'll take the analysis let's go we just
saw the move knight c6 e7 as prescribed
yeah knight h4 is a computer's first
choice i'm pretty sure and stopping
bishop is hugely important here for
white exactly yeah but the point is i
think the point is after bishop e6 uh
fabi probably did not like the position
after queen f3 because it's it's not as
if we are going to play queen d7 knight
f5 and white will do nothing at all
about it we are currently threatening
bishop takes h6 as yasser is indicating
you might have to make some slightly
uncut like knight h7 might be required
but uh
what we really wanted though then again
it might be completely fine
it's not a bad move no uh but yeah white
goes rookie one and it gets it gets
somewhat awkward perhaps
i i honestly what the line that
alejandra showed with knight of three
whisperer 5 h4
looked
seriously dangerous for black
and
g5 probably wasn't that great
i can sort of understand where he's
coming you guys want to see a funny line
i guess that queen f3 you can look at it
on your board don't need to switch to
yeah sure uh queen of three uh against
bishop hp66 not not known g5
bishop e6 queen f3 sorry yeah bishop b6
yep queen f3 yeah engine top move queen
c6
queen c6 and then there's bishop f5 or
something yes bishop takes h6
she takes h6
loses to queen takes f6 bishop f5
[Laughter]
yeah
yeah
yeah all hail our silicon overlords what
can i say
wow all all hail it's cute it's cute
it's very very cute it works but who on
earth is looking at queen season
that actually explains a lot right like
why would you play g5 because finding a
move like queen c6 is it's pretty hard
to even think of this move okay what if
i go rookie one here
you're not gonna like it but it's true
it's queen b5
it can't according to the engine this is
just the engine don't don't shoot the
messenger rook b1 is the best move and
then you go queen c6
okay okay yeah yeah we but you've
learned the the rook to e1 and not a1
with the move queen c6 i say shoot the
messenger
never a mistake
never a mistake thank you alejandro that
is some funny stuff g5 but let's look at
g5 because i loved the position for
white
and this is after all a really heavy
weight can we make an argument for
knight of five
five
let's just take a look at this for a
second because
yeah perhaps i don't like this either
but maybe and g5 is actually the novelty
of the game so far wesley was following
a correspondence game so he was very
well versed on all of these ideas and a
correspondence game that actually went
queen b5 instead of g5
uh pardon me uh the correspond went
queen b5
and then i am assuming what b1 yeah and
i guess then b6 or something yeah just
developing quietly as we've established
queen of three is not as big with
that game of course when rook b1 bishop
e6 queen f3 queen a6
yeah similar ideas but also liking the
eights upon yeah
correspondence game
yeah those correspondence games really
should not be overlooked by any of the
tournament players
um
okay uh but we do have g5 uh the
gauntlet has been thrown uh if you will
you have uh pardon me fabi has seriously
weakened his f5 uh square as he gone too
far peter
i don't know i don't know i like knight
f5 you wanted
like is a strong word i just didn't like
this i i thought bishop five h4
is problematic for black because this is
really
fun yeah
if you have to play h6h5 here you're not
really enjoying this nearly as much as
you would no no no no those darks were
weaknesses on the king side so you
wanted to try to bail a little bit yeah
but i like you're like the fun move yeah
i think [ __ ] is clever maybe i
can play not you i'm not taking only
three of course you're not and the whole
point is is that f5
falls right into my midst in in in most
of these types of positions i think
uh the bishop e3 is far and away the
worst piece white has so so trading in
the matchup is pretty much never part of
our plans i want to play knight e4 okay
establish this kind of a foothold in the
center and then just continue developing
sort of behind my knights on f5
well i want to play c4 but
i suppose i need to reinforce 73 we can
play i don't know let's say
97 bishop five maybe even in some
positions
g7
yeah
it's actually a surprisingly useful
square in in in some of these types of
positions because f5 does belong to the
bishop right okay take a deep breath for
bishop g bishop five let's let's do it
okay you've got some
how nasty are your discoveries i suppose
they're nasty enough let me uh get out
of the way
i mean do you think c4
i'm guessing you take on c4 and then
some you know a move perhaps
knight f6 could come to mind or queen
somewhere queen d7 or k8 i don't know
it's a strange position i'm not in love
with it by by any means with black but
it feels playable and we're not under
direct attack on the king side which i
think will be the case if we go on
bishop f5 right and i would very much
like not to get mated by move 20 which
is why
which is why i'm suggesting this you
know
i i remember um growing up there was a
fred ryan felt book
miniatures i think it was called chess
miniatures or something like that and
ever since i had read that book i never
wanted to lose a miniature you know
right here
you know
the the updated kind of a breaking news
gong in this on the show because yeah
you just have one this was a quiet round
for like three seconds for three seconds
flat and then two people decided you
know what g5 is good levon looked at
five he said g5 yeah that looks like a
pretty good move let me play it myself
h6 look at this quiet game you can play
anything h6 is fine c6 is fine most
moves are fine
h6 bishop h sorry whoops
h6 bishop h4 and lemon said g5 in this
position
typical idea but you always have to
watch out for a very specific sacrifice
and
others i thought about it for a little
bit picked up the gauntlet right up here
g5 takes on g5 takes on g5 bishop takes
g5 and we have this traditional pin from
g5 to d8 and the question is how do you
get out of it right in most cases when
you have a knight on c6 you know when
you don't win the pair of bishops you
play knight b8 97 that's one way to get
out of it another way you somehow
maneuver this bishop back to e7 that's
not happening in this position right so
after king g7 which is the natural move
oh try to get the queen off the diagonal
and then move the knight away
white has two interesting options
the engines are thinking that f4 might
give white an advantage it's a very
traditional way of opening up things and
the idea is that after pawn takes you
play this move knight e2 the idea is
that you take on f4 and then threaten
knight h5 and it's not so comfortable
for black to deal with this uh of course
this is very complicated it's easier for
an engine to see it the other way is to
make this a permanent pin queen f3 and
what is your plan
it's pretty much always rook h8h6 in
these types of positions yeah you have
to play rook h8 h6 but in this
particular position i'm not castle short
yeah i understand so i will castle along
here and then start pushing my pawns in
such a way that when you do get your
rook to h6 i'll go g5
so i'll go g4 very soon according to the
engine you'll go h4 g4 very soon just so
that you don't get your rook to h6 you
have to play it immediately according to
the engine you could take on c4 but i
think that's a crazy move rookie chain
for example castles and the engines are
saying go go ahead play the move for k6
but it hates black's position it thinks
takes takes g4 h4 g5 is coming and that
well material is not really that much
better for black it's still two pieces
for a rook and two pawns and
in this particular situation this king
is gonna get hunted down
outstanding i always enjoyed these
sacrifices to be on the white side i
mean i did have my
my setbacks as well but it always felt
nicer to have the initiative but that
last line in particular that aliana
andrew was explaining usually yes
unfortunately i have already castle
short and then i gotta go king h1 to get
in f4 the fact that you can castle
long uh early just play h4
and h5 peter it gives you it gives you
the types of the types of play which you
don't normally see in this in this
precisely and it's obviously obviously
in white's favor something i want to
just just mention here is
uh i mean levon is a very strong player
he knows what he's doing but a lot of
experiences yeah what i wanted to say is
alireza must be so in love with this
right now because he had this really
really bad game like honestly just just
a bad game
yeah you can't really describe it in any
other way he played passively he got he
got outplayed and then he sort of
compounded
getting somewhat out prepared by
uh
showing
i feel once again those are harsh words
but
jan in our press conference quoted their
conversation after the game and the fact
that he defended it passively until it
just collapsed
showed i think some inexperience yeah in
somewhat typical
in some somewhat typical rook ending
situations so and he also has just a
very poor score against jan and it's
never fun to continue losing to the
person you were sort of losing over and
over to exactly and he plays this rather
quiet gioco piano today
and
if if levon doesn't play g5 there it
continues being a very quiet
non-spectacular piano piano and then
suddenly you get this you know
opportunity to play a sacrificial game
and to perhaps immediately get onto the
uh onto the scoreboard with potentially
a brilliant victory right and
psychologically it's just such a you
know breath of fresh air here to be
given this opportunity i'm pretty sure
he is you know the biggest fan of the
biggest fan of g7 g5 in the playing hall
right now is alireza here
nice and i i do like this queen f3
castle's long idea it's slow slowly
ready to play g4
as well as h4 and again if you're
well if you're not playing bishop take
c4 and if you're not playing bishop e7
as you mentioned peter the only way
you're breaking the pin yeah pretty much
this is this and then yeah we take take
we play g4 we play rogue dg1 we play
like the pawns will be on g5 and h4
black is not entirely defenseless this
is not made uh but it looks very scary
because obviously
uh they will just continue running like
you play rook dj one you play h5 you aim
to play g6 and so on and
materially let's say if the c4 pawn
falls which we will continue offering it
nobody nobody really on the white side
you don't really care to protect it
protecting it
black is arguably maybe like a pawn up
if we if we just count the numbers here
maybe we'll have a pawn up but the king
of g7 is extremely unsafe the king on c1
will be saved for the longest time right
right and it's just very easy to play
with white uh alireza goes for a father
he goes for mock
explained is also very playable but
uh a much more
uh forcing way to play this position
f4 so
you have pretty much forced you can't
allow f5 if you allow f5 the knight
might land on g5 and that might just
end the game exactly so ef pretty much
forced and 100 was saying 91 92 first
rook f1 also comes into some
consideration i would assume
yes but 92
i suppose rook f1 is going to be by
bishop e3 yeah but i think those might
be transpositions because i have a
feeling in that position as well we will
be playing 92 anyway yes so 92 at the
start yeah 92.
and knight
h5 on the agenda and bishop v3 i i get
the feeling rook of one anyway or g3 uh
g3 maybe as well
if i could recap pardon me if i can
recapture with the pawn
and also aspire to knight g3 knight f
yeah h3 also looks quite quite
interesting this bishop will
fall into a tempo
this is now this is now a very very
interesting very concrete position which
i'm getting a little bit uh scared i
want to
break
this pin quincy three might be winning
material right now right
there's also this direction
this is another another another good
thing about breaking up shoot yeah
forcing forcing ef also generates maybe
this is actually why we're putting
playing 92 as a kind of a
more urgent thing to do rather than ruka
fun because queen c3 might be an
extremely useful
right why why why we got in there
well we've got a really great round
shaping up here folks but we're going to
take our first break and we're going to
see you on the other side stay tuned
[Music]
hey st louis the ascension charity
classic presented by emerson is back
this september don't miss the excitement
when the pga tour champions best compete
again all for charity september 9th
through the 11th at norwood hills
country club pro-am spots hospitality
packages vip tickets and more available
now at ascension
ascensioncharityclassic.com
[Music]
we're the corey family welcome to our
show
[Music]
[Music]
that's our show
[Music]
you may have heard about st louis's
world-class museums art history science
even
magic
but you may not know we have an entire
museum dedicated to play with a 10-story
slide and a ferris wheel on top
don't let all this family fun slide by
you
those kids it is
st lou is always exploring anybody
[Music]
be surprised be intrigued be delighted
the world chess hall of fame in st louis
is nothing you'd expect and everything
you love
three galleries highlight the history
culture and creativity behind the game
explore chess in ways you never imagined
it's a one-of-a-kind cultural
institution where rare artifacts and
world-class art play together
the world chess hall of fame
mind art experience
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to our coverage of round
three of the singfield cup 2022 very
very exciting round in progress there
were a couple of games which looked like
they might be kind of quiet
no longer blew up no longer true and all
five positions potentially uh look like
very very interesting games and arguably
maybe the quietest one and the one in
which white is fighting
i mean fighting for survival is strong
but definitely trying to equalize uh
securely is the unexpected one where
magnus carson is white against hans
neiman hans continues to impress in this
tournament
very very easily neutralizing a rare
opening idea by by magnus carlsen and is
currently very very safely maybe even
slightly in control of their matchup
first the pairings here are all five of
the pairings as you mentioned the two
leaders magnus carlson and hans ningla a
very exciting game between the the two
co-leaders
and uh before we just jump into the
games first of all uh our commercial
announcement for everybody they
got to know what's going on with the
cube boutique absolutely let's introduce
the uh the item for today and uh what
we're offering today is a granchester
t-shirt a very very nice uh nice item
there as you can see
uh
celebrate the grand chest store with a
limited edition official 2023 t-shirt
which features as you can see all of the
stops along the door on the back of the
shirt and the saint louis chess club
logo on the on the right sleeve
uh
available uh in in both men's and
women's fashion uh very nice i really
like the pastel color of the shirt and
the gorgeous shirt as as everything else
uh available at cubaticstl.com
and now back back to the positions i
guess well for and first of all during
our break we got raided by the u.s
women's olympic team
that was quite fun to have tata vendegum
uh on set so uh thank you tata f and
bingham for joining us and now we're
ready to discuss
uh however uh the game between our two
code leaders rook d-1 rug played by
magnus yeah um
one thing i couldn't figure out yet is
how we're saving the a3 pawn after takes
takes bishop d5 exactly that's the most
pressing yes question specifically
bishop d5 because i want to stop 92 if
white gets the knight to g2 white's
problems are
almost entirely over if you play some
kind of king 792 white is fine white is
not fighting for any advantage here with
a broken up queen side uh the way it is
but with the bishop d5 the knight is
temporarily frozen and as you say i want
to play knight before and i want to take
on a3 yeah and uh
i uh we've looked at uh what the engines
are saying uh on the brake and
apparently this is not very much but
looking at it from a purely human
perspective i can't figure out why
why it's hard to say so the engines just
think it's an equal end game
down a pawn which is kind of crazy it
has to do with the fact that this pawn
at the end is very weak so if you go
down some of these variations
specifically from the position you were
mentioning both knight h4 and knight e1
are apparently equal the point is that
if you take take knight c4 actually does
pick up that pawn and not in time with
the king if you go a4 keep chasing this
pawn or just go knight b2 check and take
it immediately but knight e3 which is a
draw important game if you take on e3 or
knight h4 lead to a very similar
position and that is that first of all
here i have the move c4
which can be a little bit dangerous for
black the knight is trapped and i'm
threatening king c1 king b2 but even if
i didn't have this resource and i play
the move knight f5 i basically chain you
to defending this pawn at some point
because if the king starts venturing to
the side of the board h5 simply falls
the knight on f5 is very well placed now
i also have the threat of playing knight
d6 knight c8 and harassing these pawns
so the engine just equalizes by brute
force
it's not intuitively obvious to a human
to even try to look this far ahead but
perhaps magnus felt that he had to solve
his problems immediately and that's the
way he saw how to do it
thank you for that uh alejandro the
other reason why i like rook d1 is
because as you were pointing out uh
peter the pawn on c3 the pawn on the e3
is so weak i can take away
uh the attacker of the pawn on cd if we
can get the rooks off the board it
improves our situation uh greatly and if
black has to abandon the default play
something like rook c8 here uh we can
develop our own like bishop h3 here is a
very sensible move for instance
absolutely and then we can start going
for knight h45 plans or if you play b6
uh your structure as black will also
become sort of soft enough for us
to play yeah exactly um
boy i also uh
i wanted to ask uh alejandro for favor
the game that
nepo lost in the last round
of a cinco cup to
mvl i think was a very instructive game
if you could fish that game out for me
because i'm looking at this game by
lanier
and mvl and there's something about the
game that
um
i'm
i'm i'm reminded of that game in
particular
and it seems to me like lanier has
the advantages i want to say that mvl uh
also achieved peter it's a it's a
pleasant structure uh white has uh as
you can see from from the last moment
that we looked at this game the
structure changed quite dramatically
because knight c5 95 bishop d5 happened
on bishop b6 and here
we chose a kind of a quiet move c2c3 and
97 with the idea of rerouting it to f6
happened
and now linear chose to change the
structure
again by the way c2 c3
novelty again uh big shout out to
verusion in the truck uh keeping is on
our toes 97 sorry peter yeah takes takes
p3 forces this really awkward move king
of seven which you sometimes see in
light or fca because
you you do have protected politics you
cannot possibly allow allow white to
pick that up exactly but the kingdom of
seven is reasonably uh reasonably safe
so you're not in that much trouble but
the issue is yeah this lift with a5 rook
a4 is very very useful it does a couple
of jobs rather pleasing actually right
sorry yes and uh
yeah i thought at first that black
position is really not that bad but the
more i look at it the more it feels like
a bit of a free roll for white well you
asked me to dig out that game so here i
have it yasser for you this is the game
between bashar lagrave and janne
pomniacci that gave nvl the win at the
sink field cup of 2017.
now in this particular night or it's
very similar it's the same idea of
knight f3 but we're going to see a
couple of key differences and the main
one in my opinion is that this bishop
came to g5 and eliminated the knight on
f6 and this is a concession it is the
pair of bishops that you're giving up in
this position and i remember casting
that game and thinking that after the
move knight c4 the move bishop e6 was
correct sacrificing the pawn on d6 but
getting positional compensation for it
instead nepo back then chose the passive
move bishop e7 and after a5 he found
himself clamped by these two knights
knight c4 coming to b6 knight c3 coming
to d5 and you can see only a few moves
later how white got full dominance of
this square on d5 was able to put a
bishop on d5 even and this was just a
horrible position for yanni pontiac he
must have ghosts of the same issues
because look at his structure here it's
a little bit worse he does have the d5
pawn under control you can see the
structure's very similar but he doesn't
have no pair of bishops and this pawn on
b7 is a little bit more attackable and
as you guys are mentioning this is bad
for black the engines don't like it at
all giving more than a one point
advantage currently for linear dominguez
now what is a pro for nepo he's playing
fast he has one hour and 21 minutes
against what you can expect from lanier
25 minutes left for the remainder of the
game
as you mentioned at the top of the show
peter uh
bringing the excitement all decisive
games so far winning a loss of course
it's only two games but still you you do
get the feeling he's pushing the
envelope a little bit yeah i i feel like
this this is some kind of a weird
experiment gone a bit wrong here with
black because
i i would
very very well i'd be shocked if this is
what he intended to get when he was
preparing for today's game because
specifically against linear as well i
feel like you are opening yourself up to
a lot of trouble down the line exactly
linear is going to be a a nightmare to
play against in these positions where
you can operate on uh the level of
understanding you can like
lanier's autopilot i think is one of the
best in the business and uh he sometimes
sort of gets into trouble when you have
to play a very sharp complicated
position and his search for
objective truth you know leads him to
have 30 seconds by move 25 exactly here
it's unlikely to be the case he is down
almost like not an hour 40 minutes i
guess he's done 40 minutes on the clock
but
uh it's a reasonably simple position to
play you play rook d1 you play i don't
know h3 or g3 king g2 i guess h3 because
you don't really with the queen of c6
you probably don't want the king on g2
as much and you you keep on shuffling
you keep on like threatening to play
before it a favorable at a favorable
situation okay can i just grab the
gauntlet for just a quick second and
uh he did play rook d1
yeah no knight d2 for sure yeah and then
maybe roxy four and six exactly exactly
knight d2 and rook c4 i think maybe he
doesn't he doesn't want to invite the
65. i feel the reason he played rook d1
as well
right though those are both connected
with the same idea that the 65 is about
the only improving idea black has even
with the
even with the king on f7 it's it's
extremely beneficial for black if you
can make if you can manage to play this
and not lose on the spot which is
obviously yeah yeah
let's say i play i don't know after
knight e4 you still don't really have a
threat maybe i can play e6 for instance
yeah yeah unpin myself
and the knight has to go back
pity and suddenly maybe it doesn't look
that horrible for black which is why we
see rook d1 as a prelim move uh maybe it
does preface knight d2 and as you say uh
and what is it that black is actually
looking very very difficult to figure
yeah i mean knight i think h6 yeah
would be met by a killer blow i think
specifically h6 knight f6 is the only
real way
to improve something in the position
that i can name because with an iphone
f6 the pawn on e4 will potentially hang
in some positions
if it forces knight g2 we can once again
start dreaming of pushing the 65
somewhere fair uh so yeah i'm expecting
h6 i don't really i could i was trying
to you know find a different useful move
here
and that's not really succeeding at all
yeah i think
apart from that two move sequence yeah
i'm struggling to come up with anything
productive for
for black for black at all and how about
you alejandro where where have you been
producing the good the good work
no i don't i'm not going to show any
good work but there is a game that might
not last too long okay at some point
mentioned that shakarya mammadyara is
playing maxine with cheryl graf and
they've reached this end game and i
expect this to just be drawn pretty
quickly maxim spent almost no time to
get all the way to this position
sacrificed a pawn on this queen's gambit
accepted variation and currently you
have this rook end game in which black
is clearly better except for the fact
that white has an extra pawn and that
just about compensates each other uh you
don't have any winning attempt if you
let the a3 pawn go but rook a1 is a
pretty sad winning attempt right you
won't be able to make any progress on
the king side the structure it doesn't
let you create a passport on itself and
even if it did it's a very weakened one
so i expect this game to go to a draw uh
in the game of yan and linear h6 was
played it was the best move by the
computer and at some point you do play
the move 92 now you guys were mentioning
the idea of d5 right h6 in particular
after knight d2 if you play the move d5
in this position i can take
take on d5 and then just go back
whoops yeah with rook on d1 of course it
looks less attractive because white is
very prepared to meet it yeah but then
how do you meet knight d2 because it is
a very serious question h6 didn't
particularly help you yeah roxy before
currently is a huge big threat right
right and the engines don't find like a
very good way to do so they think you
would either bishop g5 or rook fda but
if we go down some of these variations
they're pretty unpleasant if you go here
here you can even go queen c2 and hint
that b4 is going to be strong but as you
guys are mentioning also the move simply
rook b4 right with the idea of knight c4
at some point of course rook takes b7 on
tap and the position is just ugly guys
h6 was the best move by the engine but
it's not improving black's position too
much
thank you for that
alejandro and we do have in the game
between ali raza the peace sacrifice uh
alireza and lavon we do have the move
with that we had expected peter before
we went on break this knight e2 move are
we witnessing the unraveling of a
brilliancy after all we got 5 000 bucks
yeah it's a it's a potential winner it's
a potential first uh
candidate candidate yeah we we haven't
had very many games so far and we want
to say good games but not brilliant uh
the the two decisive games uh the three
decisive games so far that we've seen
uh i mean magnus won a nice game against
yam but he played that game by his own
like he he said himself that it's
difficult to imagine how how you can
play wars like he said in an interview
yesterday he was looking forward to the
next yeah yeah he was he meant every
word he was absolutely disgusted with
his own play and you know
uh i i recognize this emotion intimately
like i've done this so many times in my
in my life uh illustrious career uh and
uh uh
hans one won a very interesting game
against shah which i think shaq did not
play that poorly at all so i i thought
that was the front runner of the things
that we've seen so far but this looks
but this looks uh
very very curious now after knight e2 is
very obvious what
uh levon is facing and that is knight
takes f4 and uh
knight h5 and by the way with the
potentially open file and you also
pointed out queen c3 i'm seeing uh a a
lot of issues for blacks how are you
going to solve them i just want to check
for a second because please it feels to
me that levon is either already very
seriously in the tank or
he will be he will be soon because
i think this position uh is extremely
dangerous to navigate it's just very
very like if you make one more
suboptimal move here with black you
might never come back it feels like the
game might just be over you have to you
might have to play something incredibly
weird like king g6 sometimes is maybe a
move that you might be
uh well forced is a strong word but
horrifying i would very much like to try
to force you to play bishop take c4 but
not gonna do it no the thing is even
those positions might be quite good for
white but aren't you walking into h4
yeah i i don't know it just looks
extremely ugly but the fact that you're
the you you're um
you're looking at these uh lines with
kenji
king g6 goes to show that you're getting
a little bit
nervous
absolutely absolutely i'm i'm very
unhappy here terrifying
yeah and uh levon spent 11 minutes on
e-takes f4 which honestly seemed like an
only move and now after 92 he's already
been thinking for 10 more minutes and
hasn't made a move yet
so he's catching up to alireza quite
quickly and i don't think he's enjoying
things very much no and already and also
rook f1 rook takes f4 absolutely uh this
pin
uh alejandro clear our cobwebs we don't
like
the challenges that levon is facing this
peace sacrifice is diabolical
it's just bad for black it's just bad
for black bad for black the engines hate
black's position and not only that but
the path to survival this is very
intuitive i mean you guys were
mentioning king g6 ideas i'll point out
that the second move best move of the
engine in this position is bishop f2
check
just so that after king takes knight
takes e4 you get rid of the pin okay now
this is horrible because after takes
takes you could take on f4 immediately
you could play queen d4 first but you
are just down material with an awful k
right i mean this is losing
so
then just want to play queen e7
not
immediately clear what it's for but
after the move rook f1 then they want to
play the move king g6 whoa
yeah i know try good luck with that
the idea is that if you play king g6
immediately
then with the rook here on h1 the move
h4 is winning
and in certain situations yes you do
play for g5 so for h5 sorry so very
concrete difficult things to see this is
an engine idea to play queen e7 i think
the point is not that the rook is on f1
i think i figured out why it does that
if we if we put the queen on e7 again
yes rook f1 king g6 the idea here is to
play bishop takes c4 like you play h4
here and because there's a queen on e7
we can go bishop take c4 and after queen
takes c4 for the for the time being we
have queen takes e4 yes and suddenly
this is a much much improved version
because we've
uh we've returned material but we've
unpinned ourselves opened up the king on
e1 the king on g6 now is not getting
mated anymore uh this is just manageable
for black it's actually zeros yeah this
is this is fine but obviously white is
not obliged to be uh to be so helpful
after king g6 there are better moves uh
yes there are better moves than h4 for
sure uh the engine is saying that bishop
h4 or bishop even takes on f4 are better
for the white side simply because of the
weakness of the king now if levon does
find queen e7 rook f1 king g6 dangerous
don't think it's so terrible they don't
like the black position but it doesn't
really cross the plus one thinking well
yeah this is unpleasant the king is weak
probably i'm gonna have to shed some
material eventually but it's not like
you're going to have to shed the entire
chassette to defend the king so they
think it it's manageable still but levon
has to find some tricky moves in order
to just keep alive
uh
diabolical i'm i'm looking at this
position after king g6 peter and i'm
just
i'm kind of stunned there isn't uh a
checkmating uh pattern because the king
will have to continue running forward if
you play knight takes f4
yeah if like we play knight the four it
goes to g5 if we play queen g3 check
and
i'm assuming something goes to g4 and we
don't like bishop g4 probably
particularly here with the introduction
of the idea of queen takes e4 check next
move right but it's all extremely touch
and go because if you didn't have that
resource there you might just be getting
uh you made it completely overrun yeah
so rook takes f4 king takes g5 similar
ideas and again i guess uh well when g3
we go knight g4 bishop g4 whichever one
you like best right oh boy oh boy i mean
uh lavon uh i'm sure his
heart is uh pounding
in this position and we do have uh
our first result of a round three and
that's the truth unexpectedly uh as
expected in fact yes okay well
there and the other g5 game i wanted to
go to fabi uh versus wesley i think
wesley took a a good long time that was
uh that was a long time
g5 he played knight f3 but only after re
rejecting queen f3
yeah
i was actually surprised by how long he
took on that decision because queen of
three
really did not seem like it was uh it
was doing very much
uh
because of queen king g7 maybe he was
calculating a move like rookie one here
which honestly i'm currently a bit
curious about but i guess the point here
gh bishop h6 i think we've lost with
black right because the point of rookie
one is specifically that 96 is no longer
possible yeah exactly in this precise
position whoops because we have rook
takes e8 which we didn't have earlier
before the rook landed but i guess after
rookie one we can play one more kind of
a waiting of queen c6 or hp6 or
something quick six in particular right
five yeah you saw queen b5 and some uh
and uh
similar position
and the point is
eventually white will still probably
have to play knight five check and that
solves so many of of black's problems
you you get to trade a lot of pieces you
are left including this undeveloped
bishop after a knight f5 check yeah
sorry peter yeah so we we're left with
the uh
very nice bishop on the six against a
very restricted bishop on e3 the queen
will come back to d7 we'll play rook e8
we have absolutely zero issues here
compared to knight hf3 which as we've
discussed earlier the move that that
wesley did play
whatever you're challenging whatever you
do with black here you're definitely
being uh being very seriously challenged
so the surprise is not that he played
the surprises that he considered
the other options for so long exactly
exactly and here i had kind of
more or less my hand gravitated towards
this move knight f1
and uh well we'll see a lot of a lot of
pieces still uh on the board
absolutely now the phone does look
extremely logical i mean you could make
some argument for queenie too but i
don't really like
uh queenie two i think the neither one
is more concrete when we left it we
rather felt that the opening between
magnus
and hans had uh boomeranged
and that this kind of hybrid
system that the world champion essayed
against the nimzo indian had gotten got
him a slight disadvantage after rook d
won yeah
chosen by ancient came after
uh some thought yeah i'm pretty sure
hans went through the entire
specifically the same process that we
went through because one bishop d5 does
appear to just win the a pawn right so i
thought i'm pretty sure he saw that and
he uh spent some time trying to figure
out why he's being offered a whole pond
and yeah
which normally wins you the game right
but yeah as we've established both
knight knight e3 and knight h4 with
similar ideas and c4 as well as knight
f5 pointed out by alejandro
uh it seems to give white just the
compensation he needs rook c8 more
challenging peter
well you're not going to win this
version against the engine
but for a human being i guess he asked
me it is more challenging because if you
give black uh the tempo here to play
bishop b6 you might be in trouble uh
rook takes c4
there should be ways to uh to deal with
this uh concretely but for the time
being let's uh switch away from the
analysis of this uh the same game
because we have some
uh guests in the studio and in a moment
we will have
uh an interview
with uh shakhri armadarov all right over
to you alejandro
thank you guys shark mamadyarov with us
here in the studio
not much happened today or did we miss
something
of course
today i just want to play very solid
because
i lost yesterday very bad game
after i lose game i every time
i don't know
i can to lose after three more games and
i know myself and i just want to play
uh solid chess but i don't want to play
solid like
today but
i just want to play for two results draw
or win but
it was no
not any chance to play for win
and i just take g7
i mean i i want to play very solid draw
and at this moment
i'll just take knight g5 i think okay i
will take also we should just
if
give his knight but i can take three
pawn but after bishop g7 f6 i start to
think how to play draw now
and he was playing very quickly it
seemed like he was still within
preparation uh
no no no no
a maximum
of course
i remember this position but
i mean i i know
this typical position take f6 but of
course is
black is okay i just
try to play not miss
anything yesterday i played really bad
game i mean not very bad i just played
very bad
move a5
and after this i lost very easily and
today i just want to play very solid
talk a little bit about yesterday's game
we were a little surprised about your
decision in the opening to play this
move b6 instead of the normal b5 uh what
was your thought process there okay
i just want to play for
of course for win and
it was good chance good position to play
an interesting move
you can play b6 or
any move because where humans is easy to
miss in
in in this typical positions
i just play b6 of course i remember this
b5 move but eb5 is
he played very fast queen e3 of course
p5 he was preparing well i just want to
play b6 and just to play chess i mean
b6 is just to play chess i mean of
course i think 10 minutes prefer to play
b6 or not but it is move a5 it also
shocked me because a5 is back inside of
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah because you know it's like i
i think i announced his disposition
is and my
uh when you say analyze this position
you mean like prep or you during the
game yeah no no no no no event is after
queen e3 this problem says queen e3 move
back queen e3 yeah
inside queen e3
if not play queen e3 is
white can play is one of the best queen
g3 here
and rook e8 bishop d3 queen e6 rookie
one b5 same position oh wow
yeah i remember this position of course
so you actually got it from
transposition yeah especially i remember
it's my home preparation of the b5
because quincy iii it is bad move after
coin g3 i can't play b5 is the minimum
is black is very good puzzle i remember
this is my analysis and i remembered all
everything here till the b4 b3
everything
but is i remember is
move b3 yeah everything take bishop one
rookie one when i analyze this position
we were analyzed in board without in
jain i mean we announced this position
and i speak with my friend of course he
say you need push a5 a4 but after
i remember he said it is bad idea
the game i immediately okay i mean you
say of course this looks like a human a5
a4 but
of course i remember this one a5a voice
looks nice but after i remember this is
like a very bad idea but i played a5 of
course d6 i just calculated
i mean two means the sixth move here the
sixth take take and rookie three i think
this is a very bad position for black
because the very strong attack queen
schwarz g3 i absolutely missed the five
move here and there are 55 yeah after
the d5 is
very good position is close to win for
black
but i absolutely missed d5 and after d5
is why it is no attack i just
did miss and i played a5 as absolutely
because i remember this move in our
knowledge a5 but after
as a game i checked and said yes
is bad move
it is just bad move yeah shaq three
rounds already gone in the sing field
cup how do you feel your form here of
course is i'm not very happy with my
results but
it's very strong tournament and it's
everything can happen here i mean you
can lose
also
many many games it's not first it's not
last
and i know
[Music]
every day is i can lose and i can win
and of course for this reason when you
play in this tournament is
the
most important to think is life is
beautiful
and
as you know you need to just think
everything is good and you just play you
in this super tournament that you must
be very happy to be here and to lose or
to win okay is
obviously is is possibility every day i
mean to lose game and
to win for me it's lose
one game or two games or three games is
not surprising me i mean it's absolutely
normal and for this reason i am really
more
for more games for fighting chess more
interesting chess and also for more
results i mean to win or tools well
always on a good mood and hopefully you
don't lose two or three games we want to
see you win in that crazy attacking
style that you have thanks for joining
us and good luck in the rest of your
games thank you thank you very much
indeed check don't worry be happy peter
yeah it's just uh just such a sunny
outlook i i'm so envious exactly like
it's it's so so unusual to see this i
think this is something you should be
striving for but
very very difficult to attain this kind
of a mindset that
allows you not to get you know bogged
down with your results and not you know
over focus on
on your results because i think this is
a topic that has been discussed uh in
in like the field of support psychology
exactly
the idea that
your losses bring you more pain than
your wins bring you joy exactly is is
kind of well established right and you
if you can somehow defeat this mindset
or at least get close to defeating this
mindset it it will stand you in in great
stead and shock appears to be sort of on
his way and this is very very nice to
see and we have a social media graphic
that we'd like to share
with you uh ask the commentators peter
uh uh a question from brian loken uh
what do you guys think about having
rapid chess or 50 or 50 or 30 minutes
for games in the world championship does
it ruin chess history i mean
the question of sort of legacy concerns
and
that type of things are always very
difficult to judge right
it will be different
uh i feel that uh
abandoning you know quote unquote
classical chess altogether is
not something i'm very much looking
forward to for sure but
there is also this feeling that it might
be something that is eventually
unavoidable right much as i might hate
it or dislike maybe hatred is a strong
word i've become
over the years i've actually become a
lot more
uh
i enjoy resign no no no it's not even
it's not even that it's it's that i
actually enjoy playing faster time
controls more than i enjoy playing
classical now
which was definitely not the case let's
say 15 years ago maybe even 10 years ago
but i still feel that uh you know if all
chess eventually becomes rapid the blitz
chess it will be a pity because there
will be definitely like skill sets which
will be entirely lost
uh because they will just become
unnecessary
and and other things will come to the
fore
um
but
yeah i don't think we're there yet
we might get there eventually i'm not a
huge fan of uh of this this general
uh attitude but uh
clearly i you know i i might be in the
minority or will will will soon be in
the minority understanding what do you
think yeah well first of all let me uh
get ali a hundred uh
jump in there with his own uh take on
uh the role that 15 minutes or 30 minute
chess is going to play in
world championships and
your take are we talking about next
year's world championship are we talking
about 30 years from now because think
about it eventually eventually we are
going towards faster and faster
time controls what was the time control
in the 1920s 1930s we're talking about
germans i mean so many things in the
chess world have had to change
because we adapt to new systems now i
don't think that we should just get rid
of classical chess i think the classical
chess always will have its place
especially in the world championship but
as more the more chess progresses and
the more that we interact with it as a
sport especially as an esport the less
interest there will be on classical
chess specifically and it wouldn't
surprise me that down the road we're
going to have world championship matches
played in rapid now this might not sit
very well with a lot of traditional
players or people that prefer this long
matches but let's face it we're a sport
and we need to adapt and if that's what
the majority wants that's probably what
we will be getting eventually
for me i of course was raised with the
bobby fischer era these i even remember
the 1974 candidates final that was a 24
game match not a
4 6 8 12. 24 game match folks so i was
really raised with these and adjourn
games day well i've got to tell you i've
completely come over to the dark side if
you will i
really really really like um
well miami and what happened there with
the sets of games and in particular i
remember
calling a competition between hikaru
nakamura and magnus carlson it was the
finals of the chesable masters and it
was extraordinarily a great deal of fun
tanya and peter laiko were with me
calling the action we had 125 000
simul viewers one of the biggest
audiences i've ever seen in the chess
world simulcast i mean and i got to tell
you i just thought it was the cat's meow
it was just
so much fun
comparing that effect i will to the
recent uh match in dubai
which was tough
and that last that game six was it the
the marathon game that lasted seven and
a half hours
i needed two days to recover peter so
yeah i see 15 and 30 minutes taking on a
greater and a greater role
i yeah it's inevitable yeah greater and
greater role yes
entirely replacing classical chess i i
wouldn't be a fan but i understand that
this is the direction that we're moving
uh moving towards and also i i think
uh
you know the the the the seven the seven
hour time control uh is
probably going to get phased out
even that i feel like i'm i'm slightly
throwing on this because i i think
you grew up with the germans too yeah
yeah absolutely i i caught the the back
end of the germans era for sure i played
in some tournaments with the germans
whereas as a kid and by the time i i
hate my teenage years they were already
disappearing okay uh
i mean there's clearly even though i was
about to finish the sentence with there
is clearly no market for you know a a
seven hour live chess broadcast and just
as i say that
you know
norwegian tv
live streams magnus's games
millions of people watch it yes so i
think if you package it
uh properly and of course also if you
have magnus as a star which obviously
you know generates a lot of interest in
norway in particular
you can do that as well but i think
yes we we i mean seven hours is probably
a little bit too long but
as i mentioned i'm sort of resigned to
the idea that this is where we're going
towards
but i don't have to like it exactly a
good question uh from brian thank you uh
for putting us on the spot there we'll
we'll see how it evolves one thing i do
want to mention of course is that the
world knockout championship that was at
one time
the world championship itself features
uh rapid chess yes as well as blitz in
i'm not i'm not the purist in this
respect i i don't hate rapid chess but i
just feel that uh as with everything
i've always been uh
a proponent of you know exploring more
and more things without abandoning
what we already have you can you can
like as i said maybe seven hours is too
long and the the time control that we're
playing here in sinful cop produces like
five hour games
maybe five and a half if you have some
kind of a long technical end game uh
which which lasts until move 110 or
something
and this is
i i understand some people will still
think this is way too long but i don't
think it is i think this is fine let me
interrupt you and bring us back into a
game because we're talking about long
thinks and uh ironically enough i think
uh levan this is hufflepuff uh alejandro
we got a tank
33 minutes uh
by lavonne here and we know
uh what he's dealing with and probably
even considering the bailout with bishop
f2 check that's not a bailout bishop f2
might not lose immediately but at least
eventually he's down a pod with the
worst position i understand i understand
i'm just thinking though that those
i i guess we we didn't really refute
queen e7 rook f1 king g6 no
they said that both bishop takes f4 and
bishop h4 are dangerous for black and
that's what the engine says but the
game continues yeah the game the game
does continue here this is probably best
play but
without you know we we are very cozy
here yeah very comfy in studio
well you know with our engines and
alejandro
and alejandra we even navigate like
prompting the engines and
congratulations which is a very
important uh you know part of work
yes yeah but
to to actually commit to playing queen
is seven rook f1 king g6 over the board
for levon
is not is not an easy uh an easy ask no
it is not now uh
again we're going to let
lavon's do on that quick quick look at
the wesley game because again these both
players seem to be
slow playing the position maybe i've got
it wrong but uh
not too many moves uh yeah now to find
that knight five knight f1 did happen
and then fabi developed the bishop to d7
and wesley made this very very quiet
move bishop c2 g3 which i quite like you
do yeah i think uh
our issue with white here is getting the
rook on a1 to e1 in as efficient a
manner as possible agreed and i think
specifically quincy two followed by
rookie one probably does that job very
very well and you didn't like the queen
d3 rookie i thought i thought the green
on d3 was perhaps somewhat misplaced
yeah yeah yeah perhaps maybe
specifically because it does sort of
invite knight g7 which by five knight g7
rookie one bishop f5 i very very much
want to trade the trade that pair of
bishops i understand
it's one of my dreams in life in this
position as black is to get those
bishops well one player on the other
hand who did seem to be enjoying uh
i
dare i say a significant edge
uh was a linear we do have this move
bishop g5 maybe the most challenging
probably on the boards yeah peter take
it away and uh yeah if the bishops come
off the board the the knight will come
to c5 unchallenged then it is despite
the structure looking extreme i should
be switching five knight c5 immediately
right that was the problem right yeah
if you go hg maybe who knows i go back
with rook but it's pleasant but maybe it
was a little bit more feel for all of
the immediate knights e5 sorry but of
course you play rook c4 you're this is
why we played knight g2 at least one not
here i mean on the previous one sorry
yeah
this is why we played 92 we played 92 to
play rook c4 i agree uh quimby five
exists but it probably there's a bunch
of issues yeah first of all yeah i
blundered queen to originally i thought
before was just winning but we can take
on b5 and play let's say rook before
here we are
about
probably
uh oh you also talked about stream
structure a moment ago there's some
there's some real issues here for for
for a very pleasant choice here for
white because i think it will be up upon
regardless of what we do the question is
which one we prefer the d6 g5 where i
think i think i prefer before but this
one also is quite promising uh-huh right
here right
before here bishop b3 fe the b5 pawn
falls full stop because rook c5 knight
b3 doesn't really help you very much no
it doesn't i think winning the b5 pawn
is this is the the
tastiest of the bunch yeah but one of
many i mean it's going to be a full
harvest coming up so we i think the
point is jan will be forced to go knight
c5 okay and then we take on c5 and
black does end up not losing any
material immediately but that's
structure it's terrible
only if this rook was on a1 and i could
play knight c4 i would just that would
be like playing the game at the end of
game but the the lucky break here for
jan is exactly what you're saying yeah
we have to play knight f3 probably which
actually puts our knight two squares
away from the ideal square we're
actually misplacing our knight here by
playing out of three how dare we
black is not dead yet but of course this
is not enjoyable no no it's not not
enjoyable at all not not at all uh
lanier liking the way this game is going
um alejandro and if you have to put a
numerical number on the advantage it
would be 0.9 only only 0.9 that's what
every time i think but it's precisely
because of the variation that you guys
were looking at with the move knight f3
at the end and bishop f6 if you put it
on the board right there bishop f6 at
the end it says that yes you are better
but your rook on c4 is still very clumsy
and it's going to take some time to
bring it back i don't know what black
does in the meantime but they somehow
managed to put up a defense speaking of
defense we have the world champion who
is a little bit on the back foot against
the wild card well they're both
qualifiers hans niemann and he has
somehow sacrificed a pawn let's take a
look at what happened in this game
we left it off here after the move rook
d1 and rook c8 hans didn't want anything
to do with rook takes d1 knight end
games and after 92 bishop e6 there are a
couple of
solutions here for white to defend this
pawn first of all it's not really attack
knight e4 knight takes f6 could get back
both pawns in some cases but the world
champion just goes c4
if you think with the knight very clear
you lose b7 right the question is what
happens if you take with a bishop
now
the obvious one is knight e4 you hit
this pawn and if knight if king g7
happens you play knight d6 and you're
hitting the rook the bishop the pawn
you'll get something back even if you
don't knight f5 check is going to be a
little bit of an issue you can't play
rook c7 because 98 wins
so
uh that is what i think is the obvious
human answer
but magnus is thinking here for a while
and i was wondering what else can he
think about the first instinct was
knight takes c4 rook takes e4 rook d7
now i'm going to get my bishop to d5 i'm
threatening to take on b7 but
unfortunately this runs into rook c1
check king d2 and ip3 check and since
this knight can get back to c5 now hit
the rook defend b7 and this king is
extremely awkward on e3 black is
definitely in the driver's seat
what the engine wants to do is the
surprising part
play f4
and after pawn takes f4 which is by no
means forced
day goes d4 now
because after rook takes e4 you don't
capture on f4 you play rook d7 and the
threat of bishop d5 is so strong and
when i say strong it's just for equality
right but strong uh that it doesn't
matter that i've shed two pawns after
pawn takes pawn takes the idea is that
i'll have f2 for the kings after rook c1
so you're actually purposefully
gambiting the f pawn just so that you
have this escape square and since the
knight is so far away bishop d5 taking
on f7 is going to be an equalizing idea
but that's all we're talking about here
for magnus it's equal equalizing with
the white pieces in this end game
because let's face it if he doesn't he
is in a bit of danger
indeed and peter i want to say that
that's an extraordinary quality that
i've seen in world champions time and
time again they're in a bad position
they're in a bad position and they
seized that moment to force a draw and
you didn't even realize that you were so
much better at the time that they're
making
a two-pawn sacrifice for played by the
way and this is neither of those two
choices that alejandra was mentioning
magnus could be
uh headed towards some some you know
turbulence because well just a second
doesn't force cf4 anymore i can go i
don't know maybe rook c7
ah
ah with the knight on d2 i'm not playing
knight
you're not obliged to capture and allow
me to i i beg your pardon yeah we're not
using the same position
rook d4 maybe is a move because a3 is
quite weak although this takes takes
bishop d5 maybe i shouldn't be doing
that
but
your
your initial instinct there yeah
or rook c7
but i wanted to say that a lot of these
world champions they do find these ways
of making a defensive combination
because that's what you would call this
good enough for equality uh we're always
looking for you know white to move and
win but how about those white to move
and draw variations uh knight takes c4
rook takes c4 on the board on the board
here for me uh like
in
among the people i played uh a lot
against
uh a very very striking example has
always been uh vichy
now because i've you know from a certain
point i stopped getting good positions
against him but when we just started
playing in the mid-90s i did get a bunch
of very promising positions against him
i won zero of them
not a single not a single classical
victory over over vicio for like 25
years of trying
and i noticed very early on his uh
ability to
recognize danger like the moment he
understood that something has gone wrong
he would very often
go into a very serious tank
uh figure out
the exact way to defend from there the
best plan of defense from there and then
he would
sort of zero in on that
and start playing extremely quickly like
it was it was both a combination of
unique chess understanding he's a very
very deep chess player i understand he
understands game
excellently well but also this
recognition of where to switch gears
where to switch to sort of full-on
defense
and he also was an extremely extremely
good practical player and remains an
extremely good practical player which
meant that right once he's established
his best
in his opinion the best choice of
defensive plans
he will start playing extremely quickly
also putting a lot of pressure on you on
the clock
making it as awkward and as difficult
for you to
convert your advantages as it's possible
and in the meantime we have a very
interesting move there by levon which i
assume
uh it's a 42 minute that came after a
42-minute think uh
and it doesn't lose right away c7 c6
that looks like a terrible uh
move uh
alejandro that's not a terrible move
that's not an idea
what's the idea between a5 check queen
a5 check is the yeah the idea is 25
check it's understandable actually
because there is no particularly great
reply to q5 check currently meaning that
let's say we play knight xf4 black
replies with the check before bishop
takes before just straight up loses not
because the a1 rook is hanging but maybe
even more because the g5
bishop
the one that was doing all the damage
too and then and then black gets the
tempo to play something like knight h7
let's say we play king e2 or something
here uh my question would be what
happens if we cast along but at the very
least it gives us a tempo to play bhp3
check yes which protects the pawn on f4
and also gives us a move to play maybe
queen a5 next move anyway right so yeah
the one that's the freight well puts me
off is queen c3
check i don't know this is still being
what am i i'm so dumb today
maybe
just
i remember were you in manila in that
interzonal no where um it was uh
it wouldn't i wasn't born
it's true though
no i mean that's okay
was playing against granda zuniga
and grande zuniga had made a combination
with the last move was bishop f2 check
michael gervich took the bishop at the
same time
uh restrained his hand from playing
knight takes e4 check with it's illegal
[Laughter]
it was a pretty hilarious moment so
probably not not for whoever though not
foreign exactly
but it was it was one of those great
moments uh okay alejandro c7 c6 not the
greatest move maybe not the best
the the the worst move
uh
huh how will ali ray's uh deal with c7
c6 yes only one choice if he wants to
keep his advantage
castles bishop e3 is an issue as you
mentioned knight takes f4 queen a5
actually just loses
queen c3 loses to king g6 king g6 once
again yeah there's absolutely nothing
here knight takes d4 is coming so you
have to play b4
it does have logic it prevents the move
queen a5 and at the same time it attacks
the bishop so that's pretty nice uh the
problem for black is that after bishop
e3 rook f1 and only rook f1
the attack just kind of keeps going and
there are so many positions in which the
e3 bishop is just straight up hanging
for example if i move my queen
somewhere out of this diagonal something
like even queen b6 c5 wins a piece right
so this puts too much pressure on
black's position but it doesn't lose
immediately you can still think of moves
like king jae like queen liking g6 and
try to continue on b4 already played on
the board i think it's a very logical
move considering what levon just played
what was the only idea of the move queen
a5 let's stop it with the tempo i expect
to move bishop e3 the engine doesn't
want to play that it still wants to play
bishop f2 check let's call it a bail out
in that sense uh queen b6
takes takes is another idea of the
engine to give back the piece but this
also looks terrible after bishop takes
f4 remember that you're down material
and the this particular position d6 is
going to be hanging not to mention that
your king is weak so b4 bishop e3 as i
expected is already on the board as i
mentioned rook f1 is the only good move
here for white but it's also a pretty
logical move wow and and what's up
once again alejandro you're saying that
the move queen 63 yeah followed by g6
h4 knight
knight e4 knight takes f4 7 king h7
and this crazy position
it's just good it's just good for black
yeah i don't think this is so surprising
we're down a piece
but the queen is hanging i've got moves
like queen d3 there's always a check
from a5 right and then i will stabilize
somehow i don't think this is shocking
uh we've seen a lot more shocking
positions in the analysis of this game
but i think this one isn't really all
that shocking at all yeah it's just lost
it's like minus five and by the way
yeah breaking bishop e3 on the board by
breaking news on another board uh this
line did happen in yann nipomnishi's
game against uh uh
lanier but after bishop takes c5 jan
played bishop takes g2 saying i don't
want to have this horrible bishop on g5
instead of knight on potentially
eventually on c4 the problem with that
is that it loses the bishop takes d6 but
that's not so difficult to calculate is
it uh
it's the only thing that wins but it
means kind of convincingly i i'm
cheating here i'm not trying to be smart
uh queen takes e4 queen b7 check
and then wherever the king goes we take
on f8 it's threatening meter on g7 and
we take on g2 next move and we're two up
two
yeah rook fighter d2 where like it's
it's kind of bad i don't think you even
need to you know
elucidate on this point it's just
completely lost you can play rook c7 at
the very very end there move 25 instead
of rook takes a fade
well maybe here can i uh
what what oh sorry
queen b8 we can play queen b6 even maybe
queen b6 maybe is the one that i would
choose keeping most things under control
you have queen e2 but the rook will go
to f1 i guess stabilize completely i
don't know why we're inviting rook c8
back but maybe we should i don't know
let's go queen b6 instead if you like it
okay yeah let's go questions
yeah but this is really
i mean bishop takes d2 alejandra this is
bishop takes d6 it's not a difficult
calculation
it's just that you it's not attacking it
should be managing i'm attacking the
rook on f8 and i'm just trading and two
buttons ooh
that's not hard not not i mean bishop
takes queen takes queen b7 is very
obvious this just loses i'm attacking
the rook so you have to change the
queens queen e7 i take take brook takes
rook text rook t2 that has to be a lost
end game even if you get one back right
right like let's just like go through
that line no this is i mean this is just
lost you'll get a five congratulations
you got a five your structure is
terrible and i'm up a pawn right you
don't survive this yeah you pretty much
never survived this
and that's that's the only line because
this this straight up loses
i mean king g8 i think maybe he missed
that after no matter where the king goes
bishop takes f8 threatens checkmate
maybe he thought he had a queen e2 in
her meso or something right i'm not
really sure
because
yeah king g8 takes rook c7 and here
queen b6 and queen b8 win but also queen
b4 wins just holding on to the bishop
queen e2 rook f1 is no problem yeah we
pretty much always queen into rock f1
and then
let's say in this mission after queen b6
yeah maybe like you you might have like
this idea that queen queen ii followed
by rook f7 creates creates some kind of
a threat but there's really nothing to
see bishop there's a threat there is a
threat right there's uh
yeah
but you always have this bishop
returning here solidifies the entire
position and now i'm up two points and
have the better position
wow
as we get ready for our second break i
just also say about the magnus carlsen
game
uh these two wild card players playing
for first surprise to begin with but the
fact that uh hans is the one in the
driver's seat and uh
this game is even more surprising you
don't want to miss the conclusion
absolutely
stellar tournament so far by the young
americans absolutely and we'll see on
the other side of the break
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
united states
the st louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant central west end has
established itself as a premier global
destination for chess and is comprised
of two unique non-profit institutions
the chess club and scholastic center of
st louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays host to
all major tournaments including the us
chess championships and the sinkfield
cup one of the strongest chess
tournaments globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries led by an expert
commentary team of grand masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess with a specific focus on
bringing the benefits of chess
research shows children who play chess
exhibit improved analytical skills and
increased confidence the chess club is
highly engaged with the local community
bringing scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 schools providing hundreds
of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club is the world chess hall of
fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the u.s and world chess halls
of faith
cutting edge exhibitions feature rare
historic chess artifacts paired with
world-class art innovative programming
explores the intersection of chess art
and culture
visitors can enjoy interactive programs
designed around the exhibitions and
monthly music in the galleries
the world chess hall of fame is nothing
you expect and everything you love three
different galleries and a premier gift
shop highlight the culture history and
creativity behind the game come visit
play chess leave enriched
to learn more about the st louis chess
campus visit stlchestcampus.org
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so welcome back to our coverage of round
three of the sinkhole cup with plenty of
very very exciting positions and uh lots
to discuss and we we went on the break
with this idea that jan nipomnishi
is trying to solve his problems
tactically and should now lose uh should
linear find the right continuation
we know the answer now the right
continuation was not found by a bilinear
and
he is still a bit better but nowhere
near as crushing an advantage as he
would have had absolutely after the
bishop
and the
pairings for the round
uh the current standings are as follows
we have one draw
that was played earlier between czech
and mvl not too much happened basically
in that game that game wasn't very
exciting but the interview was excellent
i really every time every time we speak
to shakaria i think it's just
very very
very very nice to hear his thoughts
about his approach to chess return to
lanier and uh
young for a moment this is where we left
it we just saw that
there's this really nice tactical
sequence that all began bishop takes d6
and as we left it we had mentioned queen
takes b7 bishop followed by the shape of
fate
it's all good and it's all good and and
wins basically and wins and on the break
we were also discussing with with
alejandro the fact that
as long as you
tell yourself to continue calculating
it should be a variation a player of
linear's caliber
finds calculates to the end and confirms
as correct
in about five minutes because exactly it
seems like a very very there's not very
much branching going on all of these
moves are forced you take on d6 spin
take c4 is very easily identifiable as
the only chance we take on b7 with check
next move we take on f8 we pick up a
full rook we create a thread of queen
tanks g7 right we know that if we get to
play rook takes d2 we will win so rook
c7 really is the only thing you might be
worried about right but then as we've
established pretty much any sensible
queen move b6 b8 even before
and then yeah and then you get to some
kind of a position like this you get to
bishop c5 and here i think you can stop
exactly your two pawns up e6 is hanging
f2 is very very safely protected
i think
i in every piece i've got
pretty much
so
it's it's a bit surprising to me uh
honestly truly honestly that lanyard
i think that lanier had is when you get
to this position too you also kind of
convince yourself my goodness i've got
everything i've got the open file i've
doubled on the open file furthermore
after king e7 that's a kind of a
wandering king
b2 b4 and he's just played b takes c5
there which is a cute move i did not
consider at all yeah this should be
killing
because after queen b5 basically box now
uh lanier doubtlessly was calculating a
mate
right
yeah this thing rook of seven here uh
this was the this is the maid i saw yeah
i'm not sure i'm not sure this is what
he's going to like if if if we reach
this position after king e8 yeah i get
the feeling it might not even be rook
dis 26 it might not be queen d6 sorry
because queen six rook of seven
you have you have a queen ending but i'm
not sure it's winning i have a feeling
that maybe rook takes no but that also
doesn't work
do you think that's something with queen
h5 i was trying to take something like
b7 or g7 and then greek yeah i don't
know create a threat of queen d7 made
but the point is that we're just not
taking on c4 queen takes e4 i think is a
big mistake we can play something quiet
here like fg8 perhaps
okay and then from lanier's point of
view this is why he doesn't play bishop
takes d6 he's calculated this i mean
lanier's big problem is that he has five
minutes left
he's calculated he goes
calculated a lot this is a big problem
but uh
this move uh b takes c5 was he right no
alejandro absolutely not he's right if
he takes the rook but you don't have to
take the rook as peter mentioned rook
fd8 fighting for the control of the
d-file good enough for equality another
move that's good enough for equality
rook c7 just hold on to your position
here you can take on a5 at some point if
you play rook before i've already
defended the pawn on b7 so this is
according to the engines not a big deal
for the black side this was a huge miss
guys and b takes e5 has more than one
way to be defended against uh now let's
show what does happen if queen takes c4
rook d7 check king e8 now as you
mentioned peter queen d6 doesn't quite
win rook f7 is just a draw according to
the engines in the queen end game uh
instead you have to find the move rook
takes p7 i don't think it's the most
difficult move to find queen d7 is
checkmate but queen h5 is also going to
be devastating in some variations but
it's very difficult for to defend
against this move because the desirable
rook d8 runs into the aforementioned
queen h5 this is the variation in which
this is important because the king is
now caught you don't have the move king
d8 and there is just no good way of
defending that square on uh d7
for example if you play the move rook f7
uh this time you could go into the queen
end game but even much more powerful
just pin the rook and again you don't
have a good way of defending it on
because of the pin on the diagonal so b
takes e5 i don't expect nepo to miss
something like this rook c7 or rook ft8
will be played but let's update our
amazing game here between ali reservoir
ruja and levon aronian for me certainly
already a candidate for the brilliancy
price and one of the things that makes
in my opinion a great brilliancy price
is not just the one side rolled over the
other but that they put up the best
resistance and that still it was a very
interesting and fun game to watch and
that's exactly what levon is doing after
the move bishop e3 rook f1 was found by
alireza and instantly king g6 was played
now here the engines did prefer the move
bishop h4 over what already played h4
but not by very much it shows a very
logical move it just holds on to the
bishop and now it's difficult to even
find a move for black because e5 is
going to be a threat in many positions
if the queen leaves randomly bishop
takes f6 and queen takes e3 let's
remember is still on tap regaining that
piece and not to mention that of course
all the ideas of knight takes f4 are
still available so what did levon do
here he sacrificed his bishop back
bishop takes c4 queen takes e4 with the
idea of d5 and trying to regain some
space trying to create some threats of
his own because remember this king is
going to be stuck in the center forever
as long as this bishop is on e3 if you
take with the pawn things for the temple
i'll take with the queen is this bad for
black according to the engines yes it's
still bad for black but you're surviving
you're still keeping yourself in the
game you're still making moves you're
not dropping material and live on giving
himself a very strong fighting chance
currently the time situation 40 minutes
for lareza only 21 for levon and only 19
moves of chess has been played haven't
played in this particular game all to
play for now the engines don't like e
takes d5 as much as they like this
kind of tricky move queen b3 what's the
point simply to take on f4 in the next
position and remember that with the
queen on the third rank you are still
threatening that bishop on e3 in many
different variations in case that this
queen goes somewhere now bishop takes f4
is also a threat so that i can take with
the knight i've regained my piece so i
can try to keep the attack going on for
free now if you play the move queen c3
your run into knight takes e4 now that
the king is not on g7 very importantly
so that's why the move uh queen c3 is
not playable if you go down the line
bishop takes d8 knight takes e3 you
could take my knight but i'll take your
bishop this simply does not work for the
wide side d5 great move by levon this
bishop takes c4 and d5 the engine's
still loving white but he's creating
chaos on the board continue the line
please alejandro
d5 queen b3
yeah and if you take on e4 then i'd go
rook d1 right and then you mean with the
player
yeah in this case no rook d1 does not
win because look at this beauty
boom
um
you play knight d4 you're actually worse
right and if you do this
that's
perpetual
oh
that's nasty another there's a very cute
line unfortunately also knight
wow oh so you can't play d takes e4 what
what could levon do you resist the
engines think is suitable for this
position to keep the game going is the
move queen d6 you're getting out of the
pins or you're finally threatening
something like knight takes on e4 or
something like that and you keep an eye
on the knight so that if you take one f6
i can take back with the bishop remember
that if i take with the king queen takes
e3 so i'm gonna always gonna win but
taking with the queen on f6 actually
gives black a decisive advantage because
you're taking on a one next move it
gives you the important tempe to bring
everybody into the game so queen d6 is
an important move uh the engines suggest
that you should take on f4 bishop takes
f4 uh sorry take with the bishop so that
you gain the tempo on the queen
queen on e7 better than on e6 for
reasons we'll analyze that in a little
bit and now both queen g3 queen g3 and
e5 or e5 immediately you count the pawns
white is still up a pawn in this
position i'm gonna be able to long
castle and this king on g6 well it's not
a very broad
so black white's got the pawn he's got
the initiative but it's still not so
easy because the knight on e4 will be
pretty annoying it is controlling a lot
of important squares because of the
presence of the pawn on h4 i can't hide
my king on h7 so we'll still have quite
a long game before alerts i can even
think of converting his advantage
not quite a knockout blow but
as alejandro was saying where you can
resist uh you've got hope right
picking up on a heavyweight
all-american game wesley so fabiano
again
not too much has happened but at least
white's rook has managed
peter to get to the e-file uh but
uh a rather dull game at the moment i i
find
a maneuvering game but i think it's it's
sort of on a slow boil but it could uh
it could actually become quite concrete
very often
in a lot of situations because
with the queen on b3 and it's
interesting that uh wesley chose to play
queen b3 and not queen c2 we were
discussing bishop d3 with the idea of
queen c2 but uh he went for the more
with the more aggressive placing of the
queen here
uh interesting that uh fabie chose not
to even pretend to protect the pawn on
b7 saying that i will have a lot of
government to play there with ruby
right but now after rookie one perhaps
we want in some positions to play c3 c4
here as white and put maybe some
pressure on the g5 pawn
knight three g2 uh trying to smoke out
the knight on e4 i think the knight 24
is by far the best piece
currently black has blocking off yeah
the diagonal block blocking the diagonal
and the uh the the e file
so knight g2 or perhaps bishop c1
followed by
some knight to g2 is is another idea you
can go for and if you imagine the knight
only four actually getting uh
the shift shifted back to f6
you can definitely uh whoa okay this is
extremely concrete because this is
generally as we've been discussing
strategically i would be very very loath
to make this move
i really don't like the idea of uh
trading away that horrible bishop on e3
while also developing the knight on f1
to the e3 square i think it's connected
with the idea of playing a five straight
away but
then after c4 it's like it becomes a
bridge i start i start wondering about
uh these patch keys because then i can
toss in knight e5
the rook is invited to b2 i get that
but i'll have some invite sure you know
and also specifically i think c3c4 in
this particular position might just be
winning because guys really it's a lot
more game leave it alone yeah let's
update what happened in alaresa's game
because let's do it things are going
very furiously here queen b3 was found
and not queen d6 but the move rook e8
now the engines don't think this is
terrible but they definitely thought
that queen d6 offered a much better
chance now there's two good ways to
follow this up with you could take on f4
here and check so that when the king
moves somewhere you simply long castle
and what's the issue here yes material
is even once you take on e4 but check
out the difference
between this position and the other one
in this one i have a knight not a bishop
which means that i can either hop to h5
or if i calculate very well take on d5
exactly and this wins
now this is one way of doing it the
engines are thinking that you could also
take on f4 with the rook
and the idea is that after bishop takes
king takes again you do this and now you
keep the pin right they're not they
don't think that it's as good they do
prefer the more natural move knight
takes f4 to be sorry bishop takes f4 to
begin with but either way huge advantage
for alireza in this position he has his
pick i think bishop takes f4 is logical
if you
uh calculate that you have to play king
h6 in this position because of the
aforementioned knight takes d5 and once
you see that this is the only move that
just looks very juicy right it looks
terrible but by the way i just love
keeping my opponent in pin could you
pursue that rook takes f4 for just a
second absolutely uh rook takes there
for uh
knight takes uh king has to go back we
castle long yes uh what on earth can
black do here he's in a pin you're
threatening to take on d5 you gotta you
gotta move out of the pin right exactly
and you've got knight h5 yeah so queens
of seven or queen d6 has to be the move
okay so uh i don't know if they matter
too much for the difference and we take
ones we take once and here apparently
black has options you can play something
like queen e5 or king g8 your position
is terrible right but you are not that
let's put it that way
not that that's not the key yeah ooh
but very very nice and
i just wanted to
check in once again on the game between
magnus magnus has a pawn down but we
don't think it's serious why peter
well
it's uh
i think it's mainly because of the
dominance of the bishop on d5
over the night on a5 and the the pawn
weaknesses that magnus is currently
beginning to kind of
gently massage here rookie 8 i think is
a very good indication of where his mind
is at uh because if black goes king of
six which is the most natural move in
the in the world you just go to kh8 here
attack that one with check you can't
really give up the h pawn the h pawn
actually is kind of important so we go
back and after rookie if you have to
consider again currently i think hans
can play uh rook
c5
okay because after rook takes e4
actually maybe we can take right because
after king f6 f4 there is a knight c6
yeah but the bishop takes e6 i haven't
uh immediately takes f5 rook five here
okay 500 i don't think i lose material
and if you have to play king of six
after f2 f4 sorry i i'm i'm
oh it's rook takes effect okay seven
exists ah excuse me i'm like oh yeah i
i've just shattered three pawns in in a
row in the game yeah sorry so i think i
can take after roxy five king of six i
was i was worried about king of six i
thought maybe after king of six f4
for the time being we're a bit stuck
with white because we don't really have
a good next move perhaps
but also it's very unclear what black is
doing here because any of the knight
moves will just allow us to liquidate
into what i assume it's just a draw on
rook ending with the rook on h8 can i do
all of this stuff with the rook on h8
now no i think i can take on h6 right
because i have rook d6 then and now you
have rook i have rook d6 and i really
don't think you can play king seven and
play for a win i think that's a little
bit no that's not what i was uh aspiring
for
uh most certainly uh okay a little bit
dull i agree white's got competitive
position
he did find rook cc he didn't fly rook
c7 and now after roxy 7 rook before
queen c5 queen b3 has been played linear
is playing on five minutes here against
55. so you know the one thing that jan
has going for him in this game is
extreme
extreme speed of play yeah which which
did bring some let's call them
inaccuracies but yeah
he got he got uh
um what's the word amnesty
uh pardoned pardoned hard and far okay
uh which again brings us to the ali raza
game uh what's the clock situation
here in this one peter half an hour for
alireza against 22 ish 21 and a half for
uh foley one this is only move 20. if
they continue thinking and there is
plenty to think about here which could
be in for a very interesting time
trouble potentially wow this is this has
got a lot of action you
you you see this position for your for
the first time like bang
uh am i looking for a whip yeah i mean
white is clearly much better the
question is whether you can find
something that puts the game instantly a
little bit yeah or if you still have to
play some position which will offer
uh some hopes for for black but yeah
with white you're very very happy
okay and i think as alejandro said i
think the position of the bishop before
the only move is bishop takes a four you
can't possibly you know rookie forbes b3
will never work so you have to take on
f4 not the fourth chair
yeah the only square is h6 even
realizing that it's not yeah we just
castle quick queen side here you take on
e4 with whatever you like to take on e4
with i guess knight maybe and this is
where you calculate knight 95 works less
well if you don't have rook to xf7 with
check next move but let's say we just
played g2 g4 in this position probably
not the best move by far but even this
very simple idea g4 followed by g5 check
followed by knight h5 knight of six
we know we have a free role here with oh
yeah we know being great we might not be
winning as such just yet
but we know we know we have a very very
pleasant free role right so it's it's a
happy situation here foreign he can
spend some time looking for more right
because perhaps he is you know if he
calculates very precisely he can find
something that absolutely
puts it beyond any doubt right but he
has this very very nice fallback right
just a common sense common sense
fallback position which gives him a very
large advantage my prejudice uh peter i
don't know if you were you know nailed
uh in the same manner that i was i
always loved to keep my opponent in a
pin yep so i would always find these
types of uh
calculations attractive of course of
course you calculate this but the
question is i mean the problem is that
rook takes e4 will happen you will have
to trade and then we can't cut
this is why i'm not as much in love with
this if i could play yeah if i could
play long castles here i would be doing
this in a heartbeat right but because
the king gets stuck on e1 i assume we
play something like rook d1 and black
makes a move right i don't know which
move maybe queen b6 even uh trying i'm
not afraid of uh trying to pretend queen
juventuck is a threat i don't know if it
is i i might just
like maybe maybe you just you just call
my bluff here and win yeah yeah it's
very possible well again rook d6 uh
taking advantage okay let's let's go
let's go queen c7 i guess you know yeah
and i think that was
well queen c7 i thought was kind of
required because otherwise queen g3 but
all right uh
shall we yeah
you you you get this far rather quickly
and yeah rather in a snap yes and then
do you pull the plug and say well i
don't have a win you spend you spend
some time looking at queen moves in this
position like you look at queen e3 and
c3 all of those moves you see three uh
like black goes i guess knight h5
and start threatening to stabilize y
maybe some end games or f7 f6 yeah and
that's maybe not the best move
because after g4 i don't have a good
reply um
knight g4 maybe knight g4 i understand
this looks extremely dodgy but then
again like if i get to play f7 f6
my pieces around the king will start
looking a lot more consolidated like
give me give me a move here and i will
play f6 or rookie eight or maybe even e4
e3 with the idea of queen g3 check
gotcha and it might become a bit double
edged so
i think if i have to choose between this
one and the one after bishop iv and long
castles
i want my king on c1 you want your king
i want my king on cyborg
i want my king on c1 and the attack to
continue aleandro over to you what's
caught your eye let's take a look at a
game that you guys were mentioning might
heat up
it's getting there we got fabiano
carrano with the black pieces against
wesley so and we had this position after
uh knight takes e3 bishop e6 was
fabiano's choice now let's take a look
at what's going on here the engines
loved the possibility of queen c2 what
is the point if you play the knight back
i this is a strategical game i removed
that important knight from the center
and now i have access to all your light
squares i can play bishop f5 i can play
h4 i can play a lot of things in this
position with a great advantage now what
happens if i play the move queen c2 f5
and the engines here were saying you
play g4
black play g5 you go g4 and it's just to
destabilize the knight there's not a lot
of choices here for black because i'm
taking on e4 next move and you just
cannot remove this knight anymore knight
f5 is going to crush you now that i have
a pin on the bishop on e6 so this is
completely unplayable instead of that uh
you have to
kind of shed the pawn with queen f7 but
after takes takes takes it's just a
terrible position again knight to five
is being threatened e5 is being
threatened yes you have the pair of
bishops but the knights are jumping into
such powerful squares that i'm going to
eliminate one very very easily and then
just get a decisive advantage instead of
that wesley didn't look in this
direction because guess what there's a
tasty pawn right here so he went for it
queen takes b7 of course we know wesley
member of the pawn grabbers association
and after rook b8 i expect the move
queen a6 yes already already played and
i expect a knight rook to come down to
b2 and now you have certain options here
for wesley knight d1 is one but i think
he's looking at this move knight c4
what's it's a
double attack on the bishop on d6 and
the rook on b2 yes the knight is
defending the bishop for now but i can
always eliminate that now you don't have
a choice but to take on uh c4
and then after bishop takes e4 this
starts to look good for wesley you're
attacking the pawn on c6 this king's a
little bit vulnerable yes white black
has a pair of bishops and a rook on b2
but they're not coordinating so well the
engines aren't as impressed as i was and
the engines are thinking that after a
move like queen b8 or even
more concrete queen c8 fabiano will have
real chances to survive this game
because of the aforementioned pair of
bishops in this position even though if
i looked at this i would be very scared
because i see the bishop coming to d5
maybe taking on c4 i am already down a
pawn and rook takes a two i don't have
time for uh it's not because of rookie
eight
and taking the bishop it's because of
rocaine and then just move the pawn
somewhere i have to give myself this
loft remember the bishop on
d6 is controlling h2 i cannot take this
bishop because rook a1 is checkmate and
this bishop is unfortunately for black
running out of squares you have to stick
it on a6 because if you play bishop e6
d5 just
catches that bishop so you have to go to
a6 and that's just a horrible end game
and that might be the thought process
that wesley has in this current position
and the reason that he's going for the
move queen takes b7 we're gonna see what
happens i the move rook takes p2 has not
been played yet that you don't really
see an alternative because you do need
to get your pawn back and i expect to go
in some kind of channels involving
knight c4 thank you alejandro breaking
developments going on in our game
between our co-tournament leaders peter
uh we saw after rookie eight yeah hans
continued to continue finding ways to to
keep the game afloat by playing 5v4 and
then this looks like yeah looks like
magnus
is uh is wrong with this move yeah it's
wrong yeah i think g4 is not great and i
think it's specifically not great
because you can start with rook c5
provoke uh rook g8 which really is the
only way to keep the shapes the rook off
of the e and then we take on g4 and it
seems like this is now very very risky
for magnus perhaps he is planning to
play rook d7 here
not to take
before rook c3 i guess and you lose the
a i mean
okay yeah seven king of six and the
issue is you like bishop to xf7 is not
that great and rook f7 king e5 is also
um
certainly um yeah because it should be
seven there should be seven gets mater
than three which is which is
but but this is why earlier alejandro
wanted to play f4
for white just so that he didn't
yeah like that taught in this pattern
yeah such such diagrams would not be you
know part of the part of the
conversation about the game right
so um the magnus says
i mean he's not he's not out of the game
yet but he's definitely feeling feeling
the pressure and uh what should he have
done instead of the move g4 should you
maybe something like e3 or f3 just yeah
give yourself give yourself some space
for for the king for the king yeah the
king is not going to d2 because of route
d7 so something like
maybe even h3 but g4 you say premature
because of
rook
c5
and
well okay so how how good how bad is all
of this
take take me down the primrose path uh
peter uh what say you alejandra
that's the best way to do it right
no the edges really dislike this for
magnus they think that this is uh
potentially a decisive mistake
black starts playing perfectly from here
on which is of course difficult but you
guys hit the nail on his head like grix
e5 is very dangerous for bla for white
uh you hit the bishop and it doesn't
have too many squares to go to i don't
think it's a difficult calculation so
i'm starting to wonder
what is magnus's idea what is he missing
is he trying to play rook d8 rook d7 is
just not enough
is he trying to go back with bishop a2
but in this case you have pawn takes and
you don't just don't have any
compensation for your pawn i'm not i'm
not sure
what he's calculated
that's where i'm still at a little bit
of a loss
what did he calculate to go into this
position because rook 65 is already on
the board and i think magnus is in huge
trouble
huge trouble uh give me a number one and
a half one and a half point uh ponds
wow that's huge trouble that's a lot
yeah and that's a lot somewhere like
five moves ago uh the uh the computers
were saying there's plenty plenty it was
like zero three somewhere around here it
was even maybe close to actual zero zero
zero but wow uh
this plan of just sort of passing and
then pushing the pawn to e4 which kind
of begs the question was there any
reason that uh magnus himself didn't i
don't know i think he wanted to stop
well not stop but maybe discourage
knight c6 rp8 sort of very heavily
discourages 96 because i think we're
taking right i think currently here the
big problem for black is that we're
taking and if b takes ruby 6 just wins
the pawn back
yes one of the pawns dropped so he was
he was trying to play against the knight
on a5 coming back into the game
but
and well okay
as magnus is realizing uh the error of
his ways uh alejandra what do you have
for us
well we said that this king
in this variation had to go to h6 that
king did not go to h6 it went to h7 and
after castle's knight takes c4 it's time
it's time for furuja to win the game he
has to calculate the following variation
knight takes d5 clearly you have to take
this knight right czech
king g6 and now this is maybe maybe the
hard part and actually not maybe this is
definitely the hard part of this
combination the winning move and only
winning move
is surprisingly rook takes d5
not that surprisingly honestly uh i
don't think this is very difficult
because why is that surprising yeah
we're talking i don't know why i'm
saying it's a surprise i saw the queen
i'm sorry i apologize but the surprising
part is after queen takes h4 queen f3
there is no defense okay this part is
different this is the difficult part
i spoke i spoke too soon knight f6
doesn't work
this looks like a very logical defense
bringing the knight back cutting off the
coordination of the queen and the rook
but here you have this move this move
queen h5 king g7 and rook g5 you win the
queen right and the resulting end game
because you have two extra pawns against
a very weak king which will probably
even cost you the b7 pawn at some point
most likely yeah i think the seven point
probably probably falls quite quickly
probably falls very quickly it's just
lost so it's a very forcing line it's
probably not the most difficult line to
calculate but you just have to make sure
that against queen takes h4 which is the
only move in this position because you
have to keep an eye on the king on the
king side that queen f3 there is no good
defense here for black so that's what
you need to check out there are a couple
of checks you need to calculate the
queen h6 queen h1 you have to calculate
knight f6 but i think this is all within
alarez's grasp he'll finite takes d5 and
transpose into a winning queen versus
rook end game because of he has way too
many pawns
wow
that would be a nice rebound win
for ali raza for sure
certainly when you talk about the grand
chess tour standings that would
definitely
dent
uh lavonne and again uh alireza thanks
to his victory in the rapid and blitz he
hit the trampoline for 13 gct
points to get himself in the mix
uh peter you're looking once again uh
let's take a look at those standings
sure let's let's take a brief uh brief
look uh maximum shale graph is currently
leading the tour with only one event
the one we're watching uh to go
he has a one point lead over alireza and
a four point lead over the uh two
players tied for third there they wanna
and wesley so there are only three three
prizes in the gc tour
of
standings uh overall so this is what
you're fighting for uh five is not out
of the running that needs a big result
yeah he probably needs to win the
tournament and he's not doing himself
any favors today put it that way
and let's just see how the fortunes have
changed with a very nice little graphic
here this is this one i really like i
really like this one yeah yeah this one
i really really faces were bouncing
around but it's the tri-colors it's the
french who are the leading of the great
currently currently on top yeah mbl is
having a solid tournament alireza not so
much until today but if he ends up
beating
uh
beating levon today this will be
obviously a huge boost to his chances
because not only is he winning the game
he's also beating somebody who is
definitely very much in the in running
uh rival for sure and you were saying
that fabi is not doing himself any
favors uh alejandro well i said that he
had to take a pawn because the pawn is a
pawn and after rook being queen a6 i was
just going through the lines after rook
takes b2 i'm wondering what's going to
happen after that even if you get a bad
end game you still have to take the pawn
right he didn't take the pawn
played f5
doesn't actually have a threat so wesley
defended his pawn
and now he's down a pawn and white is
definitely better not just because of
the extra pawn but i've shattered your
structure on the queen side the squid on
a6 is particularly annoying it's just
attacking a7 and c6 you have exposed
your king here so any further advances
if i get a queen here you're just going
to suffer right so you have to be very
careful on how to advance the pawns and
i don't i don't see a concrete plan i
move like f4 immediately loses to knight
c4
horrible move well knight g4 or knight i
like knight g4
but but if you're not playing f4 like
are you playing g4 is this the idea
because this loses kind of similarly
here here 95 is winning bishop takes e4
is winning this this really doesn't make
a lot of sense i'm i don't understand
the point of f5
like yes he just disliked xb2 so much
that he chose to just play basically
like anything else
a five here is a move that you can
describe as not rook takes b2 and yeah
we we are watching uh jan and lanier
shaking hands there because everything
got uh
liquidated and uh
a big uh big big lead off yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
uh and uh
and jan kind of like shaking his head
like yeah i was a condemned man and i
got the pardon and i thank you as often
as this often happens i i get the
suspicion that maybe he he played bishop
takes d2 and then went away from the
board and started calculating bishop to
existence and now is it the day of
pardons
oh no i mean in this position i get it
you don't
find knight takes d5 and everything we
talked about understandable
knight h5 is pretty strong
you put the knight in an attacking
square right and then you're threading
rook takes f7 you can maybe think of
rook f5 and maybe when the queen gets in
you'll throw it in checkmate right right
and if queen takes h4 i assume it's not
the sixth check right queen takes f4 h4
knight f6 is winning but rook takes f7
is more is even stronger yeah okay yeah
but knight f6 is good enough but why why
retreat the knight yeah that is a very
very strange choice
that's peculiar that is a very strange
choice i don't really understand this
move yeah and according to the engine
alireza has destroyed most of his
advantage still gives it like 0.4.5 but
we're talking about we're talking about
winning the game just like
black resigns type of winning the game
yeah that i mean 95 was clearly winning
by force knight h5 maybe slightly less
so but also you can you can understand
how it will be very very strong again 92
is
wouldn't it really have been on my list
no i mean 95 clear knight h5 clear even
queen of three i guess he wanted to stop
queen f6 i think his point is he
understands the knight needs to go
somewhere so that queen f6 doesn't land
that uh
but yeah if you're choosing a square for
the knight first of all i'm pretty sure
he calculated knight takes d5 i think he
missed queen of three in the end there
i'm pretty sure he got to the position
after rook takes d5 queen takes h4
and
rook f7 first but okay we can get there
by whatever move order we like just to
show off yours rook f7 can you six so
you get here and you realize you don't
have sensible checks all of your checks
lose a rook in one move uh and you think
black is about to start giving me checks
from like e1 or some square and the king
on g6 appears to be somewhat safe and
you could sort of give up here with
white you could stop calculating
i think you kind of
i think it's possible just not to
believe that queen of three is fast
enough
i mean you might not even want to go any
further because queen of three is a
quiet move black has like three checks
to choose from and also knight f6
so maybe he just didn't believe this was
winning but if you're choosing a square
for the knight choosing a 2 over h5 is
peculiar
really really cool
by the way just on on this note i i'm
looking at the sacrifice more and more
by the way
and
it really looks like okay sorry just to
just to go down the primrose path once
more
queen takes h4 you were saying
you know you you don't find queen f3 you
fight
but if you did find this move
um let me check there's there's going to
be some checks at least right just
remember that question
was the only winning move right
just remember that queen f3 was the only
winning oh
yeah
check here king b25 check yeah this is
where you maybe give up because you
realize that you know the game is very
much in progress here if you have to
play c2 c3 you don't have a threat
anymore if i don't because the queen is
no longer connected to the third rank i
just go rook g8 here and i claim that
i'm better here with black or something
right you've got two rooks and a knife
for a green after all yeah so in case i
go cheese yeah i think i think queen of
three is missable i think uh this is
this is why you don't play knight takes
d5 this i can very very easily relate to
okay uh but yeah choosing choosing e2 as
your best square for the night is
confusing me i i don't know why that
would be the case and then
as
alejandro was explaining that 92 retreat
uh throws away the lion's share of the
advantage
suddenly and why is that peter i mean it
still
would appear
that black's king
well it's vulnerable with the knight on
e4 i think we cover so many uh squares
from each show from which the king can
be attacked let's say we go king g8 here
just saying go ahead and just choose
your worst yeah just bring it back yeah
just cooking g8
and we ask uh we ask black yeah rook for
i can go
perhaps
i mean it's still awkward but
i'm thinking that on a good day peter if
i can get in rook f1
knight g3 you're i i hear you loud and
clear your knight on e4 is a great
defender it's it's still awkward for
sure yeah i thought i would be able to
play rookie six through g6 but i i run
into a problem there what's the problem
well maybe you don't even play rook g4
check okay so yeah maybe maybe this is
what i
do have yeah i don't like this yeah
i get like my problem here is that
alejandro told me i'm okay with black
sort of sort of but from a purely human
perspective i would still be quite
worried i would still be quite worried
here with black i would not be
maybe king g8 is just a mistake maybe
let's go let's go rookie seven instead
maybe it's actually safer on h7
that the king is yeah on h7 and then
maybe we can play for something like 26
queen h6 or queen f8 queen h6 some kind
of a play like this like if you play
queen f3 for instance right okay then i
go i got queen d6 and i think i'm with
this position i feel like i'm reasonably
uh jack-jack
this is uncomfortable yeah it is what
you're dreaming i get that you have rook
five
which is a nice move yeah but then maybe
we can play once again either queen d6
or queen queen f8 you give a check from
h5
or
rook f1 yeah and then i go finish six
check and then i go
perhaps
yeah queen g7 check and
i've stabilized to a degree right i've
covered uh and
it all is thanks to that knight on e4
which allows me not to worry about g5 in
any single position so i can put the
queen on g7 and perhaps even play king
h7 g8 later and not have to worry about
losing using
and as we
look at the ramifications on this i just
wanted to say that
alejandro is getting a special guest in
studio all miked up to share his views
of his draw today against uh nepo and uh
lanier is with alejandro
thank you guys here with linear
dominguez you drew today but you must
have felt that you had him
yeah i mean i felt that i had a huge
advantage of course after the opening it
was so nice
but i mean he kept playing fast and
i at some point uh of course i missed
this move bishop g5 but i felt that i
should have something very stronger but
i just couldn't find it i was
calculating and wasting all my time and
i didn't really
see the killing blow i mean i was
looking here at knight c4 but it doesn't
work it seems to me
oh you played this rook c4 yeah knight
c5
takes
yeah after bishop d2 i mean i saw bishop
d6
queen c4
queen b7 and then something like king g6
takes on f8 rook c7
i just didn't look clear to me um
he wants to play queen e2 maybe next or
something like that also king d8 i mean
instead of king g6
okay let me go back a little bit
no
sorry
king g8 yes you take here hey crooks is
seven rook c7 yeah we analyzed this
position actually on air um
i gotta ask what did you think was
unclear about let's say like queen b4 or
something along those lines well queen
e2 rook f1
um
yeah maybe like this
rook f7 bishop c5 yeah very solid yeah
it goes back to c5 and everything's
stable yeah yeah no i felt that it
should be winning of course but i i mean
he played so quickly and i didn't really
um i i just wasn't sure that this was
winning
and uh yeah i went for the safest option
but uh of course position is so bad for
black that there should be a win
do you think that psychology influenced
you a lot today he was playing so fast
and you were playing so slow that your
mind started believing your opponent
yeah i mean it's uh but on the other
hand he it's it's not that he
played like this just in this game i
mean he just plays like this in general
so of course it's uh not the most
pleasant experience when you're thinking
thinking and your opponent is just
blitzing out all the moves
uh but uh yeah that's uh that's what it
is
yeah so how do you feel after this game
you did play slow you got on time
pressure do you feel that you should
have won it or do you feel well it's
just a game of chess we know of course
yeah it's uh i should have won but uh
it's you know it's normal i mean
i
i think that you shouldn't make such a
big deal of uh
any result in chess i mean just uh
there are so many mistakes and missed
opportunities and sometimes you
um escape like yesterday so it's it's
it's just fine i mean you have to to
take it easy and just to think about the
next game take it easy and be happy and
you're three rounds so far in this
tournament how do you feel your
performance has been yeah well uh i
think i
i haven't played so badly i mean even
even in the in the rabbit and blitz i
didn't think i'd play so terrible it's
just
uh i was
yeah the result was just terrible but my
play wasn't necessarily that bad and i
think uh in the classical
um yeah i'm doing uh reason reasonably
well for for the moment so but uh let's
see what uh what happens well thank you
for joining us here lanier we'll let you
go as plenty of tournament left and good
luck for those rounds thank you
thank you uh linear indeed and let's
just check
our current standings with two games in
the history books uh peter yeah two
games drawn but very very different
games uh totally major because the game
between uh shah and uh maximo shiela
grav was kind of quiet it
became a bit sharper for a moment there
with maxim giving up the pawn on g7 but
he always had it in hand and
made a pretty safe draw there with black
you know
cannot be further from the truth about
about the second game of the day where
yeah lanier there uh realizing sort of
live on there and it's always kind of
awkward to ask those questions of
players because you know once once you
ask lanier why didn't you play bishop
taking 66 he instantly knows that it was
probably it was probably pretty good
right and
as a realization dawns it's uh it's a
very kind of a sad experience
a couple of things going on
first things going on we got to give a
shout out to absolutely our birthday boy
brian adams on our production team look
at brian they're uh the one and only and
i must say brian and i had great fun in
a norway together with marcus during the
stavanger cup
has apologized for brian adams many
times yes as the quote goes
okay
uh congratulations brian secondly
is now lost thank you in our matchup of
the wild cards and the fight for first
shockingly enough with the white pieces
things are things are going going sort
of
to hell in hand basketball well when we
left it there was this knight stuck on
a5 the next thing we saw is a knight on
d6 and we go whoa whoa whoa but actually
it wasn't supposed to be on the board
anymore
this is the striking part is that magnus
who normally understands sort of changes
of structure changes of material balance
so well
after 94 you just snap it off the board
you go gf yes you lose the a3 pawn but
like rook a4 you go rogue b8 right b5
you go rook b6 rook takes a3 and you
make
a move
king jutsu i guess maybe okay
and
i think you can see the outlines of why
this isn't really winning for black
because it's very very difficult to move
those pawns without the inclusion of the
king in the game and the king and the
king is not really going to get included
because it's very stuck on g7 the rook
on b6 controls absolutely everything
uh so this is one part of the equation
and the other one is you play four
oh sorry yeah as he played in the game
yeah a4
96 you play rook g8 here i assume this
is what he was planning right and you
get hit by 43 and
you are
kind of
not doing very well
i think he just missed e3 but that's
painful he is he seems rattled by how
this game is going frankly he just does
not seem confident seems uh seems to not
be enjoying himself at all today magnus
when we talked about the lowest rated
player in the field alejandro coming
into this tournament we imagined this
biggest bullseye target anybody could
ever draw on the back of a single chess
player's
back
and hans niemann saying why you guys
think you can target me
no no no no hans name is targeting them
are you kidding me look at this e3 is
coming i think magnus completely missed
it i asked ceci about this position
minus four it's minus minus four being
serious rook d8 e3 takes 94 is just
crushing i mean mate is coming against
most rook moves
rook c1 rook d1 is met with takes takes
knight c3 so it's an actual threat and
what do you do what do you do in this
position the best move according to the
engine is start running
and start giving up pawns that's tough
not to mention magnus in this position
has nine minutes left guys
this might be
a huge upset in this tournament
i couldn't imagine a bigger upset
actually yeah so
country
really is showing some some remarkable
chess here and uh and magnus is
i mean both things can be true at the
same time i'm sitting here remembering
our discussion from two days ago which
basically i asked ourselves
can magnus reach 2 900.
you don't reach 2900s if you lose a game
to a 26.50 well he's 26.86 but you're
26.86 but i mean the point sort of
stands right he won't be 2686 for long
with this with this kind of
performance yeah wow
wow wow wow wow okay uh we're going to
take a
very very short break as round three is
certainly totted up
i like them dotted up
see on the other side
[Music]
hey st louis the ascension charity
classic presented by emerson is back
this september don't miss the excitement
when the pga tour champions best compete
again all for charity september 9th
through the 11th at norwood hills
country club pro-am spots hospitality
packages vip tickets and more available
now at ascensioncharityclassic.com
[Music]
founded in 1839 the university of
missouri is steeped in tradition the
recently founded mizzou chess program is
a partnership between the university of
missouri and the st louis chess club
collegiate jess has been experiencing a
meteoric rise at the national level
through its tradition of excellence
mizzou has always strived for the best
mizzou chess is working towards raising
the bar by bringing our institutions
ethos of respect responsibility
discovery and excellence to the
[Music]
to our chessboard
[Music]
st louis university celebrating its
200th anniversary offering world-class
education in the heart of st louis
slough attracts students and professors
from around the globe
in 2015 slu partnered with the saint
louis chess club to start a top-tier
collegiate chess team on the very first
year of the teen's inception slu
obtained second best university at the
pan american intercollegiate chess
championships
higher purpose
greater good
st louis university
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back uh the summer of chess
continues well into the autumn the
single cup uh does conclude the the gct
part of the summer but there's more
events coming up uh take a look exciting
events uh they are as we have ultimate
moves is team rex will challenge
somebody in
a kibbutzing match let's put it that way
a very fun event a very kind of a
favorite part of the
over the summer for many many people
myself included and then we'll help you
get it loose
sorry yeah please
and then we get the uh the fish random
the chess 9lx uh
showdown running from 14th to 16th
and after that there's a small break
finally
and then the national championships will
once again be hosted by the saint louis
chess club both the men's uh the open
and the women's championships women of
course are eligible for the open
championships and that will be
one uh worth watching october 3rd
through the 20th but jumping back
to uh this round and we're seeing a very
stunning development i think we we're
watching it in a kind of a little bit
disbelief as
hans is
completely winning
says what not anymore what not anymore
not even anymore
well not completely winning but han
still has a strong advantage against
magnus yes but not he didn't play
accurately we got to this position and
then we had left it off right around
here rookie 7 with the idea of this e3
coming out now f takes g4 was what um
hans played not a bad move
rook c2 was stronger according to every
engine but after
pawn takes rook d7 he still had this
idea of e3 pawn takes knight e4 king f1
and now he has a choice he can check on
c1 you can check on f5 now if you check
on f5 you defend your opponent you can
play b5 next move the engine is thinking
that was a completely winning variation
now with this move rook c1 check king g2
rook c2 bishop takes f7 the engines
aren't thinking that it's such a big
advantage anymore now of course it'll
take on e2 king g1 already played and
the problem is that you still have some
things hanging bishop d5 is hanging rook
takes b7 is hanging so not such a clear
advantage anymore still very dangerous
for magnus because after king f6 let's
say rook takes b7 when you have ideas of
knight g5 coming in with knight
on f3 or knight on h3 but there's this
key move bishop h5 it's not an easy move
to spot from afar
but it just about holds the position
surprisingly yes i understand knight f3
looks very dangerous but because the
bishop is attacking the pawn on g4 it
seems like magnus might hold on i'm not
gonna i'm gonna call it right now but it
doesn't seem like uh hans has played the
most accurately way in the last couple
moves okay but even having said that
that that position of the bishop on h5
that just looks terrible it does if if
you could go again to that position for
just a moment yes knight f3 jack i need
to put my rook on yeah they're going to
go to c2082 and then a2h4 i think is
true this is this is the the key h4 you
can't take on pass on because your
knight is hanging you have knight h2
doesn't really help you g3 doesn't work
because i still have to take the knight
so it's an important find this that move
easy to miss easy to miss
easy to miss h4
because i was about to go king g5 i was
about to go knight h oh it all looked
very tempting right
but you could actually play it this way
knight h3 check king f1 check king e1
king g5 do it this way the problem is
that you've uncoordinated your pieces
here agreed and after bishop v8 you uh
you cannot take on h2 well you can but
you have this check king h4 rook h7
hitting the pawn on h6 all computer
lines right they just don't care about
the danger of the king they calculated
it perfectly now the lucky thing for
magnus might be that he doesn't have a
choice
if he does many of those moves will be
uh absolutely absolutely forced
absolutely of course because if you
don't put the bishop on h5 in this
position i think you kind of resign
right right yeah knight f3 is just
coming it's too strong it's terrible
it's terrible you have to play bishop h5
in our remaining games peter though i'm
seeing a lot of decisive games
very very jump to wesley if you don't
mind sure
the wesley game honestly optically this
looks like an improvement for fabian i
think it's totally yeah
i thought it was even worse than this
yeah okay
but uh a tactical skirmish ensued on on
the king side here and in the center and
now we have this position where there is
this weakness on e5 white of course has
a very beautiful knight on e3 uh why
they steal a pawn up for the time being
yeah and the move queen a4 here
indicates that there are still
weaknesses you can aim against for white
but if you can imagine uh before we
already played c65 if you can imagine
like let's say playing rook g8 and
starting to threaten d5 d4
the bishop 186 does a very good job of
uh you know controlling it on e3
controlling some of our weaknesses and
supporting this push
the pawley five
constantly is being threatened by the
clean c7 and white really does not have
any pieces to get to it of course i mean
i assume white is still better here i
don't know how much but of course i
would be quiet if i had to pick right
but it felt to me that
we've sort of gotten we've gotten the
absolute maximum here with black because
we do we do have counter play we do have
some plans
that require attention okay okay can i
see the tactics for a moment peter scene
let me try to play g4 i would really
like to play take on d5 if i take on e5
right exactly exactly and you play queen
c6 or queen a7 which one do you like i
was thinking queen d7 i wasn't really
interested in dd7 even yeah also that
was true because i was uh you know what
i mean very strong yeah uh and i did
hang on a second you rock g3
it's it's not over till it's over as
queen g7 yogi bear i won this end game i
won the sun game i think i'm actually
getting the end game here because finn
is in f7 i see what you want and then
with the pawn on g3 like no i don't i
don't want to live with the pawn on d
yeah
it's a bit double edged yeah that wasn't
exactly on my agenda and this is what i
meant
of course you're still running
tremendous risks here with black but you
you see the glimmer of hope because the
position is no longer fully under
control by by wesley i do believe i've
kind of uh you solved it yeah well what
what well uh queen g4
uh
how did i say i think page seven yeah
yeah oh yeah yeah king of six doesn't
really i think is also okay i was going
to try to create rook e8 that's what i
wanted to say you might have a drawer
with the perpetual yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
i i i may blow it with the pawn on d3
you may have lost this game actually by
this point i was trying to force uh the
tactics didn't didn't quite work there
yeah uh and uh i made once again a
mistake of glancing over at alejandro's
screen so oh uh oh i should never do
that like that's just always a mistake
it's too distracting peter it's just too
distracting but we have to ask the
engines and the engines think
wesley is just winning he needs to find
a couple of good moves rook d2 rogue d2
is the start there's no choice for black
i think we'll take c5 no they have to
literally just i think they have to fly
right if you take on on e5 then queen
takes a7 it's just lights exactly lights
out clear
so you have to play rogue d2 rook d8 and
now the correct move there's there's
other moves that are give a huge
advantage one of them is knight g2 with
the united 4 i'd rather like that but b4
forces the action because if i take on
c5 and i dominate the dark squares it's
easy that's easy so what happens on d4
and the problem is that you take take
and just give up the rook ah rook takes
check
king wherever queen takes e6 this king
super super safe this king whatever not
super sweater the opposite of what super
safe is
completely lost i mean the the knight
and the queen and the million pounds of
extra material
it's just too easy so that is a very
nice line yeah so if he finds rook d2 b4
there's very little that favi can do
about it because i'm going to take on c5
next move if you take on b4 okay i could
take with the pawn it's okay but stick
with the queen yeah and the idea is that
queen e5
you have queen either e7 or a5 both
giving a decisive advantage in this
position and it's it's just very
difficult and rook d2 on the board now
rook d8 as i said b4 is not the only
move
i'd rather like this knight g2 going
back to f4 re-maneuvering the the knight
into a more aggressive position maybe
supporting this pawn on the e-file so i
like as a human to play knight g2 but
they just say you know what just go b4
if you want the dark squares go get em
because you can do it right this moment
impressive and uh forcing too
now uh
again i mean this could for all we know
be the match of the tournament that's
taking place before us between magnus
and hans
and magnus by me hans did play the move
king f6 as a prelude yeah
magnus has got to find bishop h5 not yet
no he has to take on b7 first take on b7
first uh
i think khan hans also repeated ruki
wanoki to check a couple of times which
i think is a kind of shows
a good understanding of uh
he has more time on the clock than
magnus i think that's a mistake
to repeat i think it's a mistake to
repeat why because magnus would have had
to find bishop h5 before mu 40.
and if he plays rook takes b7 right now
it's move 40.
yeah maybe maybe in that way yes but
also i think maybe hans
realizes that uh things are not as clear
as he would have liked
and he needed some time to come calm
himself down and i yeah
you're probably right i i felt that
uh
for some reason whenever i see a a young
supremely confident player like hans do
do those little uh you know things that
they they teach us you know all four
years
uh to do or they taught us when we were
young and eric well i thought it was the
russian school of chess exactly yeah i
feel to do this i feel you know a
certain affinity for that decision
because like it's uh it's the supposedly
correct way to to approach things but
maybe you're right maybe you
if you realize
king of six and knight g5 will be the
critical try and you look down on your
score [ __ ] and you realize
if i repeat it will be move 41
you maybe should not be repeating
i think i think you are you're very much
on point there alejandro i didn't
consider this
this angle
right but king f6 is on the board in the
test
the ball is definitely in magnus's court
now as far as king f6 rook takes b
rook takes b7 the only only move right
according to engines
yes everything else gives black a
decisive advantage okay so rook takes b7
and uh this
by no means knight g5 is not the only
move there's another way of getting to
uh f3 i assume but then we can play then
we can play bishop g5 maybe even because
knight h3 is no longer a threat knight
h3 is very much part of the problem here
for white that black has a combine like
knight g5 creates two very very strong
threats because i think bishop d5 loses
specifically tonight h3 and nothing else
it does lose to it though because king
h1 gets you mated in two not uh yeah
let's not go there
uh with uh this very famous rook and
knight pattern yeah so you have to go to
f1 and then black just takes on h2 and
just to the query greens the g4
uh
this looks
maybe even look up to check first so so
that we don't get boxed in with bishop
g2 here right i like that let's let's
include this little
check and then take on h2 so there's no
bishop g2 and g3 g2 happens i think
exceedingly quickly in these types of
positions makes sense so 92 exists but
apart from the fact that bishop h5 might
still be playable even there
there is also the problem that without
the knight h3 threat we can go bishop d5
and defense defend from that side and
not force the not forced to part with
the h2 pawn
[Music]
and another game that we've been
discussing quite a lot today but not for
a while
and what are in this back to being kind
of lost
against
i
uh
he's been he's been on the edge for so
long
but he made this incomprehensible
decision for me if you go back to the
night
yeah why would you why 96 yeah
out of
that you can defend the pawn on f7
whether it be king g8 rookie rookie
seven yeah okay so i'm probably best
friend why retreat your best piece yeah
this is very very difficult to
understand for me because yeah and then
there is a plate very very logically you
give this couple of checks you play
knight g3
and you land it on f5 you trade those
knights off and then the king on g8 is
very very bare exactly yeah the king is
too exposed but the knight the 94 was
such an important piece for the defense
yeah and the offense too actually
and we reached this position
on this board i assume there has to be a
concrete solution here there is jack and
rookie yeah he still needs to find it of
course he doesn't have that much time
but it is very concrete rook g3 check
king has to go to f8 if you go to the h
file queen f3 starts threading
checkmates and
it's very difficult to defend against it
once i force your queen to h6 like let's
just put something on the board i don't
know well this gets mated in three so i
need to defend uh the f7 square first
check here and the key here rook f7 wins
but this is better
and rook g5 and just rook h5 this is
this is always going to be made yeah
that's a clean one so king f8 is played
which makes sense now the engine thinks
he plays h5 i don't think anybody plays
playing each fight okay i like rook f3
better rookie
force move and then queen d4 and now
you're threatening this attack on the h8
square and he just played the move rook
f3 i expect rookie 7 to come quickly now
by that point queen d4 doesn't need to
be found there are other ways to win
rook f6 i think is maybe a more natural
way of doing this because you evict the
queen from the defense of the f7 square
and for queen e5 rook takes f7 kj
there's no immediate mate but the attack
kind of rages on after rook f5 and you
still don't have time to create the
immediate threats on the queen side so
the engine engines giving a decisive
advantage for alireza again
nice and magnus did not take on b7
[Music]
whoa whoa whoa he must have not found
bishop h5
yeah i guess i guess he uh he missed
that and uh after king f6 the media
bishop uh
to d5 and as you were
expressing explaining pardon me uh peter
knight g5 well g5 maybe we don't take on
b7 now maybe we do something smarter
maybe you have official g5 there is
there's yeah bishop g2 perhaps is a is a
market improvement over b7 okay my
biggest concern here would be
something like either knight c5 or rook
d2 but
now my engine was saying the size of a
vanish for a second and then i let it
run
and then it was thinking well maybe it's
not that bad for white so i opened cessy
which is much stronger minus 0.6
what yeah it's currently saying this is
holding which is kind of surprising to
me it looks like this shouldn't hold but
yeah the the current understanding uh of
the
of the overlords is that this is
still okay somehow it's still holdable
okay might be a little much but holdable
yes
okay from that point of view then peter
what would you think is the most
challenging for magnus here you
mentioned knight c5
would you be avoiding rook takes e3
would you be avoiding knight g5
rookie three
oh rookie through
b7 that doesn't ruby seven maybe even
maybe even there should be seven in some
positions i'm not sure but probably rook
b7 yeah so i i believe you you you did
mention 19 yeah
but i guess we go
either the immediate rook c7 maybe yeah
let's go r7 here yeah okay b6 b6 guys
this will be an interesting end game but
since levon only has 30 seconds let's go
let's let's go full sized camera on that
one as we expect this one to be quite
fiery between levana and el reservoir
he goes king g8 immediately after which
we can even take on f7 queen g3 check
will be a bit of a threat so
yeah this one is not long for this world
there's no there's no way you can defend
this position not with that many rooks
pointing at your king yeah
how many rooks
can we point at your king uh king g8
rook f7
said queen g3 yeah so you play you play
something like queen g4 or queen g6 here
you saw that lavon headshake there
he knows yeah he of course can of course
he knows of course he knows uh and he's
had
35 seconds when he so he had five
seconds when he made his previous
question i guess he goes queen g4
because queen g6 is uh
among other things allows h5 h6 which
will be
even worse additionally additionally
unpleasant yeah exactly
that was the point but i'm guessing rook
fade gives mate right you would you
would assume rook of fate i ruka face
wins the wins the rook it wins the rock
you don't actually yeah to find better
you can play rook cafe checking g7
why my ah queen g3 rook takes you yeah
yeah thank you yeah so rook fade king g7
yep
queen queen f7 check
rga
yes queen f7 check yes take stakes the
only way yeah yeah already sees it g6
and for a second there it feels like
you've protected yourself but h5
yeah
h5
the nasty that's awesome king h7 changes
nothing you still play queen f7 here and
the game ends
i mean there might be mate in five here
somehow but you don't need it because
extra rook is always better than late
and five i was taught as a
as a young child that was what ben
larson said too the mate not might not
be there but it rooks a rook and that's
the game guys all the rest of the bounce
back
wow
and what a game this was such an
entertaining game truly it was a very
very interesting game g5 was quite the
challenge by levon i mean there was no
reason he he had to give
uh alireza that it was it was a bit of a
strange decision for sure yeah i i don't
know why he chose to to provoke you know
this uh sacrifice called call fire on on
himself but
we enjoyed it absolutely no question
about it we appreciate it that's right
congratulations enjoyed it we'll see him
soon wesley so let's go to wesley
they're lower g2 and the times are
we got four minutes 45 for wesley two
minutes 16 for fabiano caruana still
five moves to make for both of them
and
we did
pardon me wesley did like your your
approach to the position which was a
nice clear one too knight g2 bishop f7
queen b5 still going on
g5d4 played uh here and
yeah you still feel like it's possible
here to lose control it's possible to
uh to suddenly find yourself in a
position which is not entirely uh
uh
one-sided
but you also feel that you have to be
winning he does have a cute line he can
play e6
you play e6 you yeah you can you shoot
yeah yeah
and i think that was the point of queen
b5
that you now can take on d4 and you
don't have a good way to recapture this
why why is he taking so horrible
i assume that i get
there's a check on the back oh pardon me
back here
immediately no no he sings bishop six
with so you include easy sorry peter
something i assume wins but i'm not
entirely sure what yeah check i go
somewhere well
uh
this is where let's say i don't know
s7 ignite f4
oh this this looks terrible yeah this
looks this looks horrific yeah
yeah it does look it does look really
really bad
and
sorry once again the times and then
it's three minutes ten seconds for
wesley two minutes 16 for fabiano and
move number is 35 so about to make 36.
35. uh pardon me
so
right here this is our moment
d4 on the board and is e6 necessary it
is is it the white is better if you
don't do it but it's
better not winning e6 probably is just
winning on the spot where everything
else
allows fabio somewhat back into the game
really difference being that if you
include cdcd here quincy one check
starts being a threat so you have to
dedicate some yeah but he's playing six
yeah it's uh
it's wesley wesley
yeah wesley doesn't miss many short
tactics i i was even
looking at the move queen e2 prior to e6
by the way queen e2
gift me the pawn on g4
but as you say e6 bishop takes e6 on the
board cd
and wesley if you want to give me the
opportunity for queen g5 sorry if you
want to generate some kind of
hope for yourself maybe you play queen
b6 here and uh at least drive the queen
away from good squares before
recapturing on d4 but then you will have
to recapture with the rook
after queen e2
she takes d4 queen takes e4 looks
absolutely absolutely horrendous so you
take with the rook
and then uh your structure is so broken
up that i can play i mean no one thing
we don't do i think is we don't take on
d4 here we go i mean b3 probably is
winning but maybe even keeping the rooks
on is quite good let's say we play rook
c2
rook c2 followed by knight e3 and then
this entire structure is like it's just
true nice game by wesley but a really
really mystifying decision by fabi to do
not take on b2 earlier i think
i think you will put your
your finger on the poles as well peter
the decision to capture that
awkward bishop on e3 and that was also
night yeah that was also i thought
that was kind of a strange choice yeah
wesley uh certainly looking as uh
down to a minute it's moved 36 so
with the 30 second increment this is not
as bad as it looks but
the problem is
really that the position is horrible not
that he is down on the clock
but he has to play queen b6 right is
there another move yeah like if you
place your takes before i assume you
just get mated
yeah this is a position we stopped
we just stopped
after night at four we just painful to
look at exactly exactly
and uh alejandro we had actually had
this conversation about
fabi kind of misfiring for quite some
time i mean at one time
clearly the world number two by quite a
margin slipping slipping slipping and
just barely in the top ten
had a rough few months i mean starting
with the second half of the candidates
right that things have gone downhill for
fabiano caruana significantly it's
very rare to see fabiano lose more than
one game per tournament in the olympia
he actually lost a bunch
he dropped a lot of rating and he hasn't
been able to really come back i mean he
had an okay rapid and blitz finished
third at the end but his classical is
where it's mostly suffering actually his
rapid and blitz ratings are still up
there but classical he seems to be not
on shape i mean
i'll be honest five is the type of
player that finds this queen d7 against
lanier no problem exactly and
use great calculator great calculator
right not not so much yesterday right
and here again he just
misfires doesn't calculate rook takes p2
properly ends up in a terrible position
i don't know things are things are going
wrong for fabiano caruana i know that he
is
just trying new things but something
needs to stick
exactly rook takes d4 as you prescribed
peter on our screen yeah b2b3 you
mentioned is one very good move
uh you don't take on d4 you said i i
really hate giving black any counter
passer of any kind yeah like but
probably still winning
yeah i would assume it's still winning
but why why would you give black hope
here well whatever slim slim hope there
may be i i just wouldn't be doing that
okay yes western usage
he still wants to be a member of the
pawn grovers association does wesley so
rook takes d4 c takes d4
gift meet upon queen takes e4 yes you
can take on a2 but i will take on g4 i'm
assuming as wesley is and also the
knight by the way the knight is so
wonderful in this position
and uh i
perhaps now with the position really
settling we can bring back the
actual breaking news again in the
carlson newman game yes what is the
breaking news uh magnus had very very
serious drawing chances and this is past
mulford as well and now he is back to
being what i assume is just completely
lost
as in completely lost yeah though
specifically after a precise move here
which i think is findable
uh he played rook f7 check after bishop
d5 uh hans played rogue d2 after some
thought and this was this concluded the
first time control
rook f7 check was the absolutely the
only move on move 41 and after king g6
then this is the second time in this
game where magnus
chooses to try to keep the bishop alive
instead of offering a rook ending you
can play rookie 7 or rook f4 in this
position both of which very likely
will lead to uh the same rook ending
after d5 rookie iv which doesn't look
very attractive right but it's
necessary it's a rook ending with all
the drawing tendencies that that implies
and instead he's gone rook d7
i'm guessing assuming that there's not
very much better than just some kind of
a repetition with king of six but
uh
you can play
using the the fact that the rook on d2
can be connected to the king on g1 by a
fork you can play nine g5 here
let me just interrupt you to say that we
do have in
uh studio special guest who won his game
ali ruiza is with uh alejandro alireza
furuja coming back into the tournament
you lost yesterday to jan bounced back
today and the first thing i have to ask
you do you know that there's a
brilliancy prize in this tournament
yes
yeah i think this is one of my very good
games i think in my career even um
i think it was very interesting this
sacrifice
and here we can show it on the board
after g5 you didn't doubt it right you
just kind of went for it how good did
you think your position was after 1935 i
felt that it's winning because of this
idea of f4 and knight e2
so
um it felt when i saw okay it's
apparently long don't worry about it
actually it it the engine the more
things the more like okay okay yes
i think it's a very interesting plan and
when i saw this plan i saw that it's
just winning
but he gave you a lot of trouble
actually yes i think he found a very
nice defense and it was very interesting
the way he played
it was very forcing actually i couldn't
find a better way to continue after
c-section
yes be before is correct yes
yes and rook f1 king this h4 is
apparently not correct wow bishop h4
liked a little bit more but i still
thought h4 has a strong advantage yes
and then it's very forcing actually
after it takes
queen b3 is very important move
excellent move the screen yes rook e8
and you played this absolutely great we
were just wondering
after knight takes e4
knight takes d5 yeah
what did you miss there yeah for sure
it's a good move but i thought i am
better anyway so i miss i didn't see the
wind king g6
here i was calculating rook d5 queen h4
and i couldn't see the win so yeah there
was only one win in this position
actually let's move queen f3 and i saw
this one knight f6 then you can just
take takes
anticipation
king g7
and then rook g5 yeah yeah you got the
queen ah okay yeah i missed queen h5
check yeah
i i just saw queen g4 king f7 rook f5
but it doesn't like this right looking
f7 hacking f7 yeah look at f5 i think
he's winning but okay i thought the
in the game i am also better so right
and he didn't have lots of time so i
thought maybe if i just keep it and
attack the king later it would be
better practical choice because if i
miss something there i am down peace how
did you make the decision between
playing the knight to e2 and what we
thought was a more logical move knight
h5
ah yes um night i thought that i could
go back and also defend the king and
also attack the
attack his king because knight on d4 is
very powerful and knight h5 is a bit
shaky move but maybe it's a better move
so yeah well it seemed like 92 was a
little bit of a mistake according to the
engines but after 96 you were just back
in control queen d3 check here and this
excellent sequence right when did you
feel you had it in the bag yes here
because the king is so weak that it's
so easy to play with white and he didn't
have lots of time so i think i was very
optimistic here so well absolutely you
should be because well you have a
crushing position and you ended it up
with a flurry of attack nice bounce back
against levona aronian after three
rounds how do you feel overall about
your performance yeah i think it's very
decent um john played a fantastic game
yesterday so i was not very upset with
the yesterday game
i could have defended better but i think
he just played a very amazing game so
um i think it's very decent it's 50
so i'm happy that today managed to come
come back and we will see the coming
rounds we absolutely want to see you
today was a great game congratulations
on it and the bounce back and good luck
the rest of your games thank you
congratulations to you as well
ali raza uh the two remaining games uh
looks like uh decisive advantages peter
uh
wesley
and fabi but what's going on in the
magnus game once again
i don't know i mean i mean i i do know
i'm just wondering are you you're not
ready to share i already i already did
share i i mean sort of in a more general
sense i haven't seen magnus defend
so shakely uh very often because i think
uh he definitely is one of the best
people in the world in terms of sort of
understanding uh
we sort of material changes required for
the best drawing chances
i just keep on coming back to those two
two specific points in this game one
where he replied to knight c4 with a4
and another one just now where you have
this option of this rook ending which
uh yes you're a down upon yes you you
i mean i i wouldn't be
sure this is a draw right but
rook g7 just sort of self-pinning
yourself like this i understand it's
probably connected with a miscalculation
of some sort but i just would be very
very uncomfortable making this move
anyway right and here after 95 i think
you have to play bishop seven check and
now after king f6 or king of fire but i
guess king f6 is good enough you
absolutely have to take on g2 yeah blake
gives a check takes on due to and then
the people just starts running
and it's a runner and i think this is
sort of very very
optically obviously bad for white like
you you don't really expect to save this
position i don't think
and it's it's just so unusual for me to
see magnus not utilize
every single
defensive resource yeah
i don't think i've seen this uh too much
from him over over the years
weigh in on this one uh
alejandro a misfire yeah not just one
right but it's several during one game
and hans has played well but he's also
kind of let it go at some point giving
magnus what you would think is the
chance right you when you think about
magnus he doesn't give you chances and
he's giving him two in this game that is
to me a big surprise
absolutely when i think also about
magnus i think about his accuracy and
knight g5 on the board and okay guys
this is pretty much over yeah this this
probably is uh
from here it should be reasonably
straightforward i don't really see how
you
how you don't win from here
wow wow again i'm just
stunned uh by
uh these two wild card players and but
most especially hans you know
coming in this tournament is clearly the
biggest underdog in syncfield history
starting with two and a half out of
three just
unprecedented i don't even know
what i could call it knight g5 on the
board and this looks
awful for
our reigning world champion and how bad
is fabi's position or
as you were saying peter i would never
allow a power i don't yeah i i think
this is a huge improvement compared to
like if you go back to the position
after rook takes d4 right i feel like
yeah like after rook d4 if you if you
play roxy 293
i think i think you win every single
pretty much every single time because
everything will start collapsing i don't
see how the structure doesn't just fall
apart
the g4 like once once the knight lands
on e3 i think the g4 pawn just kind of
is indefensible with the pieces where
they are
uh you you mentioned the word structure
peter and this is like every single pawn
island you can make you know i mean yeah
calling these structures perhaps
overly flattering right uh i hear you
loud and clear
i'm assuming the current position is
also winning but
uh if we put it on the board i think
bishop takes a2 is a very good choice
just
g4 was always weak just traded for a
healthy pawn on a2 yeah we bring the
bishop back to f7 meaning that let's say
we play knight f4 here we play bishop
seven as a matter of course
and then it's going to be very difficult
for us to get mated he played queen of
three i'm still playing with seven
exactly exactly exactly and then
uh
you can
the game players anew yeah
flare's a new maybe is an overstatement
okay the knight on the four is still
going to be very strong the king is
still completely completely devoid of
any defenders i think when f3 check was
played with the intention of playing
queen a3 check
that's my that's my idea i think wesley
doesn't want to even entertain the idea
of giving up the b2 pawn and then we go
like the four next move and we continue
improving with white maybe i don't know
where my kingdom is well maybe i'll
i'll uh
i'll take the walk
walk the walk over to the king queen
side pardon me and just still bad still
bad still bad but i i think i think the
other one was uh even worse yeah more
certain but these are i understand these
are uh
you know questions of taste more than
maybe anything else exactly when on that
one
alejandro
are you with peter uh i'm a pawn grabber
i might have i would probably certainly
have done what wesley did but
he's making
a really good argument for rooksy too no
roxy was much better than rook takes d4
according to the engines so that's
that's what i can tell you okay i i like
this position
if you had no other options but the
other one was just so safe
and in this one the problem is that you
always have a draw in the back but
how are you going to deal with the past
pawns you have a knight you're never
going to lose but to win you have to
push your pawns forward now you're not
going to mate the guy right the king is
not super safe
from checkmates from checks not safe but
from checkmates you're never going to
get there so how do you eventually
defend from this pawn rolling forward
because i'll sacrifice steep on for my b
pawn somehow i don't think that's so
difficult to do and then this pawn is
going to start rolling and unless i
capture it it's going to be very
annoying you don't want to have a knight
all the way on that side of the board uh
defending against the passing the past
pawn and more importantly in so many
situations in which you trade pieces
they might start becoming okay for black
especially the queens right once they
take off d4 and b2 off the board
uh the irony irony going on here is
yesterday we were having this uh
conversation at dinner as well what were
the biggest myths
that we were told and we had to unlearn
them and one of them was that the queen
and knight was stronger than the queen
and bishop
uh
were you told heresy
i'm not listening to this
the queen of knight shows up against the
queen and bishop
this one we'll keep an eye on that again
it's really really really bad that uh
messenger's position bishop f7 check
sorry king of fights and since i did
have to listen to this i will i will
defend the uh you know the myth the old
wild wives tales there by saying it has
to be qualified right there are
definitely positions in which queen and
bishop will be stronger than queen and
knight okay but
queen and knight i think are stronger
when there is
an unsafe king in the mix right queen
and knight are much better at creating
direct attacks against the king
and queen and knight will be stronger in
like semi-closed positions where the
bishop doesn't have operating uh
freedom
but
bishop is just a stronger piece of piece
than the knight so and like it would be
somewhat illogical
if it was entirely overridden by adding
adding the queens in the mix good point
uh knight g5 on the board uh
time a factor probably not right no
because they've just made what is the
factor is that the position is bad it's
just very very bad brooke takes the
position
okay i found i found the whole uh a
glimmer of hope i think for white you
play
king somewhere
let's say g2 and i think we're supposed
to play
if you're playing g2 i think we play a5
now
a5 yeah this is my glimmer of hope
because we're currently controlling both
b3 and c4 squares well done
meaning that bishop d5 is a very very
legitimate threat
right
and liquidating the the queenside bonds
will certainly help you make achieve the
draw but on the other hand
yeah something like this i guess bishop
d5 knight somewhere but then i go king
g3 and maybe there is like this i don't
know how easy it is to win i wonder why
it is so completely and utterly lost
glimmer of hope as you say
[Music]
okay yeah i think i think we a5 right
the bishop the bishop should not be
allowed to d5 at all i think we go king
e5 here i think this is the bigger issue
okay
a5 i really like that move i mean you've
got to make it as awkward as
uh conceivable for your opponent a5 uh
freezes
the
queen side for a moment king e5 to stop
bishop d5 and now are we ready
for king g3 yeah we can give a check
from f1 there uh pick up one of the
pawns probably the hp probably the h
pawn yeah and then the issue is with the
bishop on f7 completely locked out of
the game eventually let's say if the
entire king's side disappeared let's
continue that line oh please like king
g3 knight f1 knight f1 check we go uh
king g4 knight h2 yeah
king g3 knight f1 check
king of 292.
the problem for white i mean the king
side doesn't even disappear
there's still one but yeah the the issue
is that the bishop of seven is so
completely dominated by the king on e5
that i think
black actually eventually will be able
to relocate the knight from d2 to some
square from which you can attack the
pawn on a5
while white will still be you know
shuffling around
searching for a way to get something
somewhere exactly exactly so yeah this
the more you look at this the more you
realize if we could attack the b7 pawn
we would have drawn chances right but it
seems
weirdly unrealistic here and to ever be
able to do that and if we if we charge
just like the one charge boldly into
yeah not taking c3 followed by king g3
d4 by knight c4 as i did this instantly
up came a table base
that just said bang bang bang perfect
play but here common sense dictates that
my moves are my next two moves are king
d4 and knight c4
and then your a5 pawn is gone and you
still haven't attacked on b7 exactly uh
so yeah this is uh this appears to be
done to a degree we do have this and
a5 and this important moment is king e5
is the only the only winning move here
everything is the only logical move in
my opinion yeah
unfortunately for magnus fans it's very
very logical to play the move king e5 to
stop
this uh nasty bishop d5
i think it's a very understandable
decision here because if you make your
knight very power like if you allow
bishop d5 put your mind on either c5 or
d6 then white will have so much
contemplate just playing against the
white the black king side while you
still have to
um and king e5 on the board
uh
apologies for making comparisons but i
do remember
one gary kasparov coming out of nowhere
and i believe it was a begun a debut in
began there was tigran petrossian and
all of these you know great great
players and
the uh yugoslavian organizers had
actually made a mistake they had invited
a junior player and they wanted a player
of this certain category let's say
um
25 80.
and gary was
i'm gonna say close to unrated
like he didn't really there there was a
soviet rating
[Music]
the elo ratings in those days didn't
change very often and i'm going to say
he came in as a say 2500
and he he passed his debut
yeah did gary uh but that's
as outstanding as what i'm witnessing
today here with hans i mean i this is an
amazing result if should he convert but
from here from here it uh
like it still takes some time because
weirdly the night the knight looks very
nice on d2 but getting it to squares
where it can actually attack something
will take some time yeah but you have
all
you actually do have all the time in the
world here as black because white really
has no counter play whatsoever the
bishop one f7 cannot be
rerouted to any kinds of good squares at
all
it appears when you think of juniors
making their mark you made your mark of
course in tillberg that you came in and
timor rajabov
yeah i mean taymor i think is a much
better example because if if you yeah if
you talk about my tilburg performance i
was 21 like i i was i was an oldster
[Laughter]
well 19 year old ali raza a 19 year old
but i do remember also funnily enough
timor winning the brilliancy prize and
uh tasering
yeah gary kasparov in the process
because gary was the victim of the
brilliancy
gary i think was quite happy with that
decision by the
the uh well they're not the appeals
committee but the but the the judges
have uh offended him grievously agree
i think he
even complained yes he did yes he did
vociferously i might add king e5 on the
board uh
alejandro uh chime in
this is uh bad news for the world
champion well it's minus nine so minus
nine sorry didn't realize it was it had
gone gone through the roof yeah you need
you need a stronger engine to get those
numbers but it is up there it's just
completely dead lost uh there's just
nothing that what can do there's no
active plan there's no way to save the
pawn on the a file for uh the for the
long run and this as you imagine peter
the king on e5 is brutal it just
dominates this bishop on f7 this lone
king in the center is putting a kibosh
on any hope of counter play of bringing
this bishop uh to c8 and in this one i
hadn't asked it for a little bit this
game is going to go on for a while guys
like this one is
not even close to uh an easy win here
this king is actually kind of unsafe as
well i started playing around with it
and this bishop going to d5 this queen
starting to harass things on the light
squares we're on for a long game here
between wesley san fermin cover and i
still think wesley's favorite to win
but i want to be surprised that favi
escapes this one wow
it's definitely imaginable yeah it's
certainly
certainly something that could happen
okay uh we do have one
uh victory in the books already a very
exciting game ali raza versus lavon
haronian and i know lavon's not going to
be
happy at all but he did make it very
difficult uh so much so that ali reza
came out and said maybe this is one of
his best games ever yeah it's a very
it's a very pleasant game to play when
you're playing against somebody of
levon's stature and and you get to play
an attacking game like this it's it's
extremely rare and it gives you an
absolutely like this this warm warm glow
exactly and again let's just take a look
at the three results we have had uh in
this round three
uh so far two draws one reasonably quiet
draw and one actually kind of eventful
within year dominguez missing a golden
opportunity to increase his score
exactly over over yan nipomnishi
bouncing back immediately after his
yesterday's loss to to yan and beating
the one iranian who is now
uh below 50 while alireza climbs back to
50 for himself and i got to tell you for
the grand chest [ __ ] that loss by levon
uh really just makes extremely
consequential it's mvl very very happy
but also wesley so in the mix in the
grand chess tour wants the victory
uh today and he has nursing a two
pawn advantage one court one so far only
i thought on the engine i mean oh you
mean you mean in terms of i mean he's up
a pawn
yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly
and uh but again i i'm coming back to
this game of uh
magnus and uh i just think that this is
an extraordinary uh achievement
yeah absolutely so yeah
magnus's losses with white are
you can be numbers on fingers on fingers
on one hand over the last i don't know
how many years exactly it could do some
research but it's definitely going to be
an extremely extremely low number
piece i say so yeah and
wow and i i puff up a little bit a
little while saying those words because
i mean that's going back a number of
years but
i'm beyond that list
nice let's talk about uh
longevity
streaks
non-losing streaks and
again for me one of the really
remarkable ones was michael tall having
two of the longest
streaks of not losing were by michael
toll a player that we thought of as a
fear that was here
yeah yeah
fearless tactician
he didn't lose very many then along came
vladimir kramnik that uh who who who
extended the record beyond tal and then
came along one certain ding learn who
also had he got to 105 i think right or
that sounds a little bit more i was just
going to say he got the triple digits
and somehow stopped maybe 101. yeah it
was between between
101 and 105. i don't remember the exact
number and then magnus
and currently
magnus is on a
50 50 ish i would say i have 50 i'm not
i'm not keeping track i'm sure ph knows
if we if you track down ph ph we'll
probably know the number but okay it's
53 guys yeah varusian will uh set a
straight you know come on guys it's 53.
get it right and uh
about to be uh up ended on this street
yeah seems like it's unlikely to survive
this position it it seems very uh very
bad
you're talking about getting the 2900
losing a game
uh for magnus against costing like this
will cost you like eight points or
something
seven or eight points i don't know
exactly how many but yeah
there's about a
200 point we can actually calculate that
200 point difference is
the rough calculation is you divide it
by seven
so that's what yeah that's eight points
here and then seven two and two that
means that his expected result is around
eighty percent right meaning that you
have to score point eight out of one
and he scores zero out of one
which is eight points i mean maybe seven
and a half but definitely in that
vicinity um i mean what matters is he'll
break 2700
hans will break 2 700 on this one and
then as well yeah hans will will very
very safely
get into the 2700 club on the live list
after this one i think even draw was
enough
was it i'm not no it wasn't okay
joining players like sam savion jeffrey
zhang and getting to that 2700 club
alejandro as you know as a coach that's
a that's a
phenomenal achievement it's formidable
achievement yeah that's a tough one guys
but the juniors are
coming i mean how many of these juniors
straight up endemic started playing
chess and just rose their rating hans is
going to be breaking 2 700 and all these
indian prodigies are breaking 2700 i
think there's like two or three of them
pragnanda is up there but he hasn't done
it yet or gaieze did it recently gukesh
did it recently i mean
when you look at the top rating list
there's a lot of teenagers in there now
yeah there's been some very very strong
wars on this topic recently i think
ruslan kushnov
over on the other stream uh
who i think works with uh arjun and
erica easy right now he said that in his
opinion arjun is already like a
definitely a top 10 and maybe even a top
five player in the world nobody just
recognized it yet right uh we we just
don't know it yet but he's already up
there in terms of skill and desire and
knowledge and everything
and honestly
obviously you know rustam gets very
emotionally invested with people he
works with as it should be
as as is right and proper uh and it may
sound like it's a bit of an emotional
statement which may not be borne out in
fact but
yeah i mean looking looking at what art
is showing yeah and what arjun is
showing uh over the last i don't know
year year and a half
you wouldn't bet against it no exactly
i remember growing up uh going into
these junior championships and
uh fighting and crossing swords with
artur yusupov and he was one of those
players that you know he wasn't in the
world top 100 but once you started
analyzing and playing against archer
you go my god this guy's enormously
strong later he became a
candidate and just barely lost
candidate's match against anatoly karpov
who played one of the great matches in
my opinion but r2 yusupov yeah the
juniors are coming and guess what king
g3 knight f1 yeah this actually speeds
up the process i think the way to like
make it maybe to move 65 was to do
nothing to play like king of two king e2
or something and just wait for black to
improve black would improve eventually
but this would maybe prolong the game
king g3 knight of one i think you lose
faster because now that we've taken away
the h2 pawn uh we really have nothing to
worry about no worries yeah we can
switch fully to the process of
collecting everything on the queen side
i agree wholeheartedly taking that h2
pawn off the board is just a kind of
that extra sense of absolute blanket
security you you really enjoy
when you know you're winning the game so
king g3 knight f1 and
uh no good suggestions as alejandra said
minus nine is
quite a lot
queen a4 check and as alejandro's just a
square
not not the square i would have chosen
by fabi but but the best square but yeah
once he played it i thought yeah maybe
maybe this is where it's supposed to go
because queen takes a7 is maybe no
longer a check in some variations you
you could definitely uh see why
d8 is being chosen
and uh
okay um
let's got some work because as alejandro
was mentioning
if you had played a move for example
like knight f4 here at certain moment
how are you going to win this game
you're going to win the game by playing
f3 g4 and advancing the pawns slowly
slowly slowly um
and that's going to take a a long
process what's this all about peter why
is the queen
good on a4 as opposed to where well sure
yeah i don't quite understand what this
move achieves
it surprised me when i saw it
yeah i i will i want to see the next one
because
i mean wesley clearly did not just play
to play move and give a check you know
right it's it's a bit more sophisticated
than that i think we can safely assume
right uh but
until i see what his follow-up is i i
currently i'm not entirely sure why this
is an improvement what's the ideal setup
would the ideal setup be the queen
should belong on d2 the knight i liked
it on a3 you did i thought i thought a3
was a good square and
uh another one of those situations where
you don't think of it until you see it
on your screen and then you realize why
it's good the engine actually was
suggesting at least at some point i saw
over on the hundred screen because you
automatically put the knight on the four
here right exactly
but in fact on f4 it is sort of i mean
saying that the bishop on f7 controls
the knight on the f4 i think it's rather
the other way around right right but the
bishop f7 does cover a lot of the
squares that i can jump to for sure so
it's not obvious like it's a very nice
square it's solid it stops the d-pawn
from progressing but it doesn't really
do very much on f4 so the engine was
actually going knight h4
knight h which i think is like it's
extremely possible to never consider it
for one second not on my radar but then
like it's however if if black allows
either knight f5 or knight f3
it's possible to imagine situations
where you actually fail to protect the
deep one
and like threads threats actually begin
begin to amass let's say like knight to
five actually is a very very large
threat and if you play bishop bc for
instance i will play knight f3
and then i'm threatening queen a4
checkpoint takes d4 and then the game
will be over we uh
we may be seeing this because okay so
they approach it okay yeah i was
wondering if you just meant to repeat
the video yeah okay after check he
played queen a4 and then he went queen
a3 and he said look
i would like to check you on the f8
square in no way jose king e8 and we
might see knight h4 and like you say
that wouldn't have been on my radar and
uh just simply allowing the bishop to d5
but then after 9 suddenly you know the
fabled queen and knight
actually does start shining because
queen is seven like a very very
straightforward idea of a7 mate
is difficult like queen e6 knight g7
right hello hello yeah
for check nice to meet you there as well
hello yeah i mean it's tricky
it's tricky
all right
knight h4 uh
alejandro uh
rather a paradoxical move but
it works it's the best move especially
now that the king is back on e8 so
knight h4 is the engine recommendation
knight f5 is strong uh the engine is
thinking you should play queen c7 or
bishop d5 in either one of the move
orders and knight h4 actually already
played by wesley good recognition there
by him uh bishop d5 for example knight
f5 the knight is great here queen c7
does threaten a little bit of counter
play but it's all under control
if you play
g4
and then we start running
so this is going to be still a very
interesting game guys because queen c1
apparently is no good
uh it's just
fabiano keeping up the chances and this
is what we talk about a lot keep up your
chances start making threats and yes the
engines still think that he's lost
but
it's not so clear yet
all right
and magnus has found a way to give up
all of his material somehow
okay
okay i understand what he wants this is
actually quite cute he found a way to
create counter play he will lose but
he found a way to threaten bishop d5 and
after king takes e4 he will play bishop
b6
and he will get that bishop to c8 okay
but this i assume is lost to a number of
things first of all at least of which
might be the yeah first of all we are
probably giving mate on the king side
but perhaps the slightly sadder thing
for magnus here is that after bishop six
again i'm playing g4
bishop c8 king c5
oh bishop b7 king b5 uh-oh and yes
eventually everything on the queen on
the king's side will get collected but
by that point i'm pretty sure i will
hang on is this a draw of the king g3
maybe it's a draw of the king g3 now
huh
united is uh yeah i'm not in time i
thought i wasn't time to protect the h6
pawn but in time okay
very nicely very nicely spotted idea of
a magnus then because he is at least
he's generated
he's introduced someone
lack of clarity into the position
you still assume this is not good enough
but
something i mean of course i'm a pawn
collector i want to play king takes e4
but sometimes
you know when that bishop cannot control
the diagonal sometimes a pawn on e4 you
know if i went king f4 and the computer
said you're genius and
for all of those reasons 75 right let's
try to calculate here i'm i'm just a
little curious myself yeah we should be
seven let's say i get i want to throw in
a 45 somewhere yeah somewhere around
this this point
probably
this is winning for black
winning for black okay so what a luck
sack
uh or maybe no why is this one this is a
draw can you two right why is this
winning for black king
because king ji won i think we're in
time king do you want to think another
three check wins i understand but king
e2 right but king two is a draw yeah can
you two and the point is if you play g2
i can play
uh king f2
no this loses this loses because of h2
check king g1 king g3 bishop takes g2 hd
h2 check
the track win exactly
why is any of this winning i don't
understand what
this is winning h2 yeah
you pick up my pawn somehow but like why
am i doing anything this way i don't
know yeah well you can take you can take
bishop takes g2 earlier yeah you can
yeah bishop takes g2 okay anyway that
was just kind of like a a fantasy line
where sometimes you don't want to take
the pawn on e4 because you can go h5
h4h3 and g3
um yeah i wonder concretely though i
wonder if you're supposed to play g3
check here what
i understand it's very counterintuitive
but i think it solves our biggest
problem which is not to lose the b7 pawn
like king g3 knight f1 check okay
choose a square any square
okay i'm i'm off just 93
knight ah just to stop bishop d5 yeah
and and then i will very like i will
take only four and i will get to i will
get to the squares i want to get to and
i will win transposing to uh
a line that maybe we saw from
[Music]
a different uh move order yeah i think i
think g3 check might be the
simplest conversion honestly because uh
king g294 you resign immediately because
i've stopped bishop d5 again right so
you have to take on g3 i go knight f1
check and you have to choose between i
think f3 and f2 but against both of
those knight g2 wins the pawn on e4
let's taking of 292. once again i've
stopped bishop d5 i will take on e4 i
will play 96 i will play knight d6 and
then you know the combination of pushing
the h5 h pawn and getting my king over
to like c5 b5 those types of squares
will be good
has to be a very comfortable win for
black i would assume it has to be good
enough
whoa
uh a valiant try alejandro uh by magnus
e3 e4 trying to
trick
uh
hans but uh this move g3
looks
spot on okay or you can just take on e4
yeah show me because i mean
or
you could do it by just taking a pawn
like you take bishop e6 i think you want
to play right yeah right but then you
just win with these two pawns you don't
have to be like
bishop c8 yeah but you're not you're not
making a queen h5 you're not on time
we should be seven h2 h4 mr pace six
yeah we're just we're just winning so
quick here we're just winning g3 and
knight f3 and then you make a you make a
queen
yeah that's that's also fair yeah i mean
uh if you if you are willing to
calculate i assume this is also quite
safely winning oh yeah it's very safely
winning can you take z4 slightly easier
g3 wins as well uh king of four does not
king of four does not
no okay
and uh back to the wesley so game
purchase moment because this
counter-intuitive move well spotted by
wesley knight h4
uh heading for the f5 square and uh
there was two there was two tries for
here for
fabi uh one was queen c7 while it was
bishop e6 no i think his bishop d5 in
terms of creating problems i think
bishop f5 queen c7 might be trickier
because if you have to find g3 g4
and trust that those checks do nothing
because wha black actually picks up the
opponent f2 is checked
seven protecting against the checkmate
and creating a threat of checkmate of
your own with quincy one clean h1 yeah
and apparently g3 g4 here is win is
winning but just inviting among other
things it it it loses the f2 pawn with
check
because we can play quincy took queen f2
but after king of [ __ ] e5 i assume
the bishop just gets picked up yeah you
can't because we're back to the second
27 mate yeah yes we are
and the king just went for a nice walk
this is not a difficult variation to
calculate once you realize g3 g4 exists
right but it's very possible because
you're not getting here you're not
getting teleported towards this position
right you you have to calculate it from
from from somewhat far in advance
and then you might like stop at queen c7
and think this is awkward because you
know quincy one is a threat perhaps
queen h7 is a threat as well right if
you make some kind of an indifferent
move why am i subjecting myself to this
right yeah like
seven and like like
who knows what this is yeah but why am i
doing this exactly yeah exactly why why
am i suddenly but if you as you say if
you do spot g3 g4
then uh you're golden again by the way
bishop d5 on the board if i've played
f5b is very very good at maximizing
drawing chances and
generally defending in
as tenacious a way as possible
what makes
wesley such a good player i mean he's
won the grand chester
uh he's won
the sinkhole cop uh
what um what makes him such a great
player peter i think uh a very very low
number of outright
mistakes he's yes i think i think his uh
he is
become i think
if you remember
the glory days of like the mid mid tens
yeah when he when he was winning super
tournaments for fun yeah he
i think i think he's become a lot more
pragmatic
and there you see
his opponent there on the screen very
obviously a legend in his own right but
currently not really enjoying life
as much as he may have
earlier in the summer that american cup
that was a great event that was that was
a very very high resolved by by him
he was one second away from losing a
match against jeffrey zhang by the way
but we won't uh but that's his
gladiatorial opponent and uh
[Music]
alejandro weigh in because wesley of
course went to webster university here
in st louis we we've watched
we've seen
wesley
improve steadily steadily steadily as a
player
and uh he's always seems to be in the
mix
well he's uh
difficult to take out right he's just so
solid and his style in particular keeps
him in that mix he's not he's not a
streaky player
he's not a player like for example when
you think of a topalov in the past or
even like richard rapport
uh he doesn't lose one game and then go
on a
on a big losing streak he loses a game
every very once in a while and he just
comes back makes some draws and he's
very good at punishing mistakes he
doesn't like taking big risks he is a
player that generally has a very solid
opening repertoire he is totally okay
with playing
one berlin end game after another even
if it's the only thing that will show up
on the chessboard for the rest of his
life as long as he can defend him with
black so he's very practical in that
sense he's very
methodical he doesn't really want to get
into fights that he doesn't seem the
need for and that's one thing that's
actually kept him at the top
of his consistency for me uh guys is
that totally remarkable
you're you're right about the mistakes
you just yeah
and he punishes absolutely i i still
feel that
sort of the earlier model
there was i think uh when he was
it's at least it fell like i i don't
really want to it sounds like i'm
speaking in a somewhat disparaging
fashion about one of the absolute
strongest players in the world i'm not
i'm not but i feel that he was
you know these days he just plays
solidly and collects points when people
perhaps overpress against him or uh or
just play
you know make mistakes against him and
he is very very satisfied with playing
correctly and perhaps not winning as
many games as his as he is there as his
direct competitors do
uh as long as he is uh you know
controlling the action and feels that
everything is
uh everything is in check but
uh he used to he used to play actively
for a win much more i think let's say
five years ago six years ago than than
he does now
but among the very very top players yet
his his level of consistency is um
you you can't really say unrivaled when
we have magnus but uh sort of
they're thereabouts
i would suggest yeah exactly also i just
want to say that uh like all of the top
players his repertoire's opening
repertoire oh yeah it's very very very
good super solid and he knows his
systems
inside and out
um
going back to magnus carlson i mean how
can we not but watch
this uh
well extraordinary result i mean guys
this
yeah you can you can actually go wrong
here you i mean the the the two moves
that are winning i think are findable
both obviously king takes e4 is the most
obvious move in the position and one
thing if you just continue calculating
you realize just how slow the whole b6
c8 takes b7 takes a6
is and that your
your plan of uh advancing on the king
side is just so much faster but honestly
i think g3 is simpler because i think
not allowing any counter play at all
just makes you makes you win so much
more comfortably yeah like king king
somewhere i go knight g2 i go knight
take c4 i put the knight on d6 yeah this
this just is impossible
yeah so you play like q3 here yeah after
king of king of 292 you play king e3 i
take on e4
my next move is knight g6 the bishop
actually has to vacate yeah like 96 here
king d3 king d5 king c5 king v5 like
this is really not difficult not at all
this is really not difficult at all and
also there's really no calculation even
involved your play is to go and pick up
a pawn yeah your play requires
absolutely no thought seemingly like you
can do it by hand right so to speak
without really involving the brain once
you but he chose to king take c4
which is
i'm guessing winning faster yes but
uh yeah i'm
me you know being a
devout chicken
is that grilled or fried or
roasted
devout chicken
wesley meanwhile has found g4 he did
king takes e4 bishop e6 on the board
king f4 on the board also yeah yeah
yeah i mean sorry it's not it's it's
it's pretty straightforward from here
you're breaking a four you start pushing
the h pawn and
um
you just had to refresh the board there
for a second
we are you know it feels like we're
probably like two tempe up i mean
two tempe ahead of the counter play here
right the 5 h5 bishop b7h4b6h3
yeah we've already basically gotten
there and white hasn't really even
started properly yet h3 followed by
knight f3 we don't even have to play g3
check immediately like bishop b7 i like
neither three better than i like my
choice of wins right because if you go
bishop c8 if i bring my knight back
actually that three was the only winning
move in that position i think i just saw
on my screen now we should be seven just
go back for a second yeah
another three only move that wins
g3 does not win g3
right okay that looks
really wrong that knight f3 does win of
course yeah that's an easy one
no but i was wondering in the immediate
position bishop c8
uh
knight f3 does that also win
wait no the current position you will go
efficient d5 or something that should be
five knight of three uh and then bishop
d5 now another three uh you want to pick
up the a5 i just want to pick up the
pawn there should be seven like knight
g4 on that very lazy chopper very lazy
chose player
yeah should also be very good yeah as a
devout chicken you can endorse this one
too yeah
even though i'd be a little bit worried
about bishop c4 knight a5 bishop d5 and
i maybe have to think a little bit
uh but probably not very
hard yeah
like
honestly this is this is surprising to
me just how winning this apparently is
because
this this feels like it could be tricky
but i guess you just play king e4 you
you time king e5 when well and then
and then you might never get the g like
i play h5 h4 and then i hit like let's
continue for a second yeah king g2 i
play h4 you play a king after king g1 or
whatever and i play king e5 here yeah
and i can't play bishop yeah and the
bishop does not attack the g4 points yet
so i get to move my knight away and then
i would bring the king back to f4 and i
win very comfortably yeah i agree so
we'll see which one hans chooses because
yeah there is this very uh kind of a
pragmatic way of playing with uh just
knight of three knight anywhere e5 d4 as
i said
or you can or you can give mate
or you could give me alternatively you
can give him an idea it sounds good
wow
um again and again as i'm sorry i'm i'm
putting you to the test
when you saw junior
um
making splash
who
whose names trigger
i mean recency bias right it's
you you have to go with the car and crop
because they're just so
yeah they're just so present in your
mind yeah like the you know starting
with eight out of eight or just now in
chennai right and just sort of barely
out out out running not your back and
and and the rest of them who were also
like knowledgeback was on six and a half
out of seven right and finished i think
on like nine out of 11 at the end of it
so uh but remember maurizevich making a
splash to london
uh
maybe
nine and a half out of ten or something
that was 94
right
qualified he qualified for the
pca uh
grand prix by winning the lloyds bank
okay and i think the pca grand prix did
not start until 94 that was probably
lloyd's bank 94 but he was
yeah he was like 18 at the time yeah
yeah he was an interesting case though
because
uh i played in some junior events with
him like under 12s on the 14th
and uh
he wasn't winning them he was a runner
in them you you saw him being good like
you you could very easily see that this
is somebody who who is very very decent
but he wasn't winning them he wasn't a
favorite and then necessarily and then
he sort of disappeared from let's say my
personal view okay i i didn't see him
for a couple of years
and because in those in those days like
there was no internet people disappeared
and played in some local tournaments and
you you knew nothing of their progress
right and i thought okay maybe i was
wrong maybe he will actually just
disappear
and then he scored 10 and a half out of
11 in lloyd's bank and i thought ah
probably probably not then right
probably and for you uh alejandro when
you think about
in your history
juniors who made a splash and said i'm
here
i just want to announce myself who come
the names come to your mind
uh like in my age category slightly
below category it was magnus carlsen
faggiano
that's a nice generation by the way the
generation that's up here yeah i mean i
was a little bit older than them my
exact generation didn't have the splash
that uh the slightly younger generation
did
but i mean this was still pretty strong
junior tournaments when we had to be
mixed up together uh but i remember when
i was a little bit of the older
generation just a couple of years older
back then shakira madyarov was winning
the junior tournaments with like
humongous scores right right 10 out of
11 nine and a half out of
whatever a humongous scores so he was
obviously somebody that you're going to
look at like this guy's going to be good
soon
how about the current rapid chess
world champion uh
yeah i mean i'm a huge fan i think not
rebecca i mean but
it's not even in any kind of a minority
opinion we've just
we've just witnessed and like i covered
the olympia from start to finish and
right we started talking about ngb and
uzbekistan from day one because we
thought we didn't know how it would turn
out but from day one both me and peter
lecco were saying that these are the
teams to watch because you're just
potentially you're witnessing history in
the making exactly uh
but
i mean there was slight surprise in just
how well they were doing yeah but
honestly not that much i expected both
of them to be very much contenders for
in the fight for gold
uh and uh
yeah i mean when you see eight out of
eight you i don't think anybody i don't
think gesh himself expected to score
eight out of eight on board one in the
olympics but uh
yeah i very much expected both of those
teams to be extremely extremely in the
mix and uh that's that's what happened
again you're you're completely correct
magnus has uh well he's playing the song
bishop d5
and uh hans recognizing of course that
he should get his pawn to h4 before
essaying uh king e5 and he's done just
that
nothing to do
with his head in this hand and that's
probably
as bad a
a body posture i've seen on magnus
in ages i mean he's just like yeah this
is this is not great yeah yeah he's not
great he's not enjoying this and not at
all
no well he shouldn't
he shouldn't there's nothing there's
nothing enjoyable not at all about any
of this and he's
um he never really got out of the
opening uh
alejandro it was this kind of a strange
hybrid
a3 g3 bishop g2 nimzo indian
he didn't achieve anything and then he
played it poorly he had a couple of
chances to
equalize
but that was about it i mean hans was
always more or less in control in this
game
from start to finish and a couple of
chances that he gave magnus to come back
maybe transpose into a holdable end game
let's not even call it equal completely
holdable end game uh magnus didn't take
up all those precise moments and it was
just all hans in this tournament and not
a determined so far but in this game in
this game yeah
okay bishop d5 i'm assuming king e5 so
still wins but yeah sorry
h3 also wins but i will just play king
e5 here i don't exactly i don't really
want to touch my
h4 and g4 setup because it doesn't yeah
and there there we have it handshake
there we have it
wow what a result
guys
truly
wow i can just imagine the chat
going uh nuts at this point like uh
what are we what have we witnessed the
the sinkville cup what is it about the
sinkhole cup i mean guys uh
the fabi the streak uh the number of
decisive games the
the crazy games the good games uh
and now we have this yeah this is uh i
mean i mean he uh he played well in the
first two games he was on plus one could
have been on plus two exactly he was had
a very very good position against levon
but you still you still feel like your
first your first game with black against
magnus should not look like this exactly
you would you would assume
but you know things things work
differently in in hans universe you know
it's right
right
uh well
a a win that's our second win and that
leaves us with one remaining game and we
think that wesley is a favorite to win
this so we could be witnessing three
decisive games out of the five play
peter yeah today could be uh could be a
reasonably decisive i mean already we
have two and in a tournament as solid as
this one two out of five is uh pretty
decent but uh yeah wesley should be
favorite for uh to win this from here
with this you can even take on default
but then i guess the point is quincy you
want me to check and then bishop c4 and
you get pinned and you make sure yeah
i've been seeing queen g3 check your
three checkers maybe even a bit stronger
yeah yeah yeah
i mean this is actually not made right
no
yeah yeah
i'm not sure actually maybe maybe my
line was better
bishop c492 oh my god
maybe my life was better i actually i
completely blundered this but what was
your 25 in the end no your line is
better
your line is better
and that is q3 and then if i do what i
did i should take a draw with king h1
but here bishop c492 in a very very
beautiful position queen e5
and you can't i can't defend the knight
wow wow
and let's take a look at our current
standings uh after a very very eventful
round three with one game still
remaining peter
yeah two draws up top there a quiet one
on uh between shaq and mbl and a very
dramatic in a way game between linear
dominguez and yannick which could also
have been a decisive game today alireza
won a very very beautiful game against
ivan orion and we have just seen magnus
carlsen resign with the white pieces
against the american youngster
hans neiman
the first win for
[Music]
the black pieces in this tournament by
the way exactly
why it was on cruise control
i'm pretty sure my goodness oh my
goodness what a time what a time
i'm still a little bit of a kind of a
shock here uh yeah
yeah like i i jump right in aleadra your
thoughts please i mean this is like
that's history in the making right when
you see a junior player come up and beat
the world champion with the black pieces
that that one gets ingrained in your
brain yeah i mean like this does not
happen often magnus losing
with white
against somebody that's not 2700 guys it
happens very very rarely and it's not
that he blundered a piece and you know
once in a while that happens
he just got outplayed today yeah right
yeah this is this is the thing yeah he
he just consistently plays that game
worse than his opponent i think it's
right so it's the a way to describe it
you you do have the world champions
having these great attacking games where
they're sacrificing and they oops they
miss a tactic and
the guy who is losing the whole game
somehow magically wins the game and yeah
that was not today this wasn't one of
those not one of those moments this
wasn't one of those
uh because of the queen g3 uh what did
you think uh
uh wesley should do here did you like i
should do king two is a move yeah but it
can be met by queen e5 i think this is
why we played a7 a5 here as fabiano
because we want to
prevent queen takes a seven being a
check yeah so king ju2 you can play
queen e5 and the pawns still remain
somewhat difficult to pick up
queen d3 exists but the machine somehow
doesn't feel like it's as clear as all
that i don't know why really gosh it
seems right it seems very good but
apparently this is somewhat playable for
black people i mean it's an improvement
over some of the earlier so what did you
like best of all the therefore it's not
as clear as it was it's not as clear as
it was you you can there are technical
issues now for for
uh wesleyan he's also down to five
minutes but we do have uh hunts with
alejandro uh in the studio so yeah the
man of the hour
certainly the man of the hour two and a
half out of three a dream start for you
hans okay what's your opinion
it's not bad now he just he played quite
poorly so
uh
i didn't do anything special he just
went well okay i think i played quite
well but uh i was actually very
fortunate that this opening came on the
board and i looked at this today
and you you guessed this opening today i
didn't guess it but but some miracle i
had checked this today and it's like
it's
such such a ridiculous miracle that that
i i don't even remember why i checked it
i just
when i saw
i just remembered
h6 and everything after this and i have
no idea why i would check such a
ridiculous thing
but i checked it and uh i even knew that
the bishop b6 is uh
uh just uh very good
like it's so ridiculous that i checked
it but uh
so you you actually this morning had
this position yeah even farther
where did it stop well okay you should
play bishop f6
uh here in this position yeah well on a
different sub-variation it goes far
there so no let's see not rook d-1 this
is a mistake
so i knew this was a mistake so he could
play so bishop of six yeah queen of six
knight d2
queenie
queen b5 a6 queen b6 bishop g4
it was like
rook a1 i guess
and uh here there's a few moves
but i checked this today by a miracle
yeah you had this exact position even
further but uh i have to ask you come on
what what prompted you out of all the
variations to choose this one i don't
think that magnus has ever played this
before no he has he played against
wesley so in the longest classic 2018
all right but it wasn't the specific
variation he played um
he played uh
it was with um
he did not play with the a3
and uh okay there were so here okay
let's say you can play knight of three
right let's maybe dc4
yeah castles knight c6
queen a4 knight
well yeah
queen c2 and then bishop e7 is critical
to play e4 knight cb4
queen knight c before queen e2 knight
knight c3 cd3 and 93 black slightly
better but uh anyways he played that no
no he has it i was expecting he has a
tendency for for these types of weird
things
and um
considering how my repertoire in the
clash i expected something weird
and uh also there's a through there's a
game um
uh
chigav serrano
sharjah
what's up with a3 let's say let's say it
goes like
basically
they reached um
he played this eighth grade attack
versus the pawn and it was extremely
dangerous so i remembered this game
because i was there and i was watching
it i never even checked it so i was like
uh i was trying with the idea and um
even i played this g3 nimzo myself like
even five years ago so
it's not like maybe he should have
checked my white database to see how
familiar i would be but um
yeah a3 is just with takes in c5 it's
very concrete
and then uh
i think i vaguely remember after h6
i think even even a queen h4 might be a
move here
uh management right now yeah what does
it say what does engine say okay it's
not not here not bad
okay maybe i remember some queen h4 but
but yeah okay
after bishop e6 it's just quite
difficult but still i think i played
really well i was very happy you know i
had some great let's okay let's go i
want to enjoy it too
it's your show it's really it's really
nuanced you know like let's let's where
do we go uh just from bishop bishop b6
uh
of course yeah knight d8 95 and i was
very happy because ricky would now
rickshaw so it's very counterintuitive
right and there's okay there's a
critical line you know he was thinking
he's going to trick me but let's say red
d1 king d1 this is very critical uh okay
bishop d5 right yeah now okay let's say
1991 take take knight c4 a49 knight
snappy two right but okay so instead of
this he can okay when the pawn so so uh
he has a trick um let's go beginning of
variation okay where after bishop d5 you
can play king c2
and the point is after king c2 is let's
say knight c4 he wants to play knight d2
but there's not a three so first he
plays a4
let's go a little bit a4 then knight b6
then a5 then knight c4 then knight d2
ah so this is the little you know tricks
wasn't going to work but the interesting
yeah so we analyzed a different one okay
i'll show you that one because this one
uh instead of a4 he has knight e3 in
this position yeah but um
i think for him to play this oh take
some c4
yeah that's that's uh that's too much
that's way too much all right so you won
rook c8 which is definitely the best
move in the position yes and then 92
bishop b6 i just kept pressure and then
he went c4 yeah and then after this i
was yeah bishop c4 you know take take
yeah okay we can i'll tell you when to
stop yeah there was some critical moment
um
yeah
i was very happy with this f5 move on
move 26. i was very happy with this i
thought this was very critical
and then ricky eight e4 yeah so i could
tell that maybe okay it says 0.6 but
practically it felt so difficult and i
had a slight time match yeah g4 this is
the the big mistake that is a big
mistake and then i and then i
capitalized yeah perfectly
i wouldn't go that particularly really
there was a can can i yeah of course uh
we'll go g
i'll tell you that sassy did evaluate
this at zero zero so really yes but you
know which is a mistake
so rook c5
bishop a2 it didn't like your knight c4
should i play instead i
i think he wanted to take on g4 because
it thinks that the end game after bishop
takes e4 is a draw
actually doesn't think it knows but it's
difficult of course
to say that bishop c4 as a draw is like
the most computer thing ever
like i guarantee you turn the engine off
if you ask a hundred grand masters yeah
bishop c4 working for ef5 rick a4 what
is the evaluation
like maybe 99 will say it's lost like
i don't even want you to explain it to
me yeah because then it will just i'll
lose my
let's keep your humanity so let's keep
going
like if you want to explain to me that
bishops before is a draw like
you know then then you should just i'm
not a chess player anymore right because
like come on it's like come on like
bishop c okay let's just show it for a
second yeah okay you wanted to give
yourself c4 rook c4 ef5 rook a4 okay
like like this is the the classic thing
you get b5 you hold it then you go king
f6 like this is not the draw i don't
care what the computer says it's not a
drone all right i understand
okay so okay we can continue and then
after this so if you're saying that um
so so basically the basis of everything
is some you know
uh of of um knights four being your
stake is this is then it's the best move
in my opinion all right fair enough
better than the engine rook e7 in this
position f takes g4 yes and you had this
nice trick of rook d7 and e3 he could go
rogue d8 and then i play e3 as well yes
instead in this position
that was the that was the killer er yeah
you still it's the game going on no but
it's very difficult like it's not a it's
not like you can just uh
ricky too but it was always very close
but uh yeah yeah it was very close
rookie yeah i just wanted to
yeah i felt like practically was going
to be winning here so i just made a
repetition because objectively if i have
more time then i should be able to find
it if the wind's there then i should
repeat to have more time right because i
had more time
i could arguably not repeat
to to um
to press on the clock but i thought
there was no reason yeah so king f6 i
was very happy with what i did here so
bishop d5 yeah
would you would it surprise you to know
that this position is actually holdable
for white okay again you know you're
speaking we're speaking different
languages here
well let's take a look uh so bishop d5
was his choice what what else were you
expecting in this position well so
there's rick pick pp7 yeah but so so
here there are many there are some
nuances yeah so first there is
there's a two moves knight g5 and rig d2
correct so rook d2 i thought was very
nice
and at this moment okay let's first
check the ng5 because i want to show why
i didn't like it okay knight g5 yeah
bishop d5 knight h3 yeah bishop d5
actually does lose for white
well then okay
then i'm not then i played well
no you're not saying he didn't play well
you know
okay okay
but
yeah so this bishop d5 that is three
king f1 rick f2 king i evaluated this
it's very close but i thought it should
be winning this check and then rick
issue yes and then yes yes so i was like
okay if this is the winning then you
know
what to do
correct what's that
all right so but after bishop d5 you
definitely played perfectly in this
position yeah that's true yeah when did
you know for sure that you had it in the
back
actually in this position after rook d2
sorry i actually made a mistake g6 again
this rook end game is apparently
yeah i know zero zero
but
still
we're not communicating here
it's like a failed relationship you know
you're you're looking at it's not one
thing and i'm like i'm thinking about
the practical and you're just like you
know hard this is this is this is you
know that's why they put me in front of
the board
that's why you're they're playing
you know we're just not
you know if you tell me that
okay when i'm making decisions and i see
okay he can go for this no but actually
i wasn't even gonna go for the record
game let me correct you wreck four i
have knight g5
okay and then
and then king h5 and then you were going
for this okay this was the the idea
right yeah so this uh i don't know how
you're holding this because i go king h
where i go h5 then i have threats not h3
i have b5 pushing like
this should be lost no
it should be should be but should be
again again uh
sitting here with with white especially
yeah it's just you're and already he's
demoralized right exactly because uh you
know tell us about the body language of
the world champion at certain stages
like for example here after reaching mu
40 he actually didn't get up from the
board like he normally does he kept
himself on the board well you know he
has little ticks you know and i've
noticed that okay that's maybe
i should not use that word um he has
mannerisms
don't want to get cancelled here
mannerisms please thank god i said that
i corrected myself mannerisms so you
know when i've played him i noticed
sometimes when he wants to assert
dominant he cracks a little smile
and he wasn't cracking many smiles maybe
one or two and that made me feel very
good because i just again of course i
grew up watching him i grew up i've
watched all of his interviews and
and you know
and he said once an interview that
he spent more than 10 minutes on the
move that's a very bad sign and he did
that a lot this game so that like that
boosted my confidence but i think okay
even if there's a draw yes
i think he's just so demoralized because
he's losing to such an idiot like me you
know it's just
it must be embarrassing for the world
champion to lose to me i
feel bad for him how do you see yourself
you're two and a half out of three in
the sink field cup you consider yourself
a top player are you saying that if you
don't win this tournament
it's an issue
do i have a full point or a half point
lead i believe that depends on how
wesley does right win
he well we haven't checked in a while
i'll just update real quick you know
what it's a mess i'm not going to call
it either way oh wow that's ridiculous
yeah mg6 will move
yeah but it's been like that for a while
like fabi has been on the thread yeah um
so let's say that they draw and you have
a full point lead yeah
but still you know i'm of course uh i
believe that um
especially these three games have
encapsulated my strength and potential
as a player but you should know that i'm
still uh i'm still improving i'm still
learning and uh it's it's you don't
become world champion in one day it's
it's a gradual uh process and i'm i'm
aware of of that it's it's you know this
chess thing is is a very long marathon
that's what's going to take a very long
time so if i don't win this tournament
okay who cares uh the goal is not okay
of course winning tournaments but um the
eventual goal is to improve you know
chess and become world champion because
in my opinion i see it's sort of black
and white for me right
you know i see a lot of players who have
been top 10 for very long in their
career and
you know they're happy you know with
cashing in but for me it's
top 10 or all it doesn't really mean
much uh i think in chess uh
the striving to be the greatest is is is
for me the motivation of course it's a
long way to go but
uh to to answer a question in a shorter
way
of course i would like to win the
tournament if i don't win the tournament
it happens but
again the goal is to play good chess and
i'm doing that so far russell janov
mentioned in another broadcast that some
of these players
rating hasn't caught up to the juniors
and these players are not as strong as
they used to be in your opinion do you
think this top 10 is currently overrated
compared to the juniors i wouldn't well
you know
overrated is uh is is you could also say
they're underrated right so it goes both
ways so i would currently say that
they're a group of let's say you know
maybe you can even say 10 of the
greatest
of very strong junior players including
myself maybe 10 bit much but i will say
that the the structure of um
the the tournament system is is in a way
that it
is difficult for um players to to reach
the elite of chess um
because you have a lot of these open
tournaments you know for me i took the
path right i was a year and a half ago
24 80. then life's great you can just
play any tournament you know i was
playing like gm round robins you know
and then okay i reached 2600 then i won
every single open there was then i
reached 26.50 and then it was already
difficult you know i had to try and get
the round robin invitation i had to try
and play the strong opens and even then
it was it was difficult now obviously
i'm very thankful to have the
opportunity to play syncful cup u.s
championship this is great right so with
these tournament opportunities i thought
thankfully the single chessboard
provides it's possible but not all top
junior players have these opportunities
so in my opinion if things were
restructured then the gap but it is very
clear that
the top 10 players in my opinion are
first of all they're the age is getting
quite high and they i don't feel the
same motivation in the fire um the
younger players have but it's not to say
that they're better than them
but we should look for ways to balance
um
opportunities
um
like even for me to get this invite is
is is perfect right yes if i didn't get
this invite i'd be going playing some
league
for like you know some ridiculous amount
of money and paying me on flight it's
like
in terms of chess there's a
there's a gap it's like you know the
rich not the rich get richer it's like
all the top players
get their invites it's not like they're
bad or anything it's just that um
there are some players who i believe
have tremendous potential who just don't
get the opportunities and is that what
we saw at the olympia yeah yeah the
olympia had certainly uh reflected that
with like uh er geisse obrusiotaro of
kuka showed great results and uh that's
probably the one event where um they get
to actually play the top players right
so i guess in this regard uh this
tournament is showing you know i've been
winning every single tournament i've
played in um
now i get the chance to play them and
it's showing you know
i'm i'm not there's i'm i'm
i'm not bad at this game you know so so
uh
this these opportunities are important
but i think the grand chester is great
in general right uh
st louis without saint louis chess would
be a complete joke in my opinion you
know so yeah well uh gonna bring in
peter and yasser do you guys have any
questions here for hans we're not worthy
[Laughter]
i was specifically described as being
not worthy as well so i uh what
oh peter you're great
but yeah i mean it's a we could listen
with this for hours but we do have a
game going on but you think wesley wins
this
this is the current position yeah and
that h6 is
should be played quickly not quickly but
he has like 10 minutes no oh three and
that's the only move nature is the only
movable he's sort of forced to find it
right yes he's already repeated twice so
you can't you sort of think like uh how
do i make a threat
and then the only move to make a threat
is
so you know he'll find it he'll find it
and not nice yeah the interesting point
is not h6 let me clarify i don't want
this be negatively towards his players
it's just sort of tradition traditions
right but uh eventually i think the top
players do break through that's for sure
like if you're a strong player if you're
really good eventually you're going to
be top 10 player right but um
it's chess is a difficult profession and
um
but i'm just thankful for the
opportunity so i can't really complain
right because i'm getting i've gotten
some very fortunate invitations this one
is like
if i didn't have this opportunity then
who knows how long it would take me to
to
show that i can be top players right
because u.s championship maybe i play
top guys but when can i ever play magnus
carlsen right right
so this is a gift yeah not a gift but
it's it's true i'm very very thankful uh
for this opportunity
you've crossed only 700 for you it was a
given that it was going to happen very
soon oh i did yeah yes forgot about that
i guess that explained that answers my
question
that's okay but uh it's only the
beginning
only the beginning
hans thank you for joining us candid as
always congratulations on your
performance so far definitely a big day
for you beating the world champion with
the black pieces thank you for joining
us thank you and again uh hans our uh
congratulations
good luck uh for the rest of the
tournament knight h6 on the board on the
board and wesley
uh looks like he's in the driver's cpu
yeah as as han said you you just come
there by the process of elimination g4
was hanging when you took into account
was actually made in two threads exactly
that was very serious life sort of
forces you to play knight h6 and then
you also realize it creates a threat of
knight that queen f7 made moves so uh
yeah five is now uh pretty much uh
pretty much busted you have to take on
g4
so as not to just get made mated
completely and then after knight g4 my
big question is uh knight forward kwid
g4 machine for some reason goes knight
g4 i think quincy sorry cringy for maybe
queen f1 check is a bit awkward
but then
g4 queen f1 jack maybe yeah and then i
will play i will find a good version of
i'll play g2 like queenie one check
maybe first and then d2
so i would uh put it somewhere
yeah put it somewhere and then close
close close i don't know where what is
close well this actually might be my
name
but yeah this this gets a bit weird
right with the pawn on g2
but also after knight g4
i'm wondering the engine doesn't even
play g2 in this position for some reason
and i'm wondering why yeah because maybe
with 95 queen h5 check i was kind of
confused by this because i saw on my
screen that the engine was playing queen
of three queen takes f4 which never ever
saves the game because we can just take
on d3 and right and then yeah like you
you might as well resign if this is your
best play exactly like you there's zero
checks here you might as well resign
right so like in practical terms you
play knight takes g4 g2 okay in
particular against two minutes exactly
and you ask the question uh
and apparently the answer is very simple
i guess it's maybe queen d a check right
you you you get to give a check with the
knight and then you will win right
well i'm trying to avoid allowing a move
like 95 which
yeah
once again for me i've been
while while hans was talking i didn't
really want to interrupt and i was
watching this and i thought we get here
i understand why this is probably
winning but i haven't found it yet like
it's been five minutes i have i still
haven't nailed down the answer it's only
f5
it's only f5 it's only a five on the f5
wow good luck
yeah on dominance here good luck good
luck allowing d1 queen
[Laughter]
yeah
wow i still don't understand why this is
made to be honest wow uh d1 and then
what exactly like
f6 king of seven like do we want to lose
or
king e6
i'm kind of escaping here you know i'm
d5 is
quite near well i do have a fork of your
queen yeah but that's not winning like
that's probably just a draw right king
of five also exists king of five also
exists yeah and then i will take one of
six in the air like i'm not losing this
position i'm kind of aggrieved i'm not
winning this position
i'm definitely not losing this position
this is so bizarre like
and yeah we do expect bishop takes g4
yeah i'm still having trouble
understanding why queen g4 but knight g4
you know let's task tricks
we're just tired guys
no no king has to go to g7 so you don't
get no you have to pull it on g7
otherwise 95 check will when yeah i
agreed yeah so king seven f5 and if you
play g1 check queen f6 that's mate
and i i just didn't see king g8 knight
h6 queen g6 knight f7
yeah it's been it's been a long day
this is not this is not as difficult as
all that
true
it has been a long day but a historic
day too as uh hans niemann
puts his signature on these first three
rounds and dare i say it i mean he could
easily have won that game against lavon
lavonne
came on interviewed with you alejandro
and said i had a tough day against
hounds nemo and he was very happy he
saved that game he will be even happier
now he'll be even happier
[Laughter]
no bobby fisher records for
these junior players uh
setting up a kind of a nice trap well
not a very difficult one if the king
moves forward uh you can start trading
queens on e7 because of how far advanced
the the passer is but of course nobody
goes king h4 he played king king g3
already
indeed he did yeah so uh king g3 and now
after queen f3 check you can play uh
king upwards i'm pretty sure five he
wants to play queen d5
that's damn it yeah that's his that's
his intention here they reach move 60 so
they get new scoresheets
but not more time yeah but this looks
like queen c8 followed by knight of five
is which is a dream come true
or thereabouts yeah we get to bring our
knight back into the game with check
which was
just completely winning yeah just you
actually win the queen it's not true
yeah king g7 knight the five king of
seven sorry uh from this position queen
f2 and yeah he's playing f2 okay no
queen f2 finish together but then we go
forward and uh interposing g5 and knight
the five for instance
d5 you'll have to play queen c5 check we
go knight of five yeah this never ever
had a beautiful
construction everything's in harmony
suddenly this this never ever holds
you you like
once again for wesley so uh and the
whole gct uh tour
uh
very very important victory if it comes
to that and it will be our third win out
of the five that we had
you you mentioned the drama with lanier
could have been maybe a very very uh
bloody day and uh
well um
uh
i i i don't know about yourself but uh
your reaction to the interview great
entertainment absolutely yeah he is he's
fantastic so he makes a he makes a ton
of sense you know
behind the like a lot of the opinions
appear to be very well thought out and i
agree with much of it
uh on like on the subject of young
players needing specialists yeah and and
uh
that resonated loudly absolutely uh and
i think we're watching uh
like it would be extremely silly to deny
that you know the current generation is
here and they just need
not even time necessarily they just need
opportunities to play against the top
players to just
illustrate just how good they have
gotten over the past couple of years
when a lot of people were not as visible
due to the nature of the chess world
over during the pandemic
but yeah a lot of it a lot of it makes a
ton of sense and uh also the the
deliveries
the delivery is to to die for you
it's special uh on that note of
opportunity
it really that 128 player knockout
uh that's like along with an olympiad an
opportunity for the juniors to really
make uh their mark
and i
i have to say i think he's right there's
just for these junior players they just
need more of these opportunities
absolutely and uh it's it's very good
that as he's saying and the fact that
the the club and the the grandchild
story in general provides these wild
cards for promising players exactly um
does does afford us this luxury of you
know watching someone like hans uh play
against the rest of the world and
demonstrate just how good he's gotten
this is a very beautiful mate by the way
uh
you played bishop and now 96 after king
of seven you go 96 and if the king runs
towards send towards the center it gets
very geometrically mated by a five
and then queen of six
not yeah that's green f6 yeah sorry that
will actually make the win somewhat
tricky yeah but queen f6 is pretty good
that's a nice one
no running for you no running away for a
very a very nice construction here and
uh not one you see
very often yeah and we run the other way
after king g7 something has to win like
queen e7
uh king g8 i think the the yeah king h6
is what i like here right
this is this is what you this is what
you like to do yeah just a little
tribute to nigel
oh
as of course you're referring to the
nigel short versus
96 hasn't been played yet by the way
he's played q7 check but he'll he'll
repeat and then he'll find it i mean
it's a
um even on two minutes uh you know he is
the the consummate professional there
wesley repeating a couple of times to
get a minute
right on the clock
jump in alejandro your thoughts of the
interview you just conducted
i mean
i was there guys i know yeah very i mean
he's a candid person he's a candid
character and he just likes to speak his
mind and
in this case it's clear
i think a lot of people have been
talking about it for months like who are
these juniors and why are they kicking
so much but when we saw the olympia well
that was an opportunity as you mentioned
yes sir yeah and they stepped up they
certainly did that india team b
uh was thrilling actually to watch them
they were playing against all of these
uh veteran teams whether it be armenia
whether it be the united states
uh
yeah they they they fought really really
hard i'm seeing some
signing
what happened it's probably claiming
there's no three-fold no what's
happening here i'm s i bet i didn't see
a knight d7
is he claiming a three-fold
this is
no this is only a second time i mean no
there is no this is not a threefold the
king has only just arrived on g5 and
it's only only a second time
well
yeah that's not a threefold
one two nope
that's not how it works even even queen
the seven king of f8 is not a three-fold
yet no
but uh because the arbiters are gonna
actually no no queen seven king of eight
would be a draw actually
yeah but wesley wasn't yeah wesley knows
that he wesley will not play queen this
show and i think chris byrd is doing
what you're supposed to be doing on an
incorrect claim you add two minutes to
your to the opponent's time i see
so is also um that be short of time
no he just thought
let me make the claim and see if it's
legit
i think people are just jaded by our six
and they get um
tired yeah i think uh we're tired we're
not even playing
and we do uh the game a flare is a new
and yeah he's reaching for his knife
before anything
let me not make a three move repetition
and there we have it that is in fact the
winning move as you expected
this is very funny egg queen e7 check
bishop f7 check
knight five check
that's a commercial yeah that's the
sequence that uh you don't see very
often this is very very comical but yeah
yeah so again this is a queen e7 check i
remember these pepsi commercials where
it was
uh seven up the on pepsi i checked check
check nate it was the sequence that they
used in the commercial
check check
and then like the five and then yeah and
then we we shake hands queen of six
instead of queen in seven is also
winning but uh it's all a matter of
taste once you play king joseph
queen f6 also winning
oh you once one thing you shouldn't do
though is repeat knight to five here
because that would never step back
that way it feels like this is a second
repetition but it will tie in with the
previous repetition and then and then
the claim suddenly will become correct
so yeah repeating with knight five here
is
not advised
yeah you know i think i would probably
choose queen f6 and knight f5 personally
yeah i mean there's there's a lot here
which is very very winning
yeah that is also very very clearly the
end of game right
wow
i'll say it again and again
hans niemann leads the event with two
and a half out of three
one percent pursued by a bear
and
in the role
and who predicted
this outstanding yeah
extraordinary effort certainly not ugly
yeah i mean honestly when we thought
about hans niemann coming into this
tournament there was a possibility he
got squashed i mean his first exactly
super tournament that was a possibility
he did well
but i don't think anybody saw him play
uh these three monsters no no
this was this was not on any any bingo
card apart from maybe his right maybe it
wasn't his bingo card the way the way he
thinks about things maybe not so sure
about that even but wow wow he's making
uh believers
out of the people who've been watching
our show and thank you very much for
staying with us as we are winding down
this uh incredibly eventful round three
guys 27 chosen and by the way there's a
very sadistic way to win right now after
the queen of sangeet you can still go
9-5
still go knight f5 and just collect
everything oh no oh no it's a bit cruel
yeah i mean knight f5 fighting h6 put
him out of his music threatening mate
and then i i win win everything with
jacks yeah yeah king h6 of course is
what you play here now the only words to
avoid made i think is queen takes d6 so
he'll just receive yeah
wow
wow very exciting round uh and this is
the conclusion there is the question
goes to plus one five goes to minus one
west is in clear second i'm slightly
uh
i wanted to say that i'm slightly ahead
of the graphics and we always like to
pair this with the graphics right uh as
a kind of a spoiler for the standings
after round three uh hunts is on two and
a half out of three western two out of
three nobody else isn't plus right
including the world champion magnus
carlson drops back to 50
having been upended with the white
pieces
by hans niemann
wow absolutely yeah
we're just sitting here uh
stunned paying paying respects to what
we just witnessed yeah stunned uh
alejandra we're gonna be ending asking
you for final thoughts but uh this is uh
not
oh he didn't see a five he was going to
go for this this is this takes some
winning after queen takes f2 if our
viewers can follow the line uh wesley is
showing let me try that that one doesn't
actually win that cleanly it's all the
way further yeah it's it's further down
the road instead of bishop g to check
that line that we were showing much much
further
go ahead you mean i think yasser has got
it on his board yes yeah queen to seven
and uh move yeah
and what
are we saying
further yeah yeah they just discussed
bishop takes g2 bishop take g4 here and
wesley showed the line after knight g4
g2
where they showed the line queen g8
check king g7 and instead of f5 which
wins wester showed the line queen before
check king of f8 i would assume and then
knight of two which does not win which
might also win but after the knight of
two i can go queen takes f2
i mean you're welcome to this queen
ending if you want to play it like i
mean we know sometimes you like it's
just a draw actually like the engine
says it's a draw
so so wesley was sort of intending to
make a draw seemingly yeah yeah he would
he just completely he might have
uh at that point figured out f5 yeah i
mean like they get to that position just
three minutes he'll spend all of them
calculating so he probably actually
plays a five we're not i mean this is
the fact that he showed it on the board
doesn't mean he would necessarily play
it but that's what he showed intention
yeah but that was what he showed quindi
for check and knight of two here which
is as the engine and really not
surprisingly two against one queen
endings
are very very draw heavy exactly exactly
so
wow
yeah it's been a day it has been it's
been a day for the ages and uh yeah as
as the quote goes yeah captain yeah like
what a week captain it's monday it's not
even monday but yeah
labor day is coming
let's take a look at the results of a
very eventful
round three three decisive results out
of the five games could easily have been
four but this is as you said peter our
current standings yeah hans in the clear
lead here after three points with two
victories including one again with black
pisses against the world champion the
one we've just witnessed
wesley wins a very nice long with a very
very nice controlled game against
fabiano carano today alireza is back in
beckham 50 by beating uh leonardo in a
very very exciting game today
five players
yeah three more people are former people
and fifty percent right yeah five people
at fifty percent
and then three people on minus one uh
and yeah these are uh the pairings for
tomorrow magnus carlsen plays a second
game in a row with the white pieces uh
against an opponent who has beaten him
in the past a bunch of but not not many
have a couple of times certainly
including i think the victory which
broke is
a great three yes uh levolarian is white
against lunier dominguez uh hans is
white against arizona that's a 19 year
old yeah that's all right yeah that's
the one we want yeah you're usually the
one we want the youth
will play tomorrow
yannick plays against the player he
generally
has been known to struggle against
exactly wesley
has a very good score against uh jan and
bobby uh white against uh maximo
shirograph they've had some very very
exciting battles over the years
including that fantastic night off after
the restart of this exactly the classics
and as we get ready to close our show
we'll just tell you about the upcoming
events peter we've got uh three more to
go yeah once once this is over and this
is over either on the 11th or
potentially maybe on the 12th depending
on how the grandchester west endings go
then we have ultimate moves almost
immediately afterwards a kind of a
banter-heavy
very very fun community event here
exactly which everybody seems to enjoy
every year so i'm looking forward to
that
followed immediately by uh the 9 0x
showdown
for which we have might have some very
illustrious players coming into town to
play that including i believe wesley who
actually is the current world champion
in fisher uh random and then the u.s
champion and then rounding it off in
october by by the nationals yeah exactly
exactly national championships and uh
our congratulations of course to wesley
so
for his victory over uh fabi again a
very heavyweight matchup and uh
thinking guys getting him suited if you
will for
considering how long the game went we
probably shouldn't uh shouldn't torture
him too much but he won a very very nice
game so yeah i assume he will enjoy
telling us a little bit about it exactly
um i like that part too at the interview
with hans where he says well we'll we'll
go through the moves let me enjoy it
love you
you know how how the the computer engine
goes up and up yeah
the the the part i found the most
amusing was him sort of flat out
refusing to even discuss the the parts
where the rook endings were not lost
exactly like if you just go away i don't
care we're not coming
what we have here is a failure to
communicate to communicate exactly
although i feel that we are actually
kind of quoting different things right
because you're probably quoting in the
movie yeah cool
[Laughter]
nice nicely done
and uh yo
and uh wesley so again getting uh miked
up uh for
uh the end of again a very very very
eventful round and uh this one will be
well historic it will be remembered yeah
yes uh
we witnessed something special today for
sure absolutely absolutely
and uh away we go alejandro take it away
carly in clear second place wesley saw
you had a marathon game we're not going
to keep you here too long
[Laughter]
tell us some things you want to say
about the game no of course i'm very
pleased to to win because
if you push for what five five and a
half hours
the last thing you want is uh is a draw
after pushing so so hard and
using a lot of energy so i'm very
pleased uh
fabiano is obviously a great player and
he's one of the
he's probably the best prepared player
in the petrov
so i went for this quiet line uh which
worked surprisingly enough uh so on move
15 g5 was interesting
it seems like you were very well aware
of the position up to here you played
very quickly but g5 kind of struck you
yeah i actually prepared this line the
olympia so i was thinking to play the
better off and one of my opponents
placed this line with white
and i also played it in
uh rap or online rapid against cnn
bomniachi
that also work quite well so
yeah normally
so fabian has been playing correctly all
the way here
g5 is quite ambitious obviously black
has many moves
so knight after knight f5 he had
weakened his position a little bit but
also his knights were active and i
wasn't sure
what to play with knight on e4
but in the middle game he he sacrificed
up
yeah
one
impression p6 right well partly taking
was a mistake
yes i sacrificed upon like uh
uh my relief is that
his knight took like three moves to get
to e4 because i forced him to retreat
like normally in the petrol if we get
the knight on e4 right away right and
then
i took a point i thought i must be
better
but uh were you surprised they didn't
take it back
oh i thought i have knights before after
it takes right by the way i wasn't sure
ah so it's just slightly better it's
still a pawn right yeah i disappointed
black equalizers and queens no no he's
far from equalizing oh okay but the
other one you're just a problem at the
position
yeah so fabiano is a great player and he
plays four win with both colors
in
a better position or worse position
so i wasn't surprised when he played f5
i it looks playable and also we were
getting quite low on time
i probably didn't play the most accurate
moves like on all 26 i was thinking to
play c4
but i wasn't sure how good it
yeah i think is
play c4 maybe it's better
but uh in the game
i don't know he just went for an all-out
attack with h5 and wasn't sure what was
going on
but i was upon up and uh
uh he was almost regaining it but
fortunately i was able to keep some
pressure uh
just a few moves before the time control
moved forward yeah you eventually found
this really nice move knight h4 a little
bit later yeah like the queen end game i
wasn't sure if it was winning
i mean black has very good chances to
draw on that and i thought this knight
h4 okay one second while we got here
micked up again
i think yeah i thought with the
with his past one on on these four
blackouts very good chances to hold yeah
so it's calculating age four and i
thought it was my last chance to win so
i decided to seize it
right but um yeah after
yeah because the problem is bishop is
well centralized so i wasn't sure what
was happening probably he missed a draw
at some point on move 52
52 let's see right here with the move
king g6 strong engine
yeah the the the stronger energies think
they're winning anyway so even on move
51 even on yeah uh maybe yeah yeah yeah
after queen e2 f4 yeah you are winning
in this position according to the
stronger engines
tell us a little bit about that line
that you were calculating near the end
with him
i hear this bishop oh yeah
i thought bishop takes g4 was enough for
a draw but apparently it isn't no what
did you calculate here so
knight takes yes
d2 yes
win the 8th king
g7 oh and i didn't see f5 you didn't see
f5 but we thought that if you got to
this position you might see it i'm going
to play queen d4 knight f2 but why does
f5 win so f5 f6 is made if you're
allowed queen f6 is made
yeah you can see that
why is it meat come on
what okay so queen f6 king of seven
and then how do you check winner fix ah
king h7 oh i didn't see queen of six oh
king j8986 yes yeah yeah yeah that's the
trick knight h6 on mate oh okay
difficult no yeah it's not easy when you
have two minutes on the clock absolutely
not but he didn't go for that and you uh
eventually won that quite smoothly yeah
queen and it's very dangerous combo
combination yes unlike what yasser
thinks so tell us
tell us a little bit well i have to ask
hans demon oh yeah
thoughts the shop of the tournament well
i was watching his games in miami they
they call him
the chess villain
[Laughter]
basically he learned a lot from losing
all his matches in miami i mean he's
chess villain strikes again i mean if i
played him i played with him before in
the process like we were teammates uh
back then he was only 24 60.
but uh
he's improved a lot he's
very determined he's very angry at
himself and his opponents and he works
hard so
uh he's
yeah he's got he's got a bright future
it's nice to know that we have very
strong juniors here in the united states
and not only in india or uzbekistan
so we have we have hans niemann it's a
good change we also have sevilla and
jeffrey so yeah definitely a promising
future it was a long day wesley we're to
let you go thank you for joining us here
and good luck the rest of the tournament
thank you man
thank you thanks to wesley wesley and
thanks to our viewers absolutely
hopefully stuck stuck with us through
you know thinking yes
here yes everybody do
let your friends know where you're
hanging out thank you very much for
sharing your day with us do so tomorrow
we'll be back same time same channel for
round four of a very very eventful 2022
sinkhole cup goodnight everyone until
then
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited